and
welcome to the criminal justice and
public safety hearings for wednesday 2 9
22.
we're going to start by asking
representative marshton the leaders in
the pledge of allegiance
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
indivisible with
thank you and with that i am going to go
ahead and open the public hearing on hp
1540 fn
no
public hearings
the committee now calls representative
welch to introduce house bill 1540.
my name is david a waltz i represent
rockingham district 13.
house bill 1540
i was asked to put it in it's not my
bill
but
we also have an amendment to it
so i suspect
that
the people following me will explain the
bill in more detail
essentially what it does
it allows for
actually
calls for recording
interrogations in the police station
they're arrested
they record the interrogation
and uh
never having been arrested before i
suspect it might be a good thing
so i'll let the people behind me
explain the bill
the committee now calls buzz share
it's better when
i'm off
um
good morning uh
mr chair members of the committee my
name is both sher i am a
both a police commissioner in the town
of portsmouth the city of portsmouth and
a law professor at unh law as always the
opinions i expressed today are solely
mine and not those of unh unh school of
law or the portsmouth police commission
uh this is a bill that we've uh
the original bill we had a hearing on uh
a week or so ago
and um there were some
concerns raised by members of the
committee
and we have
sought to address those concerns
by
helping
representative welch
write the amendment so i'll address the
changes to the amendment
the first
is in
i don't have the line by line but in the
definition
of custodial interrogation
no still don't have it um i
we added the language associated
with an arrest
uh or detention
um and in the definition of law
enforcement officer we added uh in line
with the concerns expressed by
the representative from the department
of corrections uh lynn cusack uh
a probation officer a parole officer or
a corrections officer
or a security officer employed by the
educational institution who has the
power to detain an individual
i believe representative abbas felt the
definition of the security officer
employed by an educational institution
was to bra broad so he added the
who has the power to detain an
individual
and uh attorney cusack had concerns
about
the ambiguity and lack of clarity
relating to probation officers pearl
officers and corrections officers so we
added that language in there too
and
if you combine that language with the
added language in custodial
interrogation that is associated with an
arrest or detention it does not include
corrections officers who are just
engaging in uh investigation for
possible
internal disciplinary proceedings which
is a concern that
attorney cusack had
and then if you go to uh
594-a colon 4
we've added the language again
to
account for the concerns of attorney
cusack
likewise the provisions of 494 a3 shall
not apply to administrative disciplinary
hearings in a state correctional
facility
or for parole violators not charged with
a new offense so i think those address
the concerns that attorney cusack raised
and my understanding is there is an
exchange
between
attorney cusack
and
susan pachell
who has been working with the national
innocence project uh the new england
instance project and myself on this and
she approved of these um
my understanding is she approved of
these changes
and finally uh in 594 a
five
there was concern expressed by several
members of the committee about somebody
who didn't want a suspect who was about
to be questioned who didn't want to be
recorded
and
we
added an exception for somebody who
didn't want to be recorded so the police
would not
be
violating
these provisions if the person asked not
to be recorded and and uh uh
wrote you know and and that was captured
in a written document um
the final thing i would address for the
committee i know i've heard some
concern expressed about this possibly
being an unfunded mandate
um
uh as a as any law professor should i
have at least two answers for that
question
uh number one is uh
there's probably not a uh police
department even the smallest of police
departments whose mem who has at least
doesn't have at least one member who has
uh an iphone or a smartphone of some
sort so they are that they're not gonna
have to
go out and buy massive amounts of
cameras number one number two and more
importantly this provision allows for
uh if you look at the definition of
electronic recording which is required
it says an audio recording or an audio
and video recording so it doesn't need
to be a video recording you know
my personal preference is that's better
but uh there's a little give in this
statute so
every police department already has
equipment to tape uh these uh
make audio tapes of this and
as we heard from for example uh paul
halverson the merrimack county attorney
his belief is virtually all the police
departments in his jurisdiction already
do this
so uh
that's my explanation of the uh
amendment uh more than willing to answer
any questions
i i have a question um
regarding what we just you just
discussed the unfunded mandate portion
of it um
given assuming arguendo that everybody
has some type of a way to to record
i'm more concerned with the the storage
and retention
requirements and um
the possible costs that could
put on to a police department in the
manpower as far as you know
managing this because it could be quite
voluminous
and so could you speak to that yes um
uh
most police departments that i'm aware
of already have storage capability
number one hard you know
a server or the appropriate uh hardware
to do that
um and you know there's not police
departments don't obtain that many
confessions that would fall under this
uh number one number two
because of that most police departments
have already solved the storage problem
uh number three if they do an audio
recording you know that storage issue is
just
uh is a lot simpler
and uh cloud storage is uh
is a mechanism that is
far far cheaper um and my guess is
virtually every police department
uh maybe short of you know a one officer
department has a cloud storage
capability uh that uh at least i think
of of at least my belief with you know
my iphone
i don't pay any extra for the cloud
storage uh up to a certain limit
um and for just to follow up if
how would that
cloud storage from a from a privacy
perspective
guarantee that a person's information
from an interrogation
is protected
my understanding is every police
department this comes from my recent
experience
in the portsmouth police commission
where i had to take a
loosely called a security test before i
could have access to data
uh the
virtually every police department that
i'm aware of has procedures in place now
given uh a lot a lot that is occurring
virtually rather than uh in hard copy
they already have uh privacy uh
confidentiality regulations in place so
that not just anybody can access it you
know they they try to make it
understanding that in the end everything
is hackable
um
uh they they do what they have to do
what they can in order
to to
have access to
for example fbi data so that's imposed
uh
by the requirements of fbi security
so i think it's it's a problem it's a
legitimate concern but i think it's a
problem most
police departments are dealing with
good representative testament thank you
thank you for taking my question
is there any issue with
this interrogation or this interview
being challenged
and not standing up to all of
the rigors of
of
either confidentiality or was this at
the right time right place
is it tagged is it is it a
a valid
copy of something i mean
what kind of issues are we getting into
um
minimal issues actually because most the
police departments already pay attention
to
what they need to do
to the technical legal term is
authenticate
the copy of the confession
in order to get it admitted into court
they do that with a written confession
or if they they already
authentication requirements which is
really a
fancy word for
is what you're showing me in court what
you just testified to
so that's procedure that they already
have well developed
i just one more question occurred to me
um could you speak to the record
retention requirements for a recording
i'm also thinking not only of
confessions but of possible exculpatory
evidence that may be available to a
defense attorney in one of these
recordings um how could we ensure that
that i want to understand how that has
to be held and recorded and turned over
during discovery well uh it has to be
held
and
they have to turn over excludatory
evidence whether it's in the recorded
confession or in some other way
and
i am not other than police departments
who for one reason or another screwed up
most of way most often unintentionally
every police department i know holds on
to evidence in a case until the case is
completely over
in terms of some evidence uh as this
committee saw last year in the the
amendments to the post-conviction dna
statute that this committee passed and
got
uh made its way all through and was
signed by the governor there are
depending on the type of evidence there
are
requirements that the evidence in a case
be held for
a particular length of time
even after the conviction is resolved
in case there is for example
biological evidence that has
not been tested in the case itself
and
the individual asserts their innocence
after the conviction
and
there are already provisions in place in
that post-conviction dna statute for
retention for a period of time
representative representative panalacas
thank you mr chairman i just i wanted to
know if the amendment
replaces the whole bill
the the amendment makes
additions to i think they're all
additions to the the original 15 hv 1540
i don't believe it replaces anything but
it adds language that
tends to the concerns
thank you
thank you mr j thanks for taking my
question does the bill have a provision
to provide a copy of the interrogation
to the detainee
uh not the detainee
right after it's taken
but but if uh
it it has it will have to be provided as
a part of discovering uh the natural
process of discovery
follow-up
in the interest of preserving the actual
data wouldn't it make sense to have a
copy made at that point of time to
ensure that it's not
minimally in any manner
theoretically yes
i would say
that said
it would be
it's a balance between how difficult it
is in the moment after the confession is
taken with somebody who may well be
sitting in jail and getting them an
audio or
audio and vid video copy of it
uh
and uh what might become of that in that
person's hands and you balance that
against the interest in
making sure the person has a copy of the
original
to go back to an earlier question i
think that's what the
authentication process is about
um
it will the confession will always be
the copy of the confession audio or
audio and video will always be provided
to the defense attorney in the case
and
they will have the opportunity
you know if they show it to their client
or have a client listen to it and the
client said i never said that you know
that's not me on there or you know they
left something out there um
and and and
if they can make an argument that that's
a problem then it will fail to be
authenticated
um so there's a process in place so
you know in theory yeah it'd be great to
give the person a copy but um
you balance that with what uh to use the
formal legal term what a pain in the
neck it would be
to get a copy to the suspect right after
the interrogation
um uh i think
it's
at least okay
to wait until
the
the suspect's attorney gets a copy
through discovery
i'm similan
hi
how are you good how are you
so you know what uh mr professor um as
you as you know that the the air the law
in this area on custodial interrogation
has has been pretty well developed
constitutionally by case law
and i guess sometimes
i'm concerned
about the definition of custodial
interrogation in that
it it at least is susceptible to a
construction that would go beyond
what what i think we
traditionally think of as custodial
interrogation so my question is this
what if we change the definition to read
as follows
custodial interrogation means express
questioning while under arrest or other
actions or words by a law enforcement
officer which are reasonably likely to
elicit an incriminating response from an
individual and which occurs
when a reasonable individual in the same
circumstances would consider himself or
herself under arrest or the functional
equivalent of arrest
my concern with that is i i understand
representative lynn what you're asking
about
the problem with just saying associated
with arrest is
there's any number as i i know you know
there's any number of uh
circumstances
in which somebody is in custody but
hasn't been arrested
the the
the the term arrest is a fourth
amendment term it rises out of the
fourth amendment and it's defined by
that body of fourth amendment case law
whereas the term custody is a fifth
amendment term
created essentially for the purpose of
uh
implementation of the miranda warnings
so to just say arrest it then it that
it
you know
what i would say that the correct way to
say it means expressed questioning
associated with custody
you know um
it um
well but isn't that may it follow
follow-up
but it's i mean the thing i'm concerned
about particularly with your reference
to the word detention is
i mean when a police officer pulls
somebody over makes a traffic stop the
person is detained they can't agree they
can't leave but that's not custody
but
well i guess but but you talk about
detention here and that's so that's i
guess that's part of as i understand the
law it's you either have to be formally
under arrest
or you have to be in the situation of
the functional equivalent of arrest yes
um now uh i i just if we're yeah i agree
with you on the issue of detention you
know this language was initially put in
here to
distinguish those
circumstances when a corrections officer
or a parole officer
is doing interrogation
and so
we didn't pay attention as good
attention as we should have to this
issue
my preference would be to just put that
definition in there that is associated
with a formal arrest you know the
definition of of custody a formal arrest
or a restraint on on freedom uh uh
uh equivalent to that of a form of an
arrest okay yeah i'm fine with putting
that language in there uh i think it it
it cures the problem
thank you
i um the committee appreciates that um
fine legal debate um
the committee is all welcome to come to
my class on friday which we'll talk
about i am um from uh from a different
perspective um
from my um remembrance of my days in the
police academy
wouldn't it be better instead of saying
would consider themselves in custody
to say
would where a reasonable person would
consider themselves not free to leave
no
your microphone
hopefully uh representative lin will
back me up on this but
not free to leave
is the definition of detention
not free to leave does not mean you are
in custody it has to be a restraint
on freedom that is the functional
equivalent of an arrest whether they've
been told they're under arrest or not so
not free to leave would bring us back to
the
detention under the law does not count
as custody and not free to leave is the
test if somebody's detained
okay thank you
thank you
i was listening to your your testimony
and i'm not sure if i heard you clearly
but i thought i heard you say audio or
video in one of your sentences yes
okay could i could i just follow up then
in line 23
in the amendment when it says by audio
and video
are we talking the same thing um if you
read the beginning of that it says means
an audio recording or audio and video
so you can do an audio recording but if
you do a video recording there's got to
be an audio component to it also
there'd be no further questions again
sincerely thank you for your testimony
thank you oh hold on stand by oh i
didn't see you go ahead represent him
phrase this but we're now in to the
video age where
where we're
requiring officers to wear
body cams and when they're
dealing with people
but you
are saying that somebody can say i don't
want to be recorded and has to put in
writing
so what happens to the uh
body cams the uh
uh two things one
not all police departments have body
games yet
certainly
for example portsmouth doesn't in spite
of some people's best efforts
um
number two
if they would have to turn off the body
cam
during a recording
of a confession
during a confession
if the individual who would be recorded
doesn't want to be recorded under the
provisions of this
amendment
so they would have to turn the body cam
off and all the body cam regulations and
policies i've seen
uh allow for a request
within certain limits to not have a uh
a conversation with the police recorded
and this certainly this circumstance
would certainly fall within that
follow-up
so i could
also say playing devil's advocate so if
that's actually my job well i'm going to
try it so basically
anybody that
reads this law could go to the last line
and say
when they're being
interviewed or interrogated
i don't want to be recorded and so be
useless for the police departments to
have video and audio of everybody that's
being interviewed or
decides to invoke that
requirement
yes it would be but um i have to say you
know god knows i don't have any data on
this but
i would be stunned if that was everybody
chose not to be recorded the huge
majority of suspects
are
would want the recording because they
tend to be in the first instance very
suspicious of the police and they would
see this as more of a protection
than as something that would cause them
trouble
there will be exceptions and that's fine
my understanding it from talking with
the uh national innocence project is
that there has uh that that has not
happened in jurisdictions i think
there's 26 states now that have some
version of this provision
they have uh that has not been what has
happened
representative
yes uh thank you for taking my question
uh
on the just one other question on the in
the air on the in the section of the
bill that establishes the exclusionary
rule there's there's a provision if i if
i recall correctly that says if you
if you don't record
if you interrogate and you don't record
and then
then on a second round of interrogation
you do record that that you it's the
exclusionary rule still applies and this
is whether it's a sort of
cat out of the bag and i understand that
my question is this
should there be some language in that
section
that
limits it
to the same subject matter in other
words what i'm thinking about is suppose
the police
you know they arrest somebody
they interrogate the person and they
don't record it
and
then subsequent to that they get some
information about a new crime another
crime that they had not asked about and
maybe you know for example maybe they
interrogate somebody on
some
drug offense or a minor theft or
something like that and then they get
some evidence that the person let's say
was involved in a homicide
now they want to you know now they
with a recording they
interrogate him on the homicide would
would that be precluded
from admissibility under your
under the way the bill's drafted now and
if so should the should there be some
language that says it shouldn't be
well if they didn't record the as i
understand sequence
interrogation on the drug offense no
recording interrogation on the homicide
recording right
um the homicide recording will be
admissible under this the the drug
offense uh will not be admissible
uh in uh
because they didn't follow this law and
there's and there's unless the the the
suspect said
i don't want this recorded you know and
met the provisions of that exception but
short of that
the if the the drug interrogation was
not recorded it's a violation of the law
and there's no real logical reason it
should be accepted out of this
um you know i i
and number two i think part of the gist
of your question and i apologize to the
rest of the committee because we're
going to descend into legal stuff um but
um you know that's the oregon versus
elstad uh sequence of cases about
consecutive confessions
um and um so
uh number two
number three
i don't um
well i'll leave it at that
i'm down to two now
okay
go while the getting is good
thank you
the committee now calls cynthia musso
i think that's the right button is i'm
cynthia musso i'm a staff attorney at
the new england innocence project i
appreciate you hearing my words today i
came primarily to be able to answer
questions but i did want to speak to a
couple of things that were raised and
just sort of to drive home the point
about the importance of this bill in
this case
i think it's important to know just a
little bit of background about me so
that i can explain sort of where some of
the things i'm going to say are coming
from which is that i was a public
defender in this state and in
massachusetts for almost a decade and
before that i actually clerked in the
trial courts actually judge lynn was
there briefly when i was there
as well
um
what i wanted to talk about today is the
fact that
it is virtually something that we've
learned as time has moved on is how
prevalent uh false confessions can be
it's not something that's necessarily
intuitive it's not something that
necessarily sits with everybody you
always think to yourself that you would
never confess to something that you
didn't do but the reality is is that the
data that we have from false confession
shows us that in almost a third of the
confessions with dna exonerations
there's been a false confession in those
cases a third meaning almost one out of
three of those cases where dna proves
you couldn't have done it there was a
confession from somebody that's actually
a fairly concerning statistic it's
pretty high number and i i was very
surprised by that when i joined neep and
that was from a public defender who had
been in practice for a really long time
this bill is something that
it's almost virtually impossible for us
to determine whether something is a
false confession without having a
recording and that's not because the
police lie and it's not because our
clients lie it's because
people just have differing perceptions
of the same event you know they always
that classic maxim of there's your side
my side and the truth right it's just
hard to pull those things apart and the
subtleties of interrogation are
something that really need to be viewed
in person
it's really something that you have to
be able to see and hear to understand
and to pull apart
our experts when we consult with them on
these types of cases with false
confessions always ask for a recording
and it makes it essentially impossible
for them to give an opinion when there
isn't a recording in the case the only
thing you can tell is the substance of
the questions not anything about the
particular tone
the physical circumstances of the
interrogation that sometimes the state
of the of the person that's being
interrogated you can't tell that from a
recording you can't tell um if they're
tired if they're hungry if they're worn
out if they're
you know laying down on the table all of
those things are missing when you don't
have a recording it's a pretty common
sense bill so common sense that 30 other
states already have a recording bill in
place
and so it really has a lot of importance
for a fairly small
ask because the reality is is that so
much of new hampshire already does this
i know that because i practiced in
manchester which is one of the bigger
jurisdictions and there was never a case
where i didn't get a recording from
you know uh
a um
when we had like a confession case um
and the practical reality is is that
eliminated
litigation around that issue in court
because when you have the recording you
can you can check that out it it cuts
down on on coming to court and arguing
about those things
in terms of i heard a couple of comments
about um
sort of like a concern over like the
alteration of a recording potentially
um and i know we had a case in
massachusetts around a a recording being
altered actually by the police
department
and because of the way technology is we
were really able to pull that apart but
the reality was is this was a police
department that altered this recording
if we hadn't had that recording at all
right
we would never even have been able to
tell it was altered and the the version
of events
that was actually occurred was only
gonna ever gonna be what was testified
to we would never have been able to pull
that apart
um there is tech that we can use to try
and pull up alterations as well i hear
that concern that you raised i think
that's a really valued valid concern but
we do have ways of addressing that and i
think it is a logistics issue in the end
about providing recorded copies of
things
uh the other thing i wanted to speak
about was um
one of the issues that we've heard a
couple of times is sort of an issue
around the consent piece
and i mean i think the state is so
careful about uh consent and being
recorded right we have this wiretapping
statute in the state for a reason and
there are exceptions that are built into
that uh statute uh some of them are for
law enforcement but they still usually
require a warrant and so this is still
in compliance with that statute and
we're still
trying to make sure that that this
statute wouldn't supersede or override
that so there would still be a
wiretapping issue
if we even if that last this piece about
the the
the consent piece wasn't there this is
this is these are in compliance with
each other
so those are a couple of the issues i
wanted to address just to highlight a
couple of things and if anybody has any
questions i'm happy to take them
representative marston
thank you mr chairman for your
indulgence on me
my simple question i'm not 100 sure in
my mind are you in favor of the bill or
opposed to the bill
in favor
representative muse
yes thank you for taking my question um
and you may not be able to answer this
but
i would assume and i may be incorrect
that police standards and training has
some type of documentation around
standards for recording like this
if police are actually already doing it
do you know if something like that
exists
i don't think there's a requirement at
this time i'm not going to say i know
specifically uh that the answer to that
question i don't think there's a
requirement there may be a sort of the
suggested best practices but i don't
know that there's a requirement there
might be i know rep roy mentioned that
he would had gone to the academy so
maybe he would actually know the answer
to that question but i don't know
i think there's no requirement although
there may be a discussion for best
practices that was actually 30 years ago
in massachusetts
there ain't no further questions thank
you oh sorry representative true i
didn't see you back there
thank you thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question i
got a question on uh
you said one out of three confessions of
false confessions
how
how does the how does the recording
prevent that
because
if a guy is being if i'm being recorded
and i say yeah i did it
but i didn't how does that recording
play into it
that's a that's a good question so i
think the reality is is that what these
things have shown us over time is when
we have recordings we have records
and when we create a record we create
things that we can learn from so i think
the reality is is that there's been a
lot of police standards and training
that have actually changed as you said
30 years ago this was how things were
and things change over time so what
happens is when we have these records
first of all
with the uh remedy that we've put into
the statue it keeps things out of court
so it encourages police to engage in the
best practices and it shows the folks
that are being under arrest that
everything is is going to be recorded
and that they're you know they're
they're going to have to also be honest
about what's going on and i think what
ends up happening is we create sort of a
data set essentially that says this is
how here's the false confessions here's
the ones we know that are false because
of these dna exonerations and here's the
practices that we saw that were engaged
in during those interrogations and these
are practices that we shouldn't engage
in anymore that's how we've actually
learned over time
in the statistic that i cited the almost
one out of three that's how we learned
that some of the interrogation tactics
that were being used are not effective
in terms of generating truthful
confessions
so i think the reality is is that the
prevention is in the learning and it's
in the it's in the gathering and it's
also in the remedy that we've put in the
statute
representative
can i just ask one question they i
understand the
the
the section which i think makes sense in
section two of the bill that says if the
person says they don't
want to be recorded then then the record
doesn't have to occur
but i have some question about the the
provided the proviso that says provided
that this request is is preserved by
electronic recording or in a written
document because i i guess what i'm
concerned about is
what about the person you know you if
you say to somebody somebody says i
don't want to be recorded and you say ok
ok we won't record you then but just
sign this or just let me just record
this they may very well say
i'm not doing that either and so that
i mean that does seem to me to be a a
pretty big a pretty
big proviso that could undercut a lot of
what you're intending to get at
i think the reality is and and that
obviously is a concern i think the
question in the first instance you know
would it is essentially
i mean i agree with you i think those
are very those those would come hand in
hand right you don't want to be recorded
and you're not going to sign anything
like that would not surprise me that
somebody that would say one would say
the other
um i think the reality is is that uh
that would then be something that would
fall under the sort of generalized
exception which is like this is what
happened and i couldn't do it because
you know we have we have sort of a
catch-all
uh provision
i'm gonna have to scramble around to
find the exact number here
uh so it's just sort of the overcoming
the presumption of inadmissibility so
the reality is is that the statements
are
admissible under law they're proven by
clear and convincing evidence to have
been made voluntarily and they have a
reasonable justification for why they
didn't so i think the reality is it
would sort of be a catch all there for
that
just follow up thank you
i'm just wondering would it would an
acceptable alternative to this be
some kind of a provision that says
that if the person says i don't want to
be recorded
the police officer conducting the
interrogation
has to make
you know has to has to sort of make a
note of that and date and time it
immediately um and you know so that you
have you have at least some record
that's that that is contemporaneous that
the
person said i don't want to
you know i don't want to uh be recorded
or i don't want to give a written
statement or whatever i don't want to be
recorded i guess this
i actually think there was when we were
originally speaking about this i think
there was a discussion that if like in
this catch-all for example which is what
i'm saying covers it that there would be
sort of a written
uh
you know like contemporaneous uh
a written contemporaneous
recording of that so i i don't i don't
have a problem with that
thank you very much for taking
um
well i'm gonna ask one last one myself
if if this is um if this is the law that
they shall be audio be recorded
wouldn't it not be the case that every
interview would start with the recording
on and therefore the the suspect
saying i don't want to be recorded would
be captured and at that point it would
be terminated
i mean i think that's also the theory
when you're going to be yeah in a
custodial situation i think that's
exactly the theory yeah okay all right
thank you
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
wouldn't it just be easier if we could
educate everybody to shut their mouth
and don't talk
that's not an appropriate question so
i'm gonna
answer that please
um there being no further questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
does anybody else
i don't know i couldn't hear
yes go ahead
the mic
okay
uh i drafted uh the change to the
language in the definition of custodial
interrogation that i talked about with
representative lynn i showed it to him
and he had no problem with that
representative welch is actually taking
that down to get that into the amendment
i know this is an early bill and needs
to be reported out so i just want the
chair to know and the committee to know
that's in process we are so advised
thank you very much
we are going to
now close the public hearing on hp 1540
and i just want to say i think the
members of the committee and the public
is better served for having heard this
debate
we are now going to stand in recess
until 9 45.
gary hopper
good morning
at this time we were now going to open
the public hearing
on hb 1296
it's a non it's a non it's a hearing to
discuss a non-germain amendment that is
amendment number 2022-0264-h
time the chair will recognize
representative silvia to
discuss the amendment
thank you mr chairman and thank you
committee members for
listening to my testimony again on this
rather substantial
amendment
we started out looking at
the presumptions under the asset
forfeiture
section of
318b
and
the chair
using his great skills as a
lawyer decided that the process was uh
um divided so
let me describe the process as it works
now
and what we're doing with this amendment
just uh
broadly
currently
after 2016 we instituted the policy of
criminal asset forfeiture replacing
civil asset forfeiture for in-state
process
and when we did that we
and judiciary has worked on this for
years
we set it up with
um two tracks a criminal process for the
criminal charge
if there is one
and then
putting aside the civil
uh
prosecution against the asset that might
be connected to
the
um
the crime if if there is one
so there were basically two tracks the
civil
forfeiture side was set to the side
while the criminal process went on
and then
after the
criminal process was settled then the
state could do move to the
forfeiture side
of the process and that would be
a civil process
and what we were looking at previously
was the
the evidence standard
which we would be applied whether it's
preponderance of the evidence or
as in a criminal case
thank you beyond reasonable doubt okay
so
we have the um
those two processes and this amendment
brings them together
and
um
let's see where i want to go with this
so page one is all of the current law
and then we get to
the bottom of page two
section e is new
and this
uh
has been added to protect um
small um seizures
um
200 cash um you know anyone going to get
a bag of groceries these days that uses
cash is going to have 200 with them
uh in vehicles um
a two thousand dollar car is not exactly
the drug dealer's uh
favorite um
choice well they they might and they
wouldn't care but someone that is
of less means that's their way of
getting to work or the grocery store
so we've we've taken and put that
outside of the reach
of law enforcement
in general
in
asset forfeiture
the the vast majority of seizures and
forfeitures are below
ten thousand dollars in value so this is
it's it's fairly uncommon to come across
the the big
dealers which is what we're looking for
but
so we're really trying to focus on
the state process
the criminal
asset forfeiture and unifying those
processes
on top page three
we make sure that the defendant does not
waive their rights they cannot waive
their right
so
typically if you have
something a car of 2 000 value
you're not going to
hire a lawyer to try and
get that car back it's going to cost you
more than two thousand dollars just for
the lawyer so you're basically out that
so you want to make sure that
it's not just
taking assets that uh
are going to be waived so that there is
some um
protection there
down at line 23 on page three
this is where the current
civil side of things begins and it puts
aside
um
and the department of justice would have
to file within 60 days to
lock in that that
asset so that it's
becomes part of or tied to a criminal
process
going to page four
so here we are
adding the
asset
to
the duties of the public defender
because we're unifying this process
the
the court all the lawyers involved the
prosecutors
they know
all of the information having to do with
all of this process the the asset that
sieves it's got to be
inventoried uh if it's connected to
criminal activity
we certainly want to know that so all of
the information is there
this
adds
protection for those who
are served by a public defender
and um
at a very minimal expense you know the
the defender is already looking at the
case prosecutors are looking the case so
this just unifies it so the process can
be
brought together
and
in the end that
that asset if there is a conviction
will be part of the sentencing and
there's also in here protection for
the constitutional right of proportional
justice or punishment
so page four is laying out uh the
process
involved in all the
the details and
i do believe the court will have some
comments on that to
perhaps tighten things up a little bit
the
information
about the asset
is is going to be separated from the
jury so that they're not
making a judgment based on
that
evidence
and prejudicing the jury
of course
we also have
protections for
innocent owners
if
someone's mother lends a son a car and
she thinks her son's a good boy and well
it turns out maybe he's not or or he
just gets caught up in it and mom needs
that car for herself to get to work
we want to have protections for
folks that are innocent
also you know if the if a car is
on on lease or there's a debt owed on it
the the bank
or the the dealership would have the
the
access to get their
funds back on that
as i say we've uh we've gone through
this a lot in um
in the judiciary committee over the
years
so a lot of this is new to you i
understand that and it's perhaps a
little thick to get through
we've gone through it quite a bit
i'm trying to hit the highlights here
for you and i'm sure you're going to
have lots of questions i've also got um
um
lee mcgrath from the institute for
justice who has been working on this
nationally for quite a long time
who will fill in the gaps from
my testimony
then we get into some of the current
language on the division of the
forfeiture after the forfeiture has been
secured
then the
45 of the
monies would go to the department that
sees the asset 45 would go to the
attorney general's drug
forfeiture fund and 10 percent goes to
the
health and human services for
drug rehabilitation
and such
also included in this
is in the last section here
at page 11.
no that is not it
sorry all of my notes are
tucked away
um
so instead of my uh rambling further i
guess i'll take questions and if you
have technical questions
you might save those for the
the attorney behind me
so with that i'll uh i'll
conclude
representative pantalakis
thank you mr chairman
excuse my voice
thank you for taking this question
why are we digging into the fortune
professor law so deeply
i'm sorry we're digging into
why we're digging into this law so
deeply
well because we want to uh provide to
due process to uh people who have their
assets seized and possibly unjustly
second question
follow
they are coming into this state selling
our kids drugs and killing them
why should we give them any breaks
well
respectfully the uh the process assumes
innocence until guilt is proven
okay representative boardnet
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
so someone has been convicted in uh
court
their property has been seized
and they have filed for an appeal
their appeal
results in a overturn of their
conviction
is their property returned
that is the intent and until the process
is done um
their their property is still their
property and we may need to
look at the language here to make sure
that that is correct and uh attorney
mcgrath would
have a better answer to that than i
thank you
representative muse
thanks for taking my question i did have
a quick question you have an exclusion
around contraband
for the purposes of this statute what
what is considered contraband
so a contraband would be
certain any illegal drugs
drugs with no prescription
contraband could be
geez
i suppose anything that's not legal to
have
counterfeit money would be contraband
thank you
representative connolly
thank you and thank you for taking the
question
so my name is on this
um
although i'm not
i guess that notwithstanding i'm
sympathetic to what you're trying to do
with
asset forfeiture and the changes you
proposed
what i'm a little bit curious about and
i didn't hear a clear answer is
why take a one-page bill
and come back with a
10-page amendment
that
does nothing but
uh muddy
what you had previously proposed
well
i suppose my my explanation probably
muddies things pretty much um
but uh we started out with
a very simple bill and admittedly uh
this is a a rather grand expansion and
this
uh came about with uh discussions with
uh chairman abbas who's much more
familiar with the process in court
and
it was basically his idea and uh
maine has a process like this
which unifies these these uh the
criminal and civil process so that
while it it's
hard to digest no doubt much more
difficult than the
the simple one that we even had a fair
bit of discussion about
this is a process
that is seeking to protect innocent
people from having their
assets
taken
unjustly
and
i don't mind criminals losing their
assets that's perfectly fine they should
and they should be you know balanced
with our constitutional um
command that it be proportional
so these are some of the issues that
this amendment addresses it yes it is a
grand expansion from what you started
with but it's something that we've been
working on
and when we
we instituted the policy within the
state to have criminal forfeit
forfeiture
instead of civil asset forfeiture that
criminal process
protects due process
much better
there being no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you
the committee now calls lee mcgrath
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
in favor of this amendment and this bill
my name is lee mcgrath i'm the senior
legislative council for the institute
for justice
crime should not pay
it is legitimate for the state of new
hampshire to confiscate the fruit of
crime
nothing in that bill changes the
principle
what this bill does is improve upon the
policy
that you enacted in 2016.
in 2016 you said it was important
in senate bill 522
to have a conviction
in criminal court as a prerequisite to
people losing their pro their property
what we've subsequently learned is that
there's a better way of achieving that
policy goal of ensuring that no one
acquitted
loses their property
and the better
way
of achieving
new hampshire's current policy
is in this amendment it is to merge
the criminal
prosecution and the forfeiture
litigation into one single
single process
in one single courtroom
with one
single
judge
defense attorney and and and prosecutor
so the way in which you might
conceptualize this is stream
streamlining
streamlining it into a single process in
which all the evidence is introduced in
the criminal prosecution and then after
conviction with all that evidence
introduced the judge
as part of the post-conviction
determination
can determine
whether
title should transfer
whether the car is an instrument of the
crime whether the cash is the proceeds
of the of the cr of the crime
all in one all in one
process all streamlined so you might
think of what this bill does
as making the loss
of title to property
taking it out of a civil process and
making it look a lot more like a
sentence
a post-conviction determination by the
judge
that
new hampshire rightly confiscates title
to some to some
property
this is not new
north carolina has done it since the
1990s
new mexico nebraska and just last
session maine adopted this
simplification this unifi unification
there are certain there are lots of
benefits
to this
one
is
you avoid you would ensure that an
indigent person
gets representation
not only of himself
but also his property
through the public
through the public defense defender
two
by uniting
the process all in criminal court you
avoid a big but relatively unknown
problem
and that is
the in the two-track system
there are lots of people who don't
pursue the civil litigation and they
default
they may be subsequently acquitted but
because they have defaulted they haven't
answered the notices they haven't
answered the civil complaint they
haven't hired an attorney to represent
them in civil court they lose title
automatically
regardless of what happens in the
criminal prosecution
so by uniting these two
you avoid what we have found in other
states that can range between 80 and 90
percent of the cases in civil
court end in default
maine doesn't have that problem
nebraska new mexico north carolina don't
have that default problem it's all done
in one one single single pro process
this bill is also very pragmatic
in
that the
requirement in criminal
court
that triggers the loss of title
can be achieved through a plea bargain
or
it can
it can be achieved should the suspect
choose to help law enforcement help
prosecutors
in exchange for a less dramatic
incarceration
title it can be achieved there's an
exception for death deportation fleeing
and a abandonment and so the bill builds
in the pragmatism
that the prosecutor will want as part of
the criminal prosecution as it relates
to transferring title
to to this to the state through through
forfeiture
the second big benefit mr chairman
this protects spouses
wives
girlfriends boyfriend boyfriends
parents
it changes how they go into court and
try to get back their property that
their husband their boy their boyfriend
used without their consent
it changes the innocent owner claimant
and his ability or her ability to go
into into court and say
i didn't he didn't i've always had the
keys
i don't want him to use the car he took
the keys he took the car against my will
so this bill does that
both as part of a prompt post seizure
hearing known as a crimstock hearing and
it also does it by creating a a process
a process for the girlfriend
for the wife to to go in and say here's
my title i didn't consent to the use of
this his use of the your car the car
finally mr chairman one thing this bill
doesn't do
it doesn't change the distribution of
proceeds
and so
it
when forfeited when that car has title
transfers to the state
and the car sold or the cash transfers
to the state it will still be
distributed as current law
distributed
so
in conclusion mr chairman
this is a more efficient
process
a simpler process
and it is the process
that
realizes new hampshire's policy that it
has had for six years
of
of first a conviction and then
a discussion about transferring title
mr chairman i stand ready to answer the
committees
including
the question about appeals
representative
greene thank you mr chair thank you for
taking my question
what if the property was in a trust how
how does this work
mr chair mr chairman representative give
me an example so
usually the example is someone's driving
along the highway
and they get stopped the car is seized
the cash is seized but give me the
hypothetical that you're thinking of
well the person's property
their land their home their automobiles
is all set up in a trust yes how would
that be affected
so
it would operate the same that
that the
person
that this is principally a crime
so that person committed
the person committed a crime
and then did he use that land did he use
that land to to make
to to make uh
let me expand your hypothetical right uh
as a as a lab for for meth
then he loses if convicted he loses
loses a title and that trust is pierced
okay
thank you
representative marston
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question yes sir which is a
follow-up to his yes
put the trust in two people's names yes
one is the criminal one isn't what
happens
so this is the innocent let's for the
sake of ease let's say the criminal is
the husband and the
the
the uh
is it the misses
she can go into court
she can
she can argue look i own this property i
don't own half of it i own my 100
share of it
i did not
consent
for him to use the the trust assets as
part of the crime i'd i did not cons i
did not know he was baking meth
in the in the in the in the basement
i've never i haven't been to the house
for years
she is an innocent owner claimant she
walks into court
and the burden is on the state to show
that she did know she did consent she
did have actual actual knowledge
and so her interests are protected
whether they are in a trust or whether
she owns them herself
follow-up
so i'm assuming
and that's the bad word
because i'm using my own particular
situation yes sir my wife and i are in
all everything we own is in trust and we
both kind of enjoy each whatever
benefits if something happens to either
one of us
so in that case
because the criminal side of that trust
which is equally in joint
everybody loses
if you and your wife are conspired mr
chairman dare i extend the hypothetical
if you and your wife are both charged
and you and your wife are both convicted
you and your wife lose the land that was
an instrument of your crime yes but the
hypoth the earlier hypothetical was one
where she was completely innocent
she still loses she
in the where she is where she is a a
defendant
a co-defendant with you
and you and she are convicted
both of you lose the property when it is
shown to be the instrument of the crime
for which you have been convicted
well let me just answer
what he's saying is that if
she does not lose if you are convicted
and she didn't know what you were doing
she would be able to go to this hearing
and say that i had no idea and the state
would have to prove she did does that
answer your question i i believe so mr
chairman thank you yeah thanks thank you
um representative hearn
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
how many
um forfeiture cases are there in new
hampshire yearly
mr mr chairman representative
new hampshire has a reporting
requirement
but unfortunately the attorney general
has met not met those requirements so we
do not have a fixed number on the we do
not know exactly how many forfeiture
cases there are in
new hampshire
you don't know exactly follow up fall
off you don't know exactly but do you
have an average
i'm i'm sorry to use the word exactly mr
chairman
no
i'm informed we have a member of the
ag's office who's going to testify
so mr chairman we do know
the dollar amounts
we know
that since 2000 to 2019
under new hampshire state law
there's been approximately 3 million
dollars
for forfeited under state state law
that's different from the 22 million
that's forfeited under under federal
federal law
and so
you could take
3 million divided by 20 20 years
and you have roughly 150 000 dollars a
year is forfeited
if i did the math correctly in my head
forfeited under new hampshire state
state law
representative newman
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um i'm looking at the original bill
and uh
the second sentence follows up on uh
representative marston's thing that that
takes the the um
who has to prove it the claimant
used to have to prove it now the state
has to prove it would that be a correct
thing
and let me just ask a question finish
the question with the
the first sentence talks about
whatever we are talking about as the
property has to be in proximity
and i'm just wondering if that proximity
requirement in the sentence that was
taken out is covered in the new bill
thank you
uh mr chairman representative i do not
believe that that issue of proximity
is imported from existing law
into
uh into the
into the amendment
uh i will need to check whether it was
deleted or not from the from the
amendment and i will i will
do that and inform
representative sylvia to report report
back
the key component to to this
is that once convicted in criminal court
it's relatively easy
to show
that the car was an instrument of the
crime and the cash was the proceeds of
the crime
because in that conviction
prosecution in that prosecution evidence
gets introduced
and so the sort of technicality that the
original bill
bill
attempted to to address
implicit and i'll check to see
if we deleted it if it's deleted but
that it is it is uh it is implicitly
addressed by the fact that the cr that
all of this is happening in criminal
court
who's first representative bourdain
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
taking my questions
you might
i need a little clarification on what
happens
if property is seized that
uh
belongs to someone else for example
you're a drug arrested
the car is being used is
only partially owned by the
defendant
and
that car is seized
but the business that owns the car
it loses
of
that property
do they lose it forever or
what happens
mr chairman
representative
so you're right
there's this there are two types of
property owners that this bill is
addressing one is the defendant but
let's focus in on the other type of
property owner that your question
addresses
and that is the the lender
the fleet owner
the secured creditor the wife the
girlfriend the boyfriend the parent the
grandparent the the neighbor these are
all taken care of
in two ways
one is and
that that person can go into court
in a prompt post seizure hearing and say
wait a second
i didn't
i'm the secured lender i didn't
authorize him to or consent to his using
using the car or the wife i didn't know
about his using the car so there is a
prompt post-seizure hearing that can
take place as in as few as in 10 days to
get back for the innocent owner claimant
and the secured creditor to get back
that vehicle that has been seized
what if there is no innocent uh party
and
so uh
they're waiting for months to a year for
trial and they have they basically have
lost uh use of their property
so mr chairman if i could representative
let me just clarify we're back talking
about the defendant
yes okay so the defendant
is stopped his car is seized
he's charged with a crime
yes that car sits in the impound
impound lot
unless there are some mitigating
circumstances
that
he he can go and ask for a prompt
post-seizure hearing as as well but he
will have a harder time
and so he does lose
lose
uh lose use
of that car during the criminal
prosecution
but if he could show in the post-prompt
seizure
hearing that perhaps the stop was
wrong unconstitutional then he can go
and have this crime stock this prompt
procedure hearing and get his car back
just stand by just one quick question
is it third
is a third party able to intervene for
example um bank of america owns the car
it's financed could they intervene and
say we want to repossess this car yes
prior to waiting for the conviction yes
so that's the
prompt post-seizure hearing
famous case crimstock
that gets gets bank of america
gets the wife
right into court
very fast
doesn't have to wait
for
the criminal prosecution
everything that's happening to the
defendant
represent bournemouth you're following
thank you thank you for taking my
question um
so now we're no longer talking about car
we're talking about land that was seized
and that land was seized as part of
the drug offense
and of course a lot of land is not owned
all outright by the defendant it's owned
jointly by them and
a loaning institution
so
as part of the
criminal procedure proceedings the land
is seized by
the state
the uh
defendant is convicted
uh he appeals his uh
uh
uh conviction
and the verdict is overruled
meanwhile
many months have gone by
the bank our lending organization
has missed payment
the defendant
may have lost control of
the
land itself so he has no other place to
live
in fact has no place to live
and after a year two years i don't know
how long these cases drag on they could
especially with an appeal case
the defendant has lost
uh
he's no longer able to afford to pay the
loan
the bank says
i'm seizing your this property even
though you've been found guilty innocent
and
what's the recourse
mr chairman uh
representative
this is a good hypo this is a good
hypothetical
so we're focused in once again on the
def on the defendant we're not focused
in on the innocent owner claimant the
wife or the or the
the the bank
and so
banking laws
exist
and must be followed and you must pay
and this bill does not not change
the authority or the power of bank of a
of the len lent lender
to reclaim the property when the
when the
uh
regardless of whether
the bank can still proceed under new
hampshire banking laws
to take title
when they're
when they
when the borrower fails to pay
so there's
in in this hypothetical
and it does land doesn't happen a lot
most of this is cars and cash but in
this hypothetical
yes this
banking laws are not part of this bill
do not get changed if he fails to make
his payments
the bank may exercise their right to
take titles to the to the land
representative panalakas
i do
say that a person
the wife or the mother or the father
are innocent
people
but my question is is are they
benefiting from the drug money
that
has been seized
mr chairman representative no
in that
the state can show
that the proceeds from drug sales by the
defendant
when if the state can show that it went
to the to the to the payment of
of the car the periodic car payments
then that person is then the wife is not
innocent
and so
the fruit of crime
the instruments of crime
shouldn't
it should should
should go to the state and that's the
underlying concept of the of the bill
crime shouldn't pay
assets should be confiscated
i think you're misunderstanding what i'm
saying i am saying if the wife or the
mother or any of them
is
benefiting like
paying
rent or food or anything else from this
money
would you say that they shouldn't
be
the car shouldn't be confiscated
representative would you mind the last
part of your question i i i missed
that the
you're saying that the car the wife or
um
mother or father is innocent
and they should have their car
but are they benefiting
like getting food
rent and whatnot
from this drug money
uh mr chairman
representative
the bill
is focused on taking
fruits
and instruments of crime
it doesn't go so far as to engage in the
moral condemnation
of someone who may
benefit from
who's not a criminal who is not charged
but who may be able to buy food because
the defendant gave them a few bucks
it doesn't go that far
thank you
representative lynn
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question the only question i
have is this let's let's say we're
focusing on the defendant
is there anything in this bill
that would require the state in the
criminal
trial of the defendant
to prove the the
the uh
the the facts that make let's say the
car subject to forfeiture
uh mr chairman representative lin no
okay so all of that happens
in a post-conviction hearing all right
so in other words the state in a if i
may follow up in
if in the criminal case itself
it's not particularly important to the
state in proving its case to show
who owned the car that the defendant
arrived in and all that and it would be
sort of extraneous they can they can
not bother with that stuff in the
criminal trial and then deal with it
later mr chairman representative lin yes
thank you
representative true
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i was pre-pre-med not pre-law
but talking on the amendment
the change
a big change that is making to a current
law
is that
once a person is found
guilty in the court case
or found innocent
immediately after that the judge decides
what about all this stuff
what about the money but about the car
is that is that correct uh mr chair
representative you're very close
indulge me for just a second and then
i'll say yes
new hampshire in 2016
a policy
it says conviction in 2000 it's not in
the bill in 2016
sb 522
said we want convictions to happen as a
prerequisite to losing
losing
title
this bill takes that concept that was
that has
takes that concept
and
perfects it and proves it into the
single process that you just described
so the answer to your question is yes
it's all happening in the criminal court
the criminal prosecution
the person must be first
convicted
if he is acquitted the case is over the
car gets returned the cash gets returned
so the answer to your question is yes
follow up
thank you mr chair and
thank you again for taking my question
so now for something totally
nothing to do with that
on on page two of the of the amendment
uh starting down around line 30
it's talking about 200 or less or a
motor vehicle
of 2 000 or less
exempt from seizure yes
why
i 2
a two thousand dollar car probably can't
pass inspection
i mean
what about my car that's like brand new
and like it's ten thousand dollars or
whatever
why the 2000 what's the purpose of that
mr chairman of representative true
we had to pick a number
this
is
a get out of free get out of free
be completely this is an amount of of
minimal
dollars minimal
car value that is so small
that
we're not even going to allow these
assets to enter into the system
and so we wanted to make it so that it
was to point out that there are some
types of assets that are so small so
minimal that it is cost inefficient for
everyone
for the police the prosecutor the public
defender the criminal defense lawyer to
even bother
with
with trying to link certain assets to a
to a to a crime
and so the goal was to make it small not
like not big
thank you
representative schultz
thank you mr chair hi i'm a substitute
for today i'm representative schultz
from concord thank you for taking my
question
because hearing the other questions
leads me to think of one regarding that
same section
and that is
um
how do i put this
some ladies have really bad taste in
guys and they may
not have any means if everything is
seized to take care of themselves or
their children
why wouldn't there be a provision
that would account for their
financial well-being for at least a
period of time while they transition
i hate to see
children families being
punished for the criminal behavior of a
spouse
and um
yeah like i said some ladies have really
bad taste
just for the record the chair would like
to state that that
the
opposite is also true
i was waiting for that
mr representative schultz
so you are right to focus on the
innocent
person
and not the defendant
and love oftentimes doesn't isn't so so
rational
so what the bill rightly does addresses
your concern
the bill rightly does two does three
things two things two important things
one it allows that
wife that girlfriend that husband that
boyfriend to get
into court fast
and that's the prompt post seizure
hearing i'm referring to crimstock is
the name of the case
that's
that's her greatest salvation
the second thing that it does
to her benefit
it flips the burden of proof
if she shows up and says here's my title
see it's got my name on it
then the burden of proof flips to the
government to show that she actually did
consent
and did have actual knowledge
and so
the confis her getting the car back
is faster
and easier
under this bill by the prom procedure
hearing and the flipping of the burden
of
i'm sorry the flipping of this
the burden of proof yes
represent muse
thank you for taking my question
i'm curious if this amendment
effectively eliminates
civil asset fortune forfeiture in the
state of new hampshire
mr chairman representative yes as it
relates to these crimes
and that's what we want
it is an unnecessary
process
that
that the that
the
that is inconsistent with the policy
established by the by the state
and so
there's no rewards no extra rewards here
for convicted drug dealers
we're not crime shouldn't
crime shouldn't pay
all we're doing is
streamlining unifying
the the process to protect those who
haven't been charged those who have been
acquitted and in this case those who are
innocent owner
claimants
so
the best way to think about that mr
chairman if you would indulge me for
just a second
is when does civil forfeiture
make sense
it makes sense
in the port of boston
if portsmouth has support the port of
portsmouth it makes sense when the owner
of the property is in england or ireland
or argentina
and law enforcement can't get can't get
personal jurisdiction
over that owner of the property and
therefore
in rem
jurisdiction
litigation against the property in civil
court makes perfect sense in admiralty
law
because the state of new hampshire has
not gained personal jurisdiction over
the human being
by contrast
this bill says look we do gain personal
jurisdiction over the human being so
therefore let's not engage in this
artifice of litigating against a car and
litigating against cash
representative connolly question of the
chair
state question
i have practical questions um
but i'm wondering do we have other
witnesses who are intending to testify
on this that maybe would be best suited
to answer some questions yes
thank you
there be no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you mr chair
thank you members
the comedian now calls attorney attorney
richard head
judicial branch
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch i did want to take
you through um the bill or the amendment
briefly we haven't had a lot of time to
digest it so there's probably other
things that we could talk about but
sort of big picture is there are a
number of
elements of this bill that will need to
be worked on it is it has sort of
inconsistencies with either the current
system of
circuit court superior court
and it also
has fiscal impacts that i'll briefly
talk about
with regard to the overall policy of the
judicial branch does not take a position
some of these are just nits but they're
things that just need to be addressed at
some point so running through the bill
page 2 line 11
references municipal district or
superior court there are no municipal
courts
the district court is a division now of
the circuit court so it's district
division of circuit court you can just
reference circuit court there instead of
either municipal or
district
on page three
um starting at the top line three
um
is the is the waiver provision you heard
uh discussed earlier
just to clarify
at least what i think that means and
what's intended to mean and this would
be a policy of the committee that you
would have to adopt
is that it says a document purporting to
waive interest or rights and seize
property shall be
void and inadmissible in court
that would mean in the event so for
example during the the uh
a sentencing or a plea bargain
this would be a separate type of process
that could not be waived by the
defendant in the course of engaging in
their plea bargain at least we think
that's that's what is intended by the
way it's written so that you would have
to have still have a separate proceeding
even if the party wanted to uh to waive
the interest
continuing on down uh page three
beginning at line eight uh
16 to 18 which i think
is current language talks about the
initiation
of administrative or judicial
proceedings against the property
not sure exactly we couldn't quite
figure out how that ties to page 4 line
which talks about the
in a case in which the state seeks
forfeiture a property the prosecuting
authority shall file with the court and
notice a proposed forfeiture
we just were unclear as to how those two
proceedings were being tied together in
these separate sections
continuing on page 3 lines 21-22
talks about
what would happen if the attorney
general's office determines that the
proceedings probably cannot be sustained
and talks about making a written report
of findings uh to the seizing agency and
of appropriate uh authorized and direct
the release of the property there's no
connection there to if there's to the
courts and what the courts are told if
these if these occur there seems to be a
procedural gap in that particular
section
if we turn to page four
um
sort of a a
significant shift in terms of some cost
issues
so on line eight
talks about it being a part of the
criminal prosecution and following a
conviction for a felony
and following a conviction for felony
violation of the chapter
and then it goes on in the next line
line 10 of page four if a defendant in a
criminal matter is represented by a
public defender
um the public defender shall represent
the defendant that has the potential to
have a significant impact on the public
defender's office i don't know if they
were reached out to
or the
judicial council which deals with
indigent defense costs in terms of the
ultimate fiscal impact of that type of a
provision
again not weighing in on the policy but
that has a potential significant impact
not only on just fiscal but also
workload which i imagine you've heard
the just the extreme workload pressures
that the public defender is currently
operating under
continuing on
page
4 line 14 and 15 talks about giving
post-seizure hearings a priority on the
court's docket there are a number of
things that the legislature asks the
courts to put as a priority and the more
things you put as a priority it just
means that other things are getting
pushed we have a limited number of
judges limited number of of of ways in
which cases can be managed so the more
that gets pushed towards a priority
other things civil cases uh get pushed
to the rear of the line just
almost by physics as you push more into
the into the expedited uh or priority
dockets
looking at again page four line 20-21
this is i think
an issue that may not be
a lot of this is is taken out of some
some national language i imagine where
we have
circuit court and superior court and
there's a bill that is currently in in
in the legislature
that passed
the judiciary committee that would
rewind felonies first
and this
particular language in this bill
assuming the felonies first rewind
occurs has a just a a significant impact
on the circuit courts because under
under the rewind of felonies first
felonies would first be heard in the
circuit court
and the probable cause hearings would be
heard in circuit court they're then
bound over their felonies they get bound
over the superior court so there's not
sort of the same judge same trial same
same court in those proceedings there's
a bounded bound over process where those
go to the superior court
but the probable cause hearing is done
in the in the circuit court if felonies
first is in fact rewound under house
bill 1597.
it's then also unclear in lines 22 of 23
of page 4 where the party may move for
an extension of no more than 10 days
so again is that an extension that would
be
you know essentially when would that
extension request be made from a
management of caseloads is this
occurring at the probable cause hearing
stage
85 percent of which are waived anyway
is that occurring essentially on the day
of the probable cause hearing some
number of days before
you know exactly when is that happening
because as a court management process
you know these cases are being scheduled
and as a result of what goes on the
schedule other things do not go on the
schedule so if we're learning about a a
request for an extension of 10 days on
the day something is scheduled that's a
gap that we could have filled with other
cases and other other activities and
then it requires 10 days
again we're talking about management of
an incredibly complicated docket process
so the circuit court as of the end of
december had
just under 200 000 cases pending so we
are managing a huge volume of cases on a
day-to-day basis and the clerks are
doing just a remarkable job in doing
that any time you bump something 10 days
that ripple in the system sort of has a
an overall impact on the on the
management of cases within the circuit
court so it's not you know it reads very
simply it's just a 10-day extension it
has and those types of things have
significant
just case management docket management
impacts within the circuit court
um
there's some there's just some some
language we're unclear of so if you turn
to page five line nine
uh the prosecuting attorney shall serve
the charging instrument
amendment and notice as provided by the
rules of the court
not exactly sure if that means the
indictment or a complaint or or whatever
and by the way throughout this there's
references to petitions
and if those are in civil cases at least
and and some of this does seem to imply
filings that are occurring outside of
the criminal docket those would be
complaints not petitions
for the most part anyway
so but there's there's a
certain amount of uncertainty as to
you know when some of these some of
these petitions that show up later in
the bill or in this amendment would
would come into play
um
and and also by the way you know the
reference to the court's rules these are
rules that we're going to need to create
and there's going to have to be some
sort of a a process in which these rules
exist both in the circuit court in the
superior court if we're talking about
felonies that are going to get bound
over if in fact felonies first rewind
does take place and ultimately the
legislature supports that
looking at page
six of the amendment lines five and six
the defendant may petition the court to
determine before trial at trial or upon
conviction whether the force return is
unconstitutionally excessive
unclear again if that's being filed in
the criminal docket if that's a new
petition that's being filed in superior
court
not a lot of clarity in terms of what is
the intent of that petition when it's
being filed and into what case it's
being filed
similarly on line 30 of page six um
there's another
another opportunity
for the court to be
scheduling the hearings on petitions
within 30 days after it's filing
or at the court's discretion so
we're assuming that that's a request for
an expedited
process but but again somewhat unclear
in that point i made earlier about any
time you put deadlines on something for
the court you're you're pushing
something else out in a in a fairly
complicated docket system
in terms of the the innocent property
owner defense on page 7
not a lot of definition is provided to
that it simply says what the innocent
owner would would have to submit
and then provides an opportunity for the
court to hear the petition again
unclear as to what that petition is
where it's being filed and is it we're
assuming it's now a new civil case but
again in terms of of the outline uh of
what's contained in the in the amendment
if if i may respectfully um
it sounds like you have quite a
voluminous uh
oh are you okay what i'm going to ask is
if you could
submit that to us you can send an email
with that list i can i can sort of clean
it up a little and try to send something
and i would ask the sponsor to
coordinate um
also as well with the representative
from the court system if you tend on
getting another amendment to us
and i'm going to ask the
members to refrain from questions
so that we can move this along unless
anyone has a really important question
they'd like to ask
representative muse
this the original bill came to us
without a fiscal note and based on your
testimony it looks like from a cost
perspective we may be doing more than
just shuffling the deck here can you
quantify
the additional cost or personnel that
might be required
to handle
these additional process steps and
additional hearings
off the top of my head i can't quantify
it um and and in part it will depend
upon where felonies first rewind um goes
even if
it and then separately there's a there's
a cost that would have to be associated
with the indigent defense costs
so public defenders office and the
judicial council would have to sort of
evaluate how many additional cases would
be would be generated
as a result of this
and and sort of what the additional
procedures would would trigger um so so
the short answer is i i don't have a a
an estimate today
uh and and we haven't had really enough
time with the amendment to sort of
start to evaluate that level of it
but but certainly there is a fiscal
impact generally
uh thank you for your testimony thank
you look forward to seeing that list
the committee now calls buzz share
i would ask the remaining four witnesses
if they could possibly keep their
testimony to two minutes as we're
running behind another bill
uh my name is buzz
my name is both sher um
for the record uh i'm a police
commissioner in portsmouth a law
professor at unh law my opinions are
those are mine only and not of unh law
or the portsmouth police commission
i won't be uncharacteristically brief
um this uh i am
the concept behind this bill i'm very
supportive of
uh historically the civil forfeiture
process has been much abused
that said
i can't testify in support of it because
the impact on the public defender
program would be very significant
appreciate that it's not simply a matter
of
you know having uh having giving them
more money so they can hire the lawyers
to staff the program
they are at a point now where they're
trying to hire new lawyers particularly
lateral hires from within and without
the state outside the state and they're
not able to keep they're not able to
keep up at all with the the uh the
number of lawyers that are leaving the
program given the already excessive case
lows
so it's a bigger problem than
such as the you know it is a problem
that it would cost
a lot of money to staff up the public
defender program to handle this but it's
a bigger problem than that because even
if they had all the money they couldn't
staff it up anytime soon so uh with that
uh my testimony is over i believe i came
in under two minutes
you did ask
no questions thank you very much
kimberly now calls jeffrey ware and
danielle sarkowski from the ag's office
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
my name is jeffrey ward i am a senior
assistant attorney general and the chief
of the criminal justice bureau at the
attorney general's office uh with me is
danielle zakowski who is the chief of
the drug prosecution unit um at our
office as part of the criminal bureau
there
um we are here uh with
concerns about uh this bill and the in
the sea change that it would create and
how
uh drug forfeitures
uh currently occur as well as and i'll
try not to repeat uh both what attorney
had said and and what attorney shear
said but certainly those are concerns
uh about both costs associated and an
already overburdened indigent defense
system that's well publicized
in the media that's at a crisis point um
and then would add this all on top of it
in addition to a court system that has
been that has been backed up for some
time
but based on what i heard from both the
sponsor and those that spoke in favor of
this we see this really as a solution to
a problem that doesn't exist
and and while we haven't had much time
to go over the amendment as it came in
rather recently
i would urge the members of the
committee that are considering this to
look at our asset forfeiture guidelines
that are available on our website
um much of the things that this seeks to
address we've already addressed through
our asset forfeiture guidelines and our
policies
uh when dealing with asset forfeiture i
would also suggest to you that the idea
and i think
attorney head and
from the court system gave just a
preview of this this is not a more
efficient and simpler system by any
stretch
this actually would would would
significantly complicate
uh the current system that we deal with
but the what i was what i heard in
hearing the and hearing the testimony
earlier was that this is a bill with all
of its machinations it seeks to protect
innocent people from having their assets
taken
um what you didn't hear is that that's
happening
because it's not happening
um
if we
typically speaking in this process
the asset for the the forfeiture unless
waived or defaulted doesn't occur until
after a conviction
we haven't had an instance where there's
been an acquittal and an asset
forfeiture um and at least in at least
in our recent collective memory uh
before you hear
um
if that were the case we'd withdraw the
asset forfeiture
and that's that's generally part of our
policies and guidelines
so it seeks to to to solve an issue the
protection of of criminally innocent
people from having their assets taken
that doesn't exist in addition as to the
quote um innocent owner as it's
described in this statute which is not
and defined or necessarily identified i
think it's important for the committee
to be aware
that
with
drug dealers that we're dealing with
here and i know there are a lot of
questions about property typically
speaking and this is outlined in our
guidelines and in our protocols we don't
take property
i can't recall having done it i've been
at the attorney general's office for
almost 10 years danielle's been there
almost as long training sakowski
excuse me we haven't taken property
um so again it's dealing with issues
that aren't aren't actually issues in
reality we currently have guidelines
that say we don't seize cash under a
thousand dollars
we currently have guidelines that say we
don't seize vehicles under three
thousand dollars so again it's
addressing issues um that that aren't
really there in in practicality so those
are some of the highlights i'm happy i
know we have limited time to answer
questions and i and i hope there would
be some questions either here or a
future date about how the process
actually works and we have the
opportunity in depth to describe that to
you um but i understand you're pressed
for time as well so i've tried to keep
it short anyway which is not easy for us
lawyers
and the chair appreciates that is there
anyone that has a question of import
that we
they would like to answer
representative irene you had a question
i think he answered it
okay very good um further questions we
appreciate your time and testimony thank
you
the committee now calls ross connolly
afp nh
thank you mr chair members of the
committee i will be very brief since i
too am waiting for the next bill uh
my name is ross connolly i'm the deputy
state director for americans for
prosperity here in new hampshire uh here
to voice our support for for the
amendment uh we also supported the
underlying bill
uh really the top line issue for us is
is the current system
since it goes through that civil process
after the criminal process
in that civil process uh
a defendant is not given representation
uh so therefore if if property was
seized
of a certain amount that it may not be
worth
somebody actually challenging that and
trying to get their property back
since uh
since the legal fees might exceed the
property that they're trying to to get
back so we we consider this this step
obviously there's some technical issues
that uh the committee has to work
through and we'd be happy to provide
advice on that as well uh but we view
this as a good protection of property
rights uh creating a more efficient
system
and and uh protecting granite stater's
right to due process especially if they
are acquitted so uh with that i'd be
happy to take any questions if there are
any
seeing no questions thank you for your
testimony thank you very much
the committee now calls frank nack aclu
nh
mr chairman members of the committee
my colleague lee covered most of the
issues um about why we uh strongly
support hb 1296. um i appreciate just
hearing from the ag's office that they
have you know guidelines in place i
think it would be prudent on the
committee to think just back a couple of
years at the federal level under holder
they put under guidelines to restrict
abuses under the equitable sharing
program a couple years later then
attorney general sessions rescinded part
of those guidelines and so
the fact that we have good guidelines in
place now i don't think should
should um
detract from the fact that we need
strong laws in place to protect property
owners in new hampshire
um
i think one issue that hasn't been
touched on that and i know we're short
on time is just you know this the notion
of what forfeiture is about you know
forfeiture was sold to the public as
this tool for getting the ill-gotten
gains of drug kingpins think pablo
escobar think you know the cartels
in reality the way it has been deployed
in new hampshire and across the country
is to target
low-level low-income people some of whom
have not been involved in any criminal
action so fortunately new hampshire took
some positive steps back in 2016 to
require a criminal conviction
but then again in this process we have
now as as my colleague ross just noted
folks who are then
found guilty if their property has no
nexus and they are indigent they can't
hire an attorney to then prove that
their property has no nexus and so
there's a lot i heard a lot of talk
about burdens on the system i think you
know we should all think about where
that burden should really lie if the
government is attempting to take the
property of someone
just because there's some problems with
the government's ability to hire enough
people that shouldn't fall on property
owners to have to handle and that we
should be able to as a government ensure
that we have the checks and balances in
place to ensure that innocent property
owners and people who have no nexus
between the crime and the property
are protected so thank you
thank you for your testimony
all right represent me i didn't see you
back there go ahead
thank you um
one quick question there seems to be a
disconnect between what you're saying
and what the attorney general's office
said
um just to recap quickly they said that
this is not a problem in new hampshire
this is not happening
you're saying that it is
and it's a serious enough problem that
we should be uh we should be passing
this bill
i'm wondering um
where
is your information coming from
uh and and can you quantify the level of
the problem in new hampshire
absolutely so unfortunately the ag the
as as uh mr mcgrath noted the reporting
hasn't been conducted so we actually
don't have data in new hampshire we do
know from numerous articles and
stories that have been reported on that
led to you know the the forfeiture
reforms back in 2016 that new hampshire
has had a pattern of forfeiture abuses
and so you know we would appreciate that
the state would then come forward with
records of what's happening on the
ground now but you know i've worked on
this issue in a number of states the
patterns have been consistent that
forfeitures are abused and that we need
to have these laws in place and this is
just the latest iteration of
streamlining the process you know
we are ensuring that the process that
you don't have to have the judge
retrained on the facts that the council
or not have to be retrained on the facts
by having a streamlined process you know
i understood that there's somehow create
confusion but when you think about it
practically speaking you have a single
process where everyone is up to speed on
the facts of the case and that's the
most streamlined way we could think
about doing something
thank you thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
at this time i'm going to close the
public hearing
on
hb
and i'm going to open the public hearing
on hp 1476.
i'm liking this improvement in the
chairman already
um
the committee now calls representative
ross berry
um thank you uh mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is ross berry
i'm a state representative for hillsboro
which is south manchester wards eight
and nine and the town of litchfield
um i come today to present hb 1476 fn
um it is a bill
addressing uh bail which you guys have
never talked about that here before
right
so
the issue with bail in general
the state legislator passed personal
recognizance bill also known as cashless
bail a couple of years ago
the intentions of the legislature at the
time were i think
a noble cause that we could all get
behind
no one wanted poor people to be held for
minor crimes that they may or may not
have convicted purely because they
couldn't afford bail i think that was
the intention when this legislator did
that and i think to this day that is
probably still the intention of this
body
the problem is is it has grown
out of control in my opinion
i represent as i said the city of
manchester which has been particularly
affected by this issue
it is actually the reason that i ran out
of all of the reasons that i ran this
was it
when i went door to door as a candidate
i heard from the 4 500 doors that i
knocked i heard pr bail over and over
and over again
which surprised me that
the my my future constituents would be
that plugged into a certain problem it's
a level of understanding that i bluntly
didn't expect from the average voter
it's a more nuanced thing after all so
when i got to concord
i actually met with um
several stakeholders of this issue in my
city before i was even sworn in
that was still in
i don't want to say it's infancy but
they were there was many people that
were still in wait and see mode on the
effects of pr bail on the community and
i think um from people you'll hear with
today i think we've moved beyond the
wait and see mode and i think we're now
at the point of we need some change
um this bill will not fix all of the
problems with pr bail um
some of the problems include letting out
people who have been accused of violent
criminals violent crimes
you know and you guys know this from the
hearing on 92
i could sit here and i could list off
the
egregious offenses that have been given
pr bail but i don't think that would
actually be productive towards the
conversation
so the bill that i have presented is
tailored towards people who are already
out on bail so it does not affect does
not change
the current bail system for people who
are not currently out on bail if you are
not on out on bail this and you are
arrested this bill doesn't affect you at
all we are talking about people who are
arrested while out on bail
so
in my expiration or fact-finding mission
with the stakeholders one of the things
that i found is that you have a
group of people who are arrested again
and again
and when i spoke with patrolmen from my
city
they and i'd ask them about pr bail
they'd say some not so nice things about
it
but one of the things that they refer to
it as is catch and release
and the problem is is there's multiple
instances of people being arrested
in my city of manchester who are
released for an arrest before the police
officer has actually finished the
paperwork for arresting them
and
i am one of the largest advocators for
civil liberties and individual rights
but at a certain point
policy and philosophy don't always match
and i believe that if you are out on
bail and you have been arrested we need
to take a closer look at you
and i understand the arguments they
haven't been convicted of the first
crime maybe this is the second arrest
and they're innocent of both it's a fair
point to make and you're not wrong to
raise that point i won't refute that
but what i will say is is we should
exercise
some some state interest and take a
closer look at you so what this bill
does is if you are arrested while out on
bail
you cannot go in front of a bail
commissioner you will go in front of a
judge
and i did that for a couple of reasons
when i met with
people in the beginning a lot of finger
pointing was pointed at the bail
commissioners and i know that this body
passed a bill that helped fund them and
helped kind of
bolster them up so that they can better
do their job and better be funded for
their job
but one of the reasons i wanted to go
i wanted to have them go in front of the
judge was because let's say and i do not
believe this but let's just say for the
sake of the argument the other side is
right that this individual is being
targeted by the police once again i
don't hold this viewpoint but let's just
say you're right wouldn't we want that
person to go in front of a judge and say
hey i'm being targeted by the police
what can you do for me a bail
commissioner can do nothing for them
but a judge can do something so i put
them in front of the judge
the other thing is it does is it puts
the power back into the judge's hands
they cannot give pr bail
for a second arrest
they can set that bail at a penny it
doesn't matter to me but they're not
going to get pr bail
so that is the that is the intent of
this bill i did send a amendment to the
chair yesterday morning um because
there's a 72 hour hold provision and i
was told that that's not um legally
allowed so i did have i did have a
amendment to shift that 72-hour hold
down to a 36-hour hold which i was told
is in line with the current
constitutional requirements um and
obviously
as with all bail it doesn't apply to
weekends and nights and that sort of
thing but that's that's standard
operating procedure at this point so
with that i'm happy to answer the
questions to the best of my ability um
but that that is what the my intent was
and uh and i did i will say one other
thing
this is a bipartisan bill
um i actually went out of my way um to
find uh almost equal balance to it um
and i i'm i believe some of them are
some of the my friends on the other side
of the aisle are here to testify but i i
am here today to advocate for my
community
manchester
needs this
we need this it doesn't undermine this
committee's original intention of
personal recognizance bail
but i am asking you to take a holistic
holistic view of this for people that
are already out on bail and when we
arrest them again we need to figure out
what's going on
representative conley thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question
so this
bill reminds me of something we've heard
before with uh with some interesting
differences but
one of the things that has come up
in the discussion around efforts to
reform this is
the fact that people who uh could
potentially be held
for crimes that would not
require them to be held
at all under the current system um
essentially very minor offenses and i'd
like you i'm wondering if you'd address
that point yeah so it's it's a it's a
fair point i mean if you arrest you can
arrest somebody
that original argument is still is still
there right they can be arrested for
this crime to begin with right they can
go to jail um and they can be held so
it's you know it's in the hands of the
committee to address those minor crimes
if you will um i one of the complaints
about 92 was that it got into the
business of listing crimes
which i know that gave this committee
some consternation and i believe some
representatives on the floor so i i
tried to avoid that
it's admitted it's admittedly be by
avoiding that you cast a a wider net or
a broader stroke um but it is something
that the committee should look at um but
the underlying point is still there you
can still be arrested for that crime
that you can't be held for to begin with
and once again we're not talking about
holding them indefinitely we're talking
about 36 hours they have to go before a
judge and they just can't get pr bail
um but i think that then answer that
question to your satisfaction
follow it does um
i'm curious about the the underlying
thought behind this and you addressed a
very real problem in your city that is
uh happening in mind on a smaller scale
is this intended to
provide some
deterrence is that real the factor here
or is this or is deterrence only part of
it
so it i deterrence is a is a factor at
it i speaking with the patrolmen
specifically in my city they've told me
stories about when they've arrested
people who are in the as they say once
again this is hearsay but they say
they're in the back of the squad car
laughing at them because they know
they're going to be back out on the
streets before the paperwork's done
so i believe that if they know that they
won't be back out on the street before
the paperwork's done that they might be
a little more um
reluctant to do the things that they're
being accused of doing um but it's a
once again i think this is a balanced
approach to
once again the underlying purpose of pr
bail which is don't hold
indigent people who aren't capable of
paying for bail for crimes for minor
crimes they might not have committed
i think this still lives in that spirit
but at a certain point we as a society
have to step up and say what's going on
here and that's that's the purpose of
this
i don't have my name tag today
thanks for taking my question
um
i was wondering do you know of any law
or policy
which has historically tied the length
of
time that someone's
held
pre-trial
to the length of time that
is needed to complete paperwork
uh i'm i'm
i'm i don't fully understand the
question i'm sorry
may i clarify yes i'm sorry um let me
try to find another way to word it
you've um you've made many uh comments
in your presentation
tying
the length of time that a that an
administrative person needs to complete
paperwork
to the length of time that someone
should be in jail
pre-trial and i was wondering
if you could
tell us about any law or policy which
has historically connected those two
things i think you're misunderstanding
the point um so there's no
min there's no minimum that they have to
be held
it just says they have to go in front of
a judge and they can't get pr bail and
you cannot hold them longer than 36
hours
if if you take someone in and they're in
front of a judge in 10 minutes and their
the judge says you know here's your one
dollar bail and you're back out before
the paperwork's completed that's under
36 hours that's perfectly legal
um it's not it's not constraining it's
not saying if you're arrested we're
going to hold you for 36 hours it says
we can hold you for up to 36 hours while
we do our job and that job is now
including going in front of the judge
and the reason why you have to do that
is obviously if you're shifting people
away from a bail commissioner bill
commissioners were established to
basically relieve the do leave the
pressures on judges right if you're
shifting them into this system that is
already more congested you need more
time but if the system is
you know running at a hundred percent
and they're in and out in five minutes
with the two dollar bail
that's a thing that can happen
follow up
sorry i think that maybe my original
question still isn't clear
you've indicated or at least i've
received the impression from your
testimony that you feel that someone who
um is
being held
they haven't been tried they're legally
innocent they've been arrested it's time
for them to be released so that they can
go about their lives until trial
you've i've gotten the impression that
you believe that they should be held
until at least the length of time that
the paperwork uh that would be necessary
to complete paperwork
is that that that was not is that what
you you know intended to communicate no
my my point is is that we need to we
need to put them in front of the
appropriate authority in my opinion
that's the judge
i have a sinking suspicion that that
will take longer than just filling out
the paperwork and going in front of a
bail commissioner
but i don't know that um i don't work in
the court system but i think a logical
person would say if that's true
representative panalakas
thank you mr chairman this bill is just
referring to the second offense right
so that's while they're out on bail and
arrested again so it's it's not first
offense it's underneath the current
system and as i said in my testimony
in my
fact-finding in concord i did not
believe that the votes existed to go at
the underlying problem i've spoken about
my issues with pr bail as a whole
it's not a policy that i would have
supported but i wasn't here and at the
end of the day we're all one of 400 and
our votes are all the same and i thought
that this was a measured approach that
both sides could kind of look at and say
okay if you are out on that second if
you're out on bail and we arrest you
again maybe we should get you in front
of the judge
follow up
what you're saying is if you haven't
learned your lesson the first time we're
going to take care of you the second
time well i i
it's we're going to hold we're going to
take a better look at you i mean
remember they're not adjudicated on the
first crime that's right and it's and i
i said in the beginning it's a fair
point to make you have not been
you have not been found guilty of the
first arrest um but i do think the state
has a compelling interest to take a
better look at you um
going back to it
for all i know this gets them through
the system faster
but one of the complaints that i heard
from stakeholders was that the bail
commissioners don't do their job
the bill when you speak with the bill
commissioners they say they're operating
under instructions from the judges
in my opinion the judges can be held
accountable they have internal review
internal review boards um i i don't
believe in you know they are a co-equal
branch of government to us and they do
have accountability measures within
their own body and i think that they
need to be held to that versus saying oh
well that's just what the bail
commissioner did
representative true
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
i understand
uh
the the problems people feel we have
with pr veil
my concern is
a person losing their freedom
uh because we feel that they've got
problems with pr bail
you had mentioned that
about people being released again and
again and again
don't you feel if somebody's being
released again and again and again
that probably has nothing to do with pr
bail but that's a problem with the
courts
no i believe pr bill is a part of that
that's my personal that's my personal
opinion once again representative and mr
chairman
i don't believe that there's the will of
the body of concord unfortunately to
address what i think is the underlying
problem so i'm trying to find a middle
ground forward for these for these
repeat most likely repeat offenders now
once again they have not been
adjudicated guilty i acknowledge that in
my opening testimony
and i'm not going to sit up here for all
i know when they've been arrested six
times they're innocent six times that's
the standard that innocent until proven
guilty hol is we hold to but we do know
that there are compelling state
interests and i'm trying to
assert that interest and fight for the
community who is affected by the
repeated release of sometimes violent
criminals but um many times they're not
many times it's you know burglary or um
you know vandalism
but it's if you're if you're already out
on bail in my opinion you should
probably be on good behavior
um
but
you know sometimes you're not and
to the representative's point from dover
um
this will act as a somewhat deterrent
representative muse
thank you for taking my question um
would you agree that if the second crime
doesn't involve a jail sentence there
should be an exception for that
so uh
no because they're
we're still arresting them they're still
going to booking they're still going
through that they're just going through
a slightly different process so if you
can be arrested
let's say it's the first arrest right
for whatever this crime is that has no
no no no possibility of jail time right
they can still be arrested and still go
through it um they can still go through
get pr bail they're still they're still
being taken to jail
second arrest we're still taking them to
jail we're just putting them through a
slightly different process which i
believe is at a higher it's set to a
higher standard
thank you
representative newman
i just like some clarification on the
number of hours that we've talked about
detainment i
i thought i heard 36 hours
and i look at line seven in the in the
bill as i got it off the table there
that says they shall be detained for a
period of not more than 72 hours
correct so i sent uh some kind of
difficulty with that i will give you the
amendment number that i sent chairman
abbas uh it is amendment uh
uh
2022-05898
if i had not had left my computer in
manchester today i would have had
printed copies for you um but it
replaces all references to 36 of two of
72 hours to 36 hours thank you
and the chairman has that amendment and
i would highly if you do
if the committee sees fit to pass this
bill
you must pass that amendment otherwise
it will not withstand constitutional
muster
and to be clear by chairman they mean
the one who's not here and that's me the
other one is the other chairman because
uh seeing no further questions thank you
for testimony thank you so much the
committee now calls buzz sure
for the record only since i i know
you've heard this already my name is
buzz sher i'm a police commissioner in
portsmouth unh law professor
the opinions i expressed today are my
own and not those of either unh law unh
or the portsmouth police commission
first um i
i apologize for what i'm about to say in
in some ways but it is
bothered me deeply
uh over the last four years you know uh
i've been involved since the beginning
in bail reform
i authored the bail reform bill that was
presented by
senator feltus three or four years ago
so i'm very familiar with this area it
is offensive
for anyone to talk about the problem
here as catch and release
the people that we're talking about are
human beings many of whom have mental
illness problems many of whom have
substance abuse problems many of whom
are
are homeless they are not fish
and the term
catch and release treats them like that
so i would ask everybody who testifies
and on this committee to uh please do
not use the term catch and release it is
immensely disrespectful
so let me clear up
uh a number of myths that uh
related to bail reform the original bail
reform bill was not a pr bail not a
personal recognizance bill
it was a bill that that dealt with two
problems
one the fact that judges were holding
people without effectively without bail
poor people effectively without bail by
setting bail at a hundred dollars or
fifty dollars or two hundred dollars
with no attention whatsoever to whether
they could meet that amount and
and the original bill got rid of that
practice and basically said
if you can prove somebody is dangerous
or if you can prove they are a risk of
fleeing you can hold them without bail
and it expanded the number of crimes for
which mis class a misdemeanors and
felonies for which you could hold people
without bail and we got rid of the
artifice the the false idea of using
setting bail as a way to hold people and
we got rid of people being held on minor
crimes
on a hundred dollars bail because they
were poor that's what the bill was it
wasn't a pr bail bill so i disagree with
the ongoing reference to the original
bail or form as pr bail bill it
resulted in as one superintendent said
at the first of the two bail commissions
that followed
it resulted not only in poor dangerous
people being held it also resulted in
rich dangerous people being held which
was a change from the pre-bail reform
act
um
number
i've got my numbers now and i've lost my
numbers there we go
um
there's this misunderstanding there's
this myth that we're doing nothing under
the current statute
to hold people who to to pay attention
to people who have
been arrested on one charge and then
while on pr bail are arrested on another
charge the current bail reform statute
consistently from its first iteration
three or four years ago through the the
practices recommended by the first veil
commission adopted by this legislature
through the practices recommended by the
second bail commission
uh and adopted by the legislature both
bail commissions which had
a majority of law enforcement on the
commissions including individuals from
the manchester police department
um
there are provisions in the current bail
bill to deal differently with people who
are repeat
arrestees
it's not like this is oh here's a great
new idea let's deal with people who are
repeat arrestees there are provisions in
there measured provisions dealt with
through
consultation with all the stakeholders
all the stakeholders includes not just
members of the manchester police
department
not just members of prosecutorial
authorities but it includes defense
lawyers uh it include and includes civil
libertarians it includes bail
commissioners uh it includes legislators
that's what the bail commissions were
about this is yet another bill coming
before this body that is a one
stakeholder bill this is a
bill from
that it serves the interest of the
manchester police department there are
different interests at other police
departments it's not the case that every
police department uh would be in support
of this bill uh regardless of what the
police chiefs would say
number
four it's uh
it's
really important that
the people were
talking about here are the mentally ill
those with substance abuse issues and
homeless people
the huge majority of people who are
arrested for a violent felony the first
time
and if if in fact they are released
which isn't normally the case if in fact
they are not held without bail and
arrested for another violent felony
they're going to be held
now i'm sure you'll hear a parade of
anecdotes that says differently but
they're just anecdotes and some of those
anecdotes are predate the changes that
the first and second bail commissions
made so what we're talking about is
people charged with minor offenses who
are
to to to use a colloquial term a pain in
the neck
you know they're not committing serious
crimes
they're on the fringes of the criminal
justice system
they're likely uh homeless they're
either homeless or they have substance
abuse issues
or they have mental health issues
this is yet another effort to solve
the societal problems of substance abuse
mental illness and homelessness using
the criminal justice system and it
doesn't work
putting somebody in jail because they're
a repeat misdemeanor low-level
misdemeanor offender and they're
mentally ill
is a bad thing it's not they don't get
the kind of treatment they need in jail
jail is not a healthy thing for someone
who's mentally ill
or homeless
or has a substance abuse problem
so
this bill is much more of deals
that changes this make
don't improve whether violent second
arrestees are held
it makes it much more likely that
somebody charged with a class b
misdemeanor
you know a minor a shoplifting of some
you know
a mother who keeps shoplifting to get
diapers for her kids or that kind of
crime that's what this is targeted at
um
practically speaking there's no
deterrence in
arresting someone not having them go in
front of a bail commissioner
them having them go in front of a judge
and being released 36 to
you know 96 hours later
depending on whether they're arrested on
a saturday friday or saturday
um
you know the people who are committing
these crimes
this
get out of your minds if it's there this
idea that these are these people who are
horrible criminals
you know the huge majority of people
committing
minor crisis misdemeanors and class b
misdemeanors
are people who are really struggling in
their lives and this bill
wants to get them sweep them off the
street and put them in jail pre-trial
rather than use
other mechanisms for dealing with it and
it's just
i understand
some of the frustration but it's the
wrong way to deal with it
uh
i know at least one other person will
talk about
uh
the data that's out there but briefly
when bail from the time bail reform was
not in effect
to a year or so year to two after it
went into effect
the crime rate in manchester went down
so
let's be careful
in buying into these stories that things
are out of control in manchester they
are not out of control in manchester
the manchester police department does an
excellent job
and
we do not need this change
representative newman
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
we don't i i don't have a copy of the
amendment i think it may be coming but
i've heard testimony i think i heard
testimony that said that they it would
uh keep people from being able to see a
bail commissioner
and
just for my benefit could you kind of uh
talk about what kind of impact that has
on the people that you have not having
ability to have access to a bail
commissioner
it keeps them in
just just to set the scene when somebody
is arrested
they usually they now they go in front
of a bail commission
commissioner
and the bail commissioner listens to
what the police officer has to say
there's no defense lawyer there they go
in front of uh they
they listen to what the police officer
has to say and if the individual has
anything to say they'll listen to them
then they set bail
then if they're held
then an arraignment is scheduled if
they're held by the by the bail the
police commissioner sets then they see a
judge
usually within a day or so
this bill takes that bail commissioner
step
out of the mix so they they get no
initial screening of whether they
deserve bail or not they wait until they
get to see a judge and and that you know
that creates an a a large number of
extra hearings uh for the court system
and and uh of inc significantly
increased costs which i believe another
witness will talk about
you
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
um
it just showed up the amendment have you
seen it i have not
what's that i have not oh okay i just
wanted to know what your opinion was my
understanding is that instead of 72
hours it's 36 hours
is that what the amendment says
i just got it follow up
okay
so uh you
know the problem is if you're arrested
on friday afternoon after the
there's not a judge available
you're held
24 hours to saturday 48 hours till
sunday and then there's 36 more hours
another day and a half so you might not
get a hearing until sometime on tuesday
even if you were arrested on friday
so i you know i think that's still an
issue
uh it puts it
and then it also puts because of the
increase in the number of hearings that
are going to be required
it puts the courts uh certainly the
monday and tuesday docket of circuit
courts and superior courts
under a lot of stress to handle
everybody held over the weekend within
the 36 hours period starting on monday
morning
for a hearing
this is one of the problems that
sb 92 that made it to the house floor
had it you know it increased the cost to
courts by millions of dollars man and
this bill has that same problem
thank you
representative panalakas
thank you mr chairman
professor
with all the problems we've had with the
bail bill
uh from the seacoast
to the north country
we just not clarify the law a little bit
for them
this one bill
this won't improve the problems that are
out there
um
uh you know
i think we
oversize
the degree to which we hear that there
are problems
based on the bail reform act you know
crime rights around the straight state
not only in manchester are going down
i think what needs to happen is we need
to gather all the stakeholders together
and not have yet another bill from
the police chiefs or from one police
department and we need to gather all the
stakeholders together like we've done
before
to solve this problem a complicated
problem it intersects with social
services uh it intersects with any
number of uh
issues and to deal with this on a once
one stakeholder basis i think is the
wrong way to do it i freely acknowledge
the criminal justice system has got
significant issues to deal with and
you know i
would love to participate in any any
comprehensive effort multi-stakeholder
effort to deal with them but this
doesn't do that it's it's trying to
fix something that actually doesn't need
fixing
second question
this does not just pertain
to me and chester i agree i have had
heard these complaints
from seabrook clear up in the north
country
and we've had two
commissions
meeting and they have not resolved this
problem
so
wouldn't this law just classify it uh i
don't
uh respectfully uh representative
penalakis
i don't think it will
it it it's a it's using a sledgehammer
to try and kill
something that's closer in size to a
mosquito
uh than you know
uh something other than bigger than that
and and
uh i agree there's a problem
but one stakeholder solutions are not
work are not the way to try and solve
the problem because the criminal justice
system is complicated
represent muse
thank you for taking my question one of
the things that we hear about
anecdotally and this is in portsmouth
and manchester and i think a lot of
other communities is
the the frustration that police have
with dealing with folks who are
shoplifters and a lot of times there are
gangs that come in from out of state and
cars and things like that
um
there seemed to be some real logistical
issues around
being able to hold people for crimes
like that so i i guess what i would ask
you is is there
is there a middle ground that's not in
this bill
that maybe we should be looking at yeah
there may be um i i
i recognize that problem practically
speaking uh if it's a
quote-unquote shoplifting uh gang um if
they're released once on pr bail
they're not coming back to the state
so i i think this bill doesn't deal with
that um
or if it does it's already dealt with in
the the bill as it exists that has
repeat arrestees provisions in it so you
know i think there uh
i think there may be
other ways of making a dent in that
problem i i don't think they're easy
answers but again i think we need a
multi-stakeholder
uh problem solving group to do that
rather than
one stakeholder
solving
representative testament
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
isn't there a
purpose
of the police department
to keep the citizens
safe
sane
and
and feeling comfortable i hate to say
just feeling comfortable
and the kinds of crimes that we're
talking about
or you talk about the shoplifting that
really aren't
if you get a lot of people shoplifting i
don't feel safe going into a shop
i don't you know it
a certain amount of respect and a
certain amount of
of you know ability to to go about my
business yeah
don't doesn't this
you know this would stop some of the the
second
or third time this person
did that i mean
i i i know you're you're you're enamored
with this commission you were part of
and they did a wonderful job but it
isn't working
i um
i recognized your concern for safety and
being able to
go into stores without fear of getting
in the way of shoplifters
but shoplifting hasn't because of bail
reform
shoplifting hasn't skyrocketed anywhere
in new hampshire because of bail reform
this has been an enduring problem that
we continue to struggle with
and
i want solutions to this but i want good
solutions not just facial solutions that
seem to sound good i have to say you
look around the country
and you
you look at those jurisdictions where
there's been bail reform
and every single police department
regardless of the fact and almost new
york city is a good example that bail
reform went into effect in new york city
the crime rate new york city has gone
down 98 percent of the people who were
released under the bail reform act in
that involved new york city and new york
state 98 of them did not commit another
crime
so um
there's
what we're talking about is issues where
we need to balance
civil liberties we need to
balance the desire of the police
to sol to to deal with
uh citizens concerns with public safety
there's a whole bunch of complicated
issues um you know i
i didn't get
virtually anything
i was interested in getting out of the
second bell commission
you know so
uh i'm enamored of the process i'm not
necessarily i was not necessarily
enamored of the result but it's a better
way to do it
we always screw up when we let one
stakeholder decide the way we're going
to do it
there being no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you
the committee now calls the honorable
victoria sullivan
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee my name is victoria sullivan
and i reside in manchester new hampshire
and i am afraid that my testimony is
going to further anger the gentleman who
preceded me
just six days after being released on pr
bail amari diol was arrested for
allegedly raping a woman for two hours
at the valley street cemetery deol has a
criminal record dating back to 2011. i
do not believe that being raped in the
cemetery for two hours is anecdotal
enrique castro hit a child in the back
of the head and threatened to hit
another with a hammer despite having
numerous interactions with the
manchester police department castro was
released on pr bail
most recently just this week tanisha
ozuno allegedly went to a residence on
somerville street to talk about the
involvement of her significant other
with another woman
evidence presented indicates that the
victim was attacked with some form of
weapon while she was holding a young
child although the child was not injured
the victim required emergency treatment
to close a significant wound a zuma was
released on personal recognizance bail
with several stipulations including
having a
curfew and having her firearms removed
from her address i ask you if this
person was not viewed as a threat why
were there so many stipulations
surrounding her release
in 2018 then senate
then state senator dan feltes was the
prime sponsor of senate bill 556 which
changed the bail laws to allow for any
person claiming they were indigent to be
released on their own personal
recognizance this created a system
whereby people were released with no
known address no financial reason to
appear in court no responsibility for
their alleged actions
this in turn did in fact create a catch
and release program which has resulted
in repeat offenders going on to commit
violent acts let me be clear
no person should be held simply because
they are too impoverished to pay their
bill all people are innocent until
proven guilty however there is a clear
pattern of systemic abuse of this bail
reform which is endangering our
citizenry
this has been a frustration for police
departments around the state who work to
get gender dangerous people off the
streets only to see them released within
hours
i had the honor of serving with many of
you
my voting record supports the fact that
i am a liberty minded person i believe
in bill reform but i also believe in
consequences for actions
come spend some time in manchester and
you can see the direct impact to our
community when people are let out on pr
bill they often do not appear back in
court because they have nothing on the
line they end up hiding in our growing
encampments and go on to commit
additional crimes increasing the crime
in our streets
my liberty liberty is being stripped as
a consequence of this bill my neighbor's
liberties are being stripped as a
consequence of this bill and is
significantly impacting our downtown
businesses
our
our law enforcement officers are using
resources on repeat offenders that we
need elsewhere
now there was a comment saying that this
impacts manchester and maybe some of the
other cities well first of all
manchester is the largest city in the
state so it's going to be impacted more
at a greater rate however
we have a court in our city when people
show up for their court date they come
to manchester when they're released on
pr bail they end up in our streets so it
does have a significant impact on our
city that you won't see in towns that
don't have a courtroom so i ask you to
please support
hb1476
amended to give our city some relief we
cannot carry the burden of the entire
state we can't and our officers are
working out there every day fighting the
opioid epidemic fighting the crimes in
the street trying to help the homeless
and we are not doing it without a heart
as as has been sort of um
referred to here we don't say catch and
release because we are heartless people
we have resources for people and we try
to help them but there is a line between
helping people and hurting our citizenry
and we have crossed that line and we
need to pull it back so i thank you
and the witness thank you for your
testimony
the committee now calls ross connolly
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is ross
connolly i'm the deputy state director
for americans for prosperity here in new
hampshire and uh this will be a bill
that the two rosses diverge on
unfortunately uh
we are in strong opposition to hb4 1476
as it is currently written
uh the way we view this is uh really
there's been multiple iterations now
uh that this committee and and others
have gone through uh with trying to to
address issues when it comes to bail
reform in new hampshire we view this
bill to be the most
threatening to the
due process rights of granite staters it
puts every defendant in one size fits
all boxes
it has no discretion to to the uh the
type of crime uh the seriousness of the
crime and and we view that as as uh a
mistake i i will point out that we we
did provide the sponsors of this bill
with suggested language uh that we would
be totally comfortable with it addressed
violent crime uh uh re-offenses and and
especially the the issue in manchester
of continually uh some folks continually
being charged at the same location with
trespassing we did provide language for
that but unfortunately it was not
adopted by the sponsors we would be
happy to send that to the committee if
if members are interested
um
really i we understand the the concerns
from the
the proponents of of this legislation
and others like it
the intent of the 2018 law
uh was never
uh to result in violent criminals being
released uh in fact in the law it
plainly states that if an individual is
suspected to be a danger to themselves
or the community they shall be held
our language our proposed language was
was to really clarify that in statute
and and show that these you know xyz
violent crimes
should not be considered for uh for for
release um
really
what we worry about is is
misdemeanors
you know areas of of criminal code that
don't actually uh
aren't actually a direct threat to uh to
the public and and
uh again putting every everybody in a
one-size-fits-all box uh we we just
believe is is not the correct way to
address some of these very targeted
targeted issues there are a lot of
anecdotes they should not be happening
uh to the previous speaker's uh point
those those anecdotes should not be
happening under current statute we're
happy to work with with uh the committee
to try and address those those anecdotes
but they they are just that they they
are outliers in in what's happening in
practice uh to attorney sher's point uh
so we we urge the committee to
as this bill stands uh to move this bill
in expedient to legislate but again
happy to to work with the committee on
uh any improvements that that you may uh
be looking to do and i'd be happy to
take any questions
i'm going to recognize myself for the
first question
you said you found that this was the
most dangerous of a slate of bills that
were addressing bail reform
and i'm i'm curious it's it's it's kind
of ironic that this bail this bill
actually um
actually mandates someone be able to get
in front of a judge to plead their case
which is the the nature of habeas corpus
it's the nature of our law system to put
them in front of a judge who has the
power to make decisions versus a bail
commissioner who's got very limited
authority so what makes someone being
able to get in front of a judge so
dangerous
uh thank you for the question mr
chairman uh it's because they shall be
held uh so so they will be held uh in
detention uh
until they they see that judge and uh we
view that as as a threat to do process
rights for granite staters
and uh
we we just
we understand again
the going to see a judge is a good thing
one we have a backlog already in our
judicial system
a lot of these crimes are non-violent
crimes addressing violent crime
is perfectly appropriate in our mind
we should not be releasing people that
are threat to the community
however
prison jail are not solutions to drug
crime to mental illness to the previous
speaker's points
these are not solutions if anything that
sometimes they exacerbate uh criminal
activity uh there's a famous george jung
quote that he went to
uh
before he went to prison he had a
bachelor's in marijuana and he graduated
with a with a doctorate in cocaine uh
it's not really the solution for every
single crime in treating every single
second offense in this one-size-fits-all
box
is is not appropriate in our mind
representative lynn yes i wonder if i
could ask you in your view if somebody
if somebody commits a shoplifting and
they get arrested and they get released
on bail and the next day they commit
another shoplifting maybe at the same
place maybe at another business and they
get arrested and they can get released
on bail and they do it a third time and
a fourth time if at what point if any in
your view do they become a danger to the
public
thank you for the question
representative i i would agree that that
those those uh people repeat constant
repeat offenders in this case
shoplifting
i know the sponsor had a concern about
trespassing that's what we
provided language for but uh i i don't
know of specific examples i've seen in
other states this happening the sort of
crowd
funding
of shoplifting that's happening that
that would not be appropriate we we
would not uh want to see those people
continually released uh
so i
again we would be happy to provide
language that's that does uh
still protect due process but in
specific
cases of concern uh we're we're willing
to work with the committee to sort of
address those especially when it comes
to shoplifting trespassing repeat
offenses should not uh
be constantly happening follow-up ask
your phone just you know you talk about
due process i mean i i
i assume you're talking about sort of
your view of what due process should be
because i haven't heard anybody
including professor scherer
say that being brought before a judge
within 24 hours to have a hearing
somehow violates due process and i'm not
aware of anything that would say that
that does violate due process
thank you for the question
representative our our big concern is
this is going backwards towards
criminalizing people for being poor
and if you just can't afford bail
we don't think that should be a reason
to hold somebody um
when it comes to the repeat offenses
again we're willing to to uh compromise
on those issues uh when it comes to due
process we we believe that you are
innocent until proven guilty and and
that should be respected and uh
unless in in some of these anecdotal
circumstances
uh of of of crimes
happening on a repeated basis uh that
that people shouldn't be held just
because they can't afford it
thank you testimony thank you very much
the committee now calls richard head
judicial branch
good afternoon mr chair members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch
um as you may not be surprised i'm here
to talk about the potential impact this
bill would have on the circuit courts
not so much to address the policy behind
this bill
the
you know
i've had multiple conversations with
this committee in in with regard to a
number of bills when senate bill 92 was
before you
we talked about
the potential increase in cases in the
circuit court of around 3 000 cases
that bill by the way does exist again
this this session as senate bill 294
in in that issue is is still going to
probably be brought for you again what i
don't know and i can't tell you is how
many cases this covers because we we
sort of know how many of the
misdemeanors that that would be
at issue under under the senate bill 92
scenario what we don't track is how many
times somebody is rearrested because we
don't really know that we don't have
that data it doesn't come to us so i
can't tell you you know this will result
in x number of additional hearings
before a circuit court judge
but what i what i do know is the scope
of the bill which is all felonies all
misdemeanors
class a misdemeanors class b
misdemeanors all felonies all all
misdemeanors
and
just judging from the testimony it could
potentially be a number of cases you
know maybe even a significant number of
cases and when we're talking in circuit
court what i'm talking about is three
divisions because all judges virtually
all judges in circuit court hear from
all the divisions so they're hearing
probate division cases they're hearing
circuit
i'm sorry
district division cases and family
division cases so in any particular day
their docket can be filled with these
these types of cases
and then on top of that with really no
notice are
bail hearings because they're coming in
probably being either transported from a
county jail or
there's a video arraignment that's
occurring depending on whether or not
there's video time available
there's an actual hearing that has to
occur in front of a judge because these
would otherwise have been handled in
front of a bail commissioner so we now
have another hearing event that is
occurring in front of a circuit court
judge who already has a complete docket
all i'm all
i'm talking all i'm suggesting is that
these bills have a significant impact
on the circuit court on the circuit
court judges and
probably even more especially on the
staff in these circuit courts because
they're involved in the paperwork the
scheduling and getting keeping
everything moving and the burden is
incredible these days you know as i said
relative to the last hearing they're
approximately pending at the end of 2021
just under a
691 cases pending
there are 46 full-time judges in in
circuit court there's two senior judges
and one marital master it is a huge
volume of cases so every time there is a
change in the system that puts more
cases in front of those judges you're
pushing into a system that is full
and the more that happens the greater
the chance at some point we're just
going to hit that point of one too many
um
and so all i all i suggest is one this
will have a fiscal impact it will
need some additional resources
especially in the four busiest
circuit courts manchester concord nashua
and keene
those are the ones that are probably
going to see the greatest impact from
this type of bill bill
it currently has a 60-day effective date
what i would suggest one is
and i've mentioned this statute before
rsa 14 colon 9-a
addresses effective dates
and talks about any uh any bill or any
law that affects judicial process and
procedure
uh establishes or eliminates criminal
prohibitions civil causes or remedies or
limitations of actions shall take place
shall take effect january 1 of the
following year at a minimum we would ask
that the january 1 effective date be be
implemented but really what we would be
asking is that
give give this bill an opportunity to be
heard as part of the budget process also
at least not the bill but the but the
fiscal impact because we're not in a
budget year
so we are going to see impacts occurring
if this becomes effective sooner
within the circuit courts which are
already overwhelmed and you're just
going to see you know that those cases
that can get pushed get pushed civil
cases will get pushed other things get
pushed and there's delays in the system
and our goal is to try to keep things
moving to keep things expedited
and these types of bills require
resources so one other ask is at a
minimum january one effective date but
really if we can push it to after the
budget is passed
as an effective date even to the bill
passes uh that way we can address those
resources needs as well as the sort of
cumulative resource issues that are seen
in in the bills um that that are in in
front of this session not only senator
bradley's sb 294
but the bill that was heard in judiciary
which would rewind felonies first
that will be heard on the floor of of
the of the house that's about roughly
another 6 000 cases that would be coming
into the circuit courts that are not
currently in the circuit courts you know
this cumulative effect of these of these
bills
is having a a significant as the
likelihood of a significant
negative impact on the circuit courts
that will require resources and i think
to be able to do some of that in the
budget process is is really the most
reasonable way of trying to approach it
thank you very much and i would be happy
to answer any questions
i i have a question
um
prior to the bail reform bill of 2016
has there been a significant cut in
judicial staff
so that adding this
in other words this isn't really
unless there's been a significant cut in
judicial staff this isn't adding
anything more than was already on the
plate in 2016 is that correct
truthfully i didn't practice criminal
law and didn't wasn't in the court
system back then so i actually don't
know what the balance was uh in terms of
post pre sort of that that sort of
i don't know what the difference was uh
truthfully and so i couldn't answer that
i think the
the other aspect of it though is other
burdens that have been added since then
also
because every legislative cycle there
tends to be some additional changes that
are that are implemented
thank you um representative bourne has a
question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
if we were to have no more arrests in
the state
no more new cases
put before us
uh
how long would you could you give me an
estimate how much time it would take for
the court systems to clear
a little over a year
uh so we we roughly get 175 000 filings
a year
it really depends on the case too so
some just by their nature take longer
some are very quick
um
so if we get in 175 000 we're up to
around around 200 000 now
into 175 new ones we're pending around
200 there's about a 25 000 increase gap
between those some of that is covid
related but really the circuit court has
has worked down a lot of its covet
backlogs um
so you know more than a year how much
more than a year i i don't know
thank you and and actually let me take
one step back in that's just criminal
docket you know with
that 175 the 200 that's all of the all
of the circuit all of the districts so
that's you know
district division
um uh probate and and family division um
so we're just cutting out the criminal
which is the
highest number within within
circuit court you know those tend to get
cleared out and could get cleared out
probably within a year
essentially no new ones were coming in
representative
thank you for taking my question
um on bills like this that are that are
framed as fixing flaws in the judicial
system one of the things that we hear a
lot is
we hear a lot about the importance of
fixing those flaws regardless of the
impact on the judicial system
what are some of the unintended
consequences that happen in your opinion
when we take that kind of an approach
and in particular if we were to take
that approach with this bill
um so thank you for the question the you
know the the
impact any time of of adding
especially in in the criminal context
which has
certain constitutional overlays and and
statutory overlays in terms of timing
and
processing is it simply means other
types of cases get pushed later so civil
cases small claim
cases that don't have the same
uh type of of statutory or
constitutional requirements
get her
sort of get filtered in where they can
but they don't have the same
deadline they're not driven by the same
deadline so they just get pushed later
so it just may be a significant period
of time before
a small claims case gets reached
it also is you know increases
you know the the stress on
staff is tremendous in terms of you know
they're managing
you know 200 000 cases scheduling
getting them in the docket putting them
in front of the judge getting notices
out mistakes happen too and and you just
increase the the
rate of error
to the extent those happen they do it
just a remarkable job
but i think the primary one is is you
just move
a certain class and certain types of of
cases to the back of the line
so that they just
it takes a very long time to get them
reached
thank you for testimony thank you
the committee now calls stephen andre's
merrimack county attorney's office
good afternoon my name is stephen
hendricks i'm an attorney with the
merrimack county attorney's office
i've been a prosecutor for a little over
20 years now
i've appeared in circuit court
pretty much every day from
november 2003 to the start of the
pandemic in march of uh
i don't that was 2019 or 2020 now
but
um
listening to representative barry's
comments about this bill
the takeaway to me
is that he said when a person is
re-arrested who's out on bail
they shouldn't be brought before a bail
commissioner they should be brought
before a judge
and i absolutely agree with that and i
think that's a fantastic idea
um
we've talked a little bit about
shoplifting
and
when a person's arrested for shoplifting
they're brought back to the police
station they go through booking
a bail commissioner is called
the bill commissioner would come meet
with that person
and make a determination of whether or
not that person is a risk of flight or
danger to the community
if they're not a risk of flight or a
danger to the community they'd be
released on personal recognizance bail
and in my opinion that's appropriate
but personal recognizance fail comes
with some conditions
and one of those conditions is that you
remain of good behavior
meaning that while you're released on
personal recognizance bail you don't
commit additional crimes
if you're released on personal
recognizance bail and you do commit an
additional crime
you've broken your promise to the court
to remain of good behavior
so it absolutely makes sense to me that
instead of having a bail commissioner
come and perhaps set pr bail a second
time that you should have to go in front
of a judge
and the judge may set pr bail the judge
may set cash bail the judge may set
preventative detention depending on the
facts of the case
but it certainly makes sense to go back
in front of a judge
with reference to
these hearings
we do bail hearings in circuit court
every day
it's not uncommon to have
hearings within 24 hours or 36 hours
under 594 20a
so this isn't something that we're not
used to doing
if we don't do the hearing within 24 to
36 hours and the person's released on pr
bail by the bail commissioner we're
still doing an arraignment but it may be
30 days down the road
one of the
and i'm sure if you spoke to any
prosecutor any law enforcement officer
all of us could tell you
stories for hours about people who have
been arrested released on pr bail
arrested again released on pr bail
arrested again released on pr bail and
it continues to happen over and over and
over again
when we talk about the number of filings
in court
i can't help think that maybe if a
person is arrested and released on pr
bail
and arrested a second time
and then brought before the judge
maybe there won't be a third time
they're arrested when they're on pr bail
maybe there won't be a fourth time
maybe those filings would actually go
down
the the difficulty that i have with
um
house bill 1476
is
i actually really like this section of
597.28
the way it currently is written
and i can certainly answer questions
about why i like that or why i think
this section exists
i think if the issue is that
the bail commissioners shouldn't be
setting bail on people who are
released
already on bail
bail commissioners have statutory
authority under 597.18
i would suggest that perhaps amending
the bail commissioner's statutory
authority under 597.18
to indicate that bail commissioners are
unable to set bail
on a person who's already out on bail
and that's not an unprecedented thing in
new hampshire law if you violate a
protective voter under 173 the bill
commissioner has no authority to set
bail you have to go in front of the
judge
we've been doing that for years
we could certainly mirror that with
people that are currently released on
bail
so that they do in fact go in front of
the court which again
makes sense to me that the judge would
be the person to decide what the
subsequent bail is
i'd be happy to answer any questions yes
representative boardnet
thank you
thank you for answering my question
i'm not sure this bill is necessary i'm
looking at rsa
597 colon
7-a which
does talk about detention and sanctions
for the fault of breach of conditions so
if a
person is a
br does break their terms of condition
they are brought before judges
is that not true
that is not necessarily true under 597
7a
the detention for sanctions for bail we
can file an additional charge of breach
of bail if you violate your bail
conditions
so the way that potentially works is
going back to the shoplifting example a
person shoplifts they're released on pr
they shoplift a second time
they're again released on pr bail
the second time i can not only file a
shoplifting charge but i can file an
additional breach of bail charge
but they would still potentially be
released on pr bail by a bail
commissioner that person could go out a
third time and i've certainly had this
experience where after being charged
with breach of bail
they violate their bail conditions again
by committing a new crime and they again
are released by on by a bail
commissioner on personal recognizance
bail
under 597 7a i can file a motion asking
that their bail be revoked
my experience with that though is that
those motions
get scheduled
in the regular course in court
so i may file a motion to revoke
someone's bail but i may not get a
hearing on that for 30 to 45 days after
it's filed
i've
had the experience that during that 30
to 45 days while my motion revoked bail
is pending the person is again arrested
and i was shocked that they were
released on personal recognizance bail
despite the fact that there was a motion
to revoke their bail pending
follow-up
so i i'm looking at paragraph five in
this uh rsa
our paragraph one
uh and a sentence says the accused will
be brought before a justice for a bell
rick devotion hearing within 48 hours
isn't isn't that a judge or is that
another bill conditioner
you're the
597a paragraph one yes
you certainly could bring the person
before it justice um
however there is the provisions of the
statute and now
the rules of criminal procedure which
indicate that a person's entitled to a
bail commissioner
so
i believe most of the police when
they're arresting people for
crimes that they've committed while out
on bail
still see bail commissioners
go ahead additional follow-up
thank you
so maybe rather than writing a new
section of law we should
make
look at paragraph one
and make it uh required that it is a
judge in a court that it does here has
the hearing
i certainly think there's other statutes
you could amend as i said earlier
in terms of amending the bail
commissioner statute you could certainly
amend 597 7a to strengthen those clauses
but i
i do think there are certainly other
statutes you could amend to accomplish
the goal that if a person is arrested
while out on bail they see a judge
instead of a bail commissioner
thank you
very much
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
we've heard testimony that these
individuals who tend to fall into the
category of offense that's
really at issue here
tend to be committing
victimless crimes
or that
or that they're extremely minor and i'm
wondering in your experience
do these crimes have victims and i'm
also curious if you could address what
the victim
might share with you when they learn
that this offender is out on bail
with reference to whether these crimes
have victims i think that
you could have an academic debate on
that
if i'm the manager of mcdonald's
and i have a homeless person for example
who comes into my restaurant
and sits down at a booth doesn't
purchase anything
and falls asleep and i politely ask that
person to leave and they refuse to leave
and i call the police the police come
ask the person please leave they refuse
to leave they're arrested for trespass
they're released on personal
recognizance bail and they come back to
my store
i think i'm the victim as the owner of
that mcdonald's or as the franchisee
that
i can't control who's coming in and out
of my premises
so i certainly think some of these
repeat crimes like trespassing or
shoplifting
absolutely have
tangible victims
we've certainly also had
the experience where i can think of a
gentleman who is out on personal
recognizance bail
and i would agree with
attorney sure that this person probably
was suffering from mental health issues
he
felt that somebody had walked past him
and knocked over his coffee which
my understanding is that his coffee fell
over while this person was walking past
him and he proceeded to violently attack
that person and send them to the
hospital
i don't know if i personally care if the
person is who's beating me up has mental
health issues or if they're just a jerk
if i'm being beat up by someone who's
out on bail that's not right
and we certainly have
experienced
input from members of the public with
frustration
why is this person out to begin with
when we have repeat offenses from people
on bail
thank you
representative newman
thank you chair
um thank you for taking my question and
it seems to me that this whole
discussion has to do with this one word
shall or may one gives discretion and
one does eliminates discretion
and i'm it seems like the testimony that
i'm hearing is that bail commissioners
just always give out personal
recognizance bail
and that when they go before a judge
that won't happen i
i'm just confused why
if both of them are i guess they're both
judicial officers
why we're addressing this problem by
taking away discretion i think for both
judges and bail commissioners if you get
arrested on a friday night you you could
be there for
up to 72 hours even with the exclusions
in the 36. that that's the concern i
have
i agree that both judges and bail
commissioners have discretion
it
not to give antidotal evidence because i
don't know that that's necessarily
appropriate but it's been my experience
that people are more likely to get
personal recognizance bail from a bail
commissioner than a judge
um
but again that that's just my personal
opinion
i don't think that this statute would
take discretion away from judges and i
think that
we all want judges to have discretion to
set the hell as appropriate
the shell in this amendment
means that the person shall be detained
to be brought before a judge
so it would take the discretion away
from the bail commissioners not
necessarily the judges
thank you
no further questions thank you for your
testimony thank you
the committee now calls paul halvorson
merrimack county attorney
good afternoon
i'm paul halverson merrimack county
attorney attorney enduras covered many
of the items that i was going to address
so i'll defer to his testimony
i do have some additional comments
though
one of the issues one of the reasons
bail exists
in its current format is to address the
issue of public safety
when you're looking at individuals that
are released on bail and reoffending
while out on bail
albeit one two three four seven times
the issue becomes one of public safety
and as attorney andres pointed out
the proper venue in in
my opinion too is that when you violate
a promise to the court
the person to address that should be the
judge of that court
the
amendment that attorney andrus mentioned
moving
the
change under
597.18 to limit the powers of a bail
commissioner frankly i believe is a much
easier methodology
to attain what i believe is the goal of
the proponent of the bill and that is to
to have a serious look by a judicial
officer namely a judge on someone who's
already been released on
on some sort of bail yet continues to
violate the
the terms of that bail and the promise
to the court
and i do think that's appropriate
the harsh reality is
that there are there are there is a
small group of people which commit a
larger number of crimes
certainly i think the default setting i
think we can all agree the majority of
people comply with the orders of the
court out on bail the vast majority do
but you have that small population that
becomes a risk to society
and i think you can argue through that
risk to society or risk to themselves
when they repeatedly offend and by
limiting the ability to be released on
bail by a bail commissioner forcing that
individual to go to the court
to account for
their actions in a bail and public
safety arena
is appropriate
um
and as i said the best person to do that
is indeed
a judge not a bail commissioner
there have been several anecdotal
comments throughout today's test
testimony my preparation coming today
over the last couple of days i've had
some telephone conversations and some
email conversations with other
prosecutors throughout the the the state
uh i don't speak for them individually
and so i'll not use their names and they
shared with me some individual cases
that are currently open so i'll not
share the specifics of the cases but i
will share their generalized con
concerns as they were as i understood
them
in
one location a prosecutor mentioned to
me
that an individual was finally held
after a fourth domestic violence charge
now i guess as a as a public policy
measure
what are we telling a victim of domestic
violence or multiple victims of domestic
violence
when that when a person who reoffends
while they're out on bail
is not being held or not being reviewed
by a judge and may be released by a bail
commissioner what kind of public policy
is that
and that's a question that you as a
committee and you as the legislature
have to to address
um
another prosecutor mentioned
that
there was a
defendant in court who is appearing on
multiple failures to appear from several
jurisdictions
again as a public policy matter
what are we saying when an individual is
released on bail
and
not appearing and is really so many
times that he's now has several
prosecutors from several jurisdictions
in court on the same day
to address his behavior in society and
his threat to the individuals within
in society
that's the bigger concern
uh and as i said i agree that limiting
the issue under 597.18 is probably a
more appropriate place
to place this uh attorney sure made a
good point um and i think there'd be
several of the prosecutors that would
agree with me that generally speaking
the bail statute as it's currently
written
generally works it really does
the issue becomes with these several
individuals the small group of
individuals that commit the most the
most offenses
and repeat offenses and it's that small
population we need to address
and i believe one of the ways to address
that is to limit the ability of a bail
commissioner to set bail and for that
person to appear in court as soon as
possible and under the current statute
that would be well within 36 hours
attorney andrus commented about
circuit court issues hearing cases i too
practiced in circuit court
since 2000 uh up until i was elected as
county attorney i appeared frequently in
several counties and probably uh four
counties and seven or eight circuit
courts uh and the job i had before i was
county attorney i was in an office where
we had
upwards of give or take a couple
thousand twenty thousand scheduled
hearings a year
so the attorneys are already
addressing these issues
uh and as was mentioned in prior
testimony in multiple hearings often uh
and um hopefully an amendment to 597-18
to affect the change that i believe the
committee's looking to affect or to pro
or to sponsor this bill is looking to
affect uh would would be a better way to
to accomplish that i'll gladly take any
questions
representative boardney
thank you sure thank you for answering
my question yes sir
so
it seems to be
the issue seems to be that there we have
a lot of people with mental illnesses
that are
uh
committing and recommitting crimes
is there a better solution than putting
them in jail or re-arresting them over
and over again well if i if i knew the
answer to that question i
you know i i'd certainly share it but i
i don't think there's any one answer i
can tell you
that
there are throughout the state i believe
there are multiple
initiatives
to help people navigate the
the myriad of services that are
available i also understand there's been
multiple discussions throughout the
state
that many of the services service
organizations
are underfunded
but that's a question for the
organizations and and and the
legislature i would note that in
merrimack county uh the county uh just
began and just uh just funded in the
budget process uh a position within the
county to help those with substance
abuse and mental health issues navigate
the myriad of services that are
available uh and i was part of that the
discussion and and happy to be part of
it in fact we shifted
of some of the
opioid
settlement money
that was under my office over to assist
in hiring individuals just to accomplish
some of those goals
so you know i think there's a number of
people including myself that are working
towards that goal um what the right
answer is i don't know i wish i did
thank you very much thank you
representative
newman thank you mr chair thank you for
taking my question yes sir
um
would judges be available uh are they
available on the weekend to hear these
kinds of bail cases or would they not be
able to do that and i know the um courts
have on-call judges for uh uh for search
warrants and items such as that i don't
believe they're on call for arraignments
frankly i wish the the state did have a
24-hour arraignment judge
uh and
to handle arrests and arraignments on a
rolling basis many states many
jurisdictions do
and
if they had a 24-hour
pool of judges just for arraignments
on a 24-hour basis individuals can be in
front of judges within hours uh we live
in an electronic world and we're able to
move paperwork seamlessly throughout
throughout the uh the state
but then again that's a that's a matter
for the courts to address and uh and the
legislature to uh to fund frankly i
think would be a great idea uh there are
many prosecutors that really do think it
would be a great idea and frankly that
protects the individual's rights um uh
to a uh to a greater extent than i
believe that a current then current
statutes do i would support that
follow-up
uh in the anecdotal testimony that we've
heard about
arrested released arrested released
arrested released
does that are those people released both
by bail commissioners and judges
i'd have to give you only my observation
i would say more so
with
with um with bail commissioners
but uh
but i deal on in just the superior
courts for the most part now uh the
superior court in merrimack county for
the most part now so i i couldn't
comment on how the trend has changed in
the last year with the with the lower
courts uh other than to say that i do
have several individuals that are
prosecutors within the county that are
telling me that that folks are still
released and re-arrested
several times
thank you
no for other questions the witness is
excused thank you thank you for
testimony
we now call chief oldenburg manchester
pd
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee i will be uh
you have my written testimony mr
chairman i believe but i'm gonna i'm not
gonna read that word for word i'm out of
respect for everybody's time people are
probably already dwindling out of the
room um
prior to the attorney from merrimack
county speaking um
i come to you let me first start as a
chief of police for the city of
manchester um
and there's been a lot of comments today
which some i agree with on both sides
i just want to clear the record that as
a chief of police of manchester i did
not ask the sponsor as was
insinuated by the unh professor that i
asked for this bill
that is not a fair assessment it's not
accurate i'd like to clear the record on
that
we've heard about
impacts on the judicial branch impacts
on the offenders
prior to the gentleman from merrimack
county i haven't heard any discussion
about impact on victims
and why are we having that discussion as
a community
as
a legislative body as law enforcement we
have it every day
so i think that needs to come more to
the forefront victims of domestic
violence child abuse
merchants store owners people that are
losing money
domestic violence victims that are being
offended over and over
it's time for that discussion to come to
the forefront um
you know along the lines of the bail
commissioner under the statue of
597.18 i believe i believe you said um
maybe that is the right place to do this
the bill commissioners
do not work for me they work for the
court but they lack training they lack
expertise
they lack that subject matter expert on
the laws that the judge has
so getting these people in front of a
judge within 36 hours our repeat
offenders is probably more appropriate
and i can tell you is more appropriate
than having the bail commissioner take
on that responsibility
put it where it belongs in the courtroom
um
there are times where this current bail
bar does work judges do hold people
judges do hold people on preventative
detention
there are times when they don't but
that's
they're the judge and they're acting
within the purview of the law i may not
always agree with somebody being
released on pr bill out of a court but
the end of the day that's the judge's
decision and we respect that
um and i'll end with
you know 36 hours doesn't seem like a
lot of time
to me it's not and if that's one less
victim or
one less opportunity to somebody to
reoffend
i worry about
what's it going to take in this state
and this just isn't manchester um
we have a tendency in our society
um
as a country
to we wait for that horrible horrible
moment
and then we say you know what now we got
to really do something and let's name
this bill after this victim
who was gunned down
or
murdered as a result of a domestic
violence incident we see it all the time
do we not we we name bills after people
and we don't do that until something
serious happens and we all go
oh now i gotta now i gotta really take
this serious um do i have people
reoffending in my city um 100 percent i
do i can give you an adult and it goes
upon anecdotes i'm not going to do that
because you're all smart people
you all watch the news and read the
newspapers um
but quite frankly
this is very difficult on law
enforcement
it's a drain on resources
it's a
drain on the
mental health of my police officers when
they have to arrest the same person
within 36 hours
for some violent offenses
and i i don't want to
stand in front of an officer of my
one of my officers families or one of
your families and say hey
we're sorry that your your loved one was
killed
by gunfire or whatever other means
um
because we didn't want to because we
didn't want to wait for the offender to
be held for 36 hours to go see a judge
it's time to start talking about victims
and
i'm sorry for my tone if i get a little
aggressive
just getting a little frustrated with
with the quality of life
and all the other impacts that people
that are reoffending are having on our
society and it's just not fair to the
good people of this state quite frankly
i'm happy to take any questions
representative lin
yes chief i wonder you seem i think
you'd be probably in a very good
position to comment on this do you
what would be your view and it's i know
it's really beyond the scope of this
particular bill but what would be your
view
on the idea of just doing away with bail
commissioners all together and saying
everybody
when you get arrested you go before a
judge no i don't i don't think we have
to go that far i mean bill commissions
serve a purpose in our in our system
because you have those people that
may be arrested for that minor
shoplifting no criminal record um first
arrest
you know pr bill is probably appropriate
um they have cut they have connections
to the community they have a job um they
made that one mistake okay pr bill there
was appropriate so eliminating bill
commissioner is not something i would
i would be in support of okay i just
think maybe what i think they need is
some more training and more education um
and some maybe some attention should be
paid to that because they they come in
well intended to do the good do the
right thing um
but sometimes things get cloudy for them
and i can't and my officers can't tell a
bail commissioner what bills should be
we cannot do that all right we can only
present them
the facts of the arrest and then they
have to make the decision from there
thank you
representative boardney
thank you chair and thank you for
answering my questions or taking my
question shall i say absolutely sir i'm
going to refer you to
rs 597
uh 7a yes sir paragraph 1a
and it actually does prefer
refer to
a person that validates restraining
orders our protective custody they can
be
a warrant can be arrested
issued and appear for justice within 12
hours correct
do you ever use that yes we do and at
597.7 we also use that um
when it comes to violation of bail or
breach of bailout the attorney prior to
me has spoken about um that's something
that that's a practice that the
manchester police adheres to so if
you're out on bail if you're out on bail
and you reoffend
we will file a
motion to revoke your bail
but does that necessarily mean that
they're held it does not
representative board name
thank you um
with that so what is this bill needed
since uh this particular section of law
really allows you to uh
have them for a judge that's on domestic
violence related offenses right did you
not say 173
rsa 173 those would be domestic violence
related offenses and this also refers to
uh 480
458 coen 16.
uh it is talking about
valuing the restraining order as well as
protective custody representative
boarding just before you continue just
understand that the witness does not
have that the rsa that you remember i
can lend it to him it would
what you're referring to is 173 you're
referring to domestic violence related
offenses violation of restraining orders
those type of um
particular violation restraining order
some will be held pending to see a judge
uh
we should be recognized for a follow-up
thank you
i
only brought up paragraph one a because
that is
the issue you were brought up
but uh
paragraph
one
also talks about any particular crime
that is being uh committed by a
uh
someone who's violating their
terms of their release
correct and you can file a motion
to revoke their bill
right which we do as a matter of
practice
so
why do we need this bill
there's not i understand where i think i
understand where you're coming from i
think um
i the importance of this is getting the
offender
in front of a judge as opposed to a bail
commissioner and i think
there's
you know we may have better outcomes if
the judge
is hearing
these cases when 36 hours as opposed to
a a bail commissioner um
setting bill when it may not have been
appropriate
but some jurisdictions don't there's
some jurisdictions that don't
um
exercise
finally a motion to revoke bail some do
and some don't so i think this would add
doing it this way would add more
consistency across the board
follow-up question thank you
also i'll read a sentence from the
paragraph one the cues should be brought
before a justice for a bail refresh and
hearing within 40 hours now are you
telling me that that judge
justice is
could be a bill commissioner as well as
a
judge
i don't think that's it i don't think
that states bill commissioner does it no
it does not okay
it says justice
so
representative boarding
well this is it's a healthy back and
forth
you only permit to ask members of the
public testifying questions
and just be specific and again the
witness does not have the irs in front
of it
thank you uh chair uh thank you for
answering my question i'm happy to have
that discussion offline if you'd like to
be glad to
representative newman
thank you for taking my question
absolutely sir when somebody
is arrested on a friday afternoon in
manchester and this bill is in effect in
the future
and they don't have a process
they don't have the availability of a
bail commissioner any longer
what happens to them where
do you detain them or
do they go to the county jail or what
what happens to that person well they
would you would still they would still
have access to the bill commissioner if
they were arrested on a
thursday morning at four o'clock in the
morning or friday afternoon two o'clock
they would still have access to a bail
commissioner
and then bail would be
i don't know i'm talking about if this
bill if bail commission this bill within
the 30 36 hours it says within 36 hours
but it also does it also says
notwithstanding something else it means
that you they would not be able to go as
i understand reading the bill maybe i'm
wrong they'd be transported to the
county jail to the county jail we can be
arraigned
within that 36 hours weekends and
holidays excluded
right so they would not be
in manchester i can tell you that if
they're arrested on that friday
afternoon and we can't get them in front
of a judge on friday then
they'll be in front of the judge on
monday afternoon
either district court or in superior
court that's how we that's how we handle
it follow-up representative newman you
recognize for a follow-up
thank you and i know that
i listened to your testimony and you
thought that bail commissioners should
not be eliminated
um do you feel that there could be
something better do
where they might be trained and and be
brought up to a standard that would be
that would be helpful i wouldn't i think
they would they would welcome that
because i've had those discussions with
the bill commissioners that
they wish they had got some type of
further training in education
thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
mr chairman
the committee now calls frank knack aclu
new hampshire
mr chairman members of the committee uh
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today my name is frank knack i'm the
policy director with the aclu of new
hampshire we are here
in opposition to 1476.
um and so
i guess you all have my testimony you
should have my testimony soon um i think
it's important to note that we are
talking about taking the liberty or
depriving delivery of potentially
thousands of granite staters
and the entire discussion today has been
based on anecdote and i think that that
should be worrisome to everyone on this
committee and so you know while
proponents have not brought data i
thought it was important to bring some
data to the discussion
and so as um
police commissioner shearer noted uh
earlier uh today when bail reform went
to effect in 2018
so i went to the department of public
safety website looked at crimes crime
data from 2018 2019 and 2020 there's no
2021 data available yet so those are the
most current years we have crime in new
hampshire is down 14
during that time period
again we heard a lot of talk about
manchester
so between 2018 and 2020 crime is down
10.6
for group a crimes arrests are down 38.5
for group a crimes and for group b
crimes arrests are down
28.7 percent
we also heard a lot about shoplifting
and concerns about shoplifting
shoplifting between 2018 and 2020 is
down 21.2 percent
and so while i'm not going to sit here
and say
crimes are down because we did bail
reform the notion that crime that bail
reform is making our communities less
safe is not supported by the data and so
i think it would be prudent for this
committee as a first step if there is
some alleged concerns that we would
actually have a data collection as a
logical first step before potentially
depriving thousands of people of their
liberty
um
again this base this this bill is based
in fear not evidence i think it's also
important to note that this bill does
not make our community safer again as it
has been noted before existing law has
provides the authority to hold people
who pose a danger to their communities
it's an individualized assessment that
is a proper way to do it we should not
be
grouping everyone together and then
depriving groups of people of their
liberty just because it's more
convenient for the courts or more
convenient for law enforcement
um and again i think we just had just
heard um um someone testified that 36
hours isn't a big deal i think you know
for folks who are working everyone knows
that 36 hours is a big deal if you're a
parent if you have a job it's a shift
job where you can't miss work
if you have other responsibilities you
can lose employment income your house
within 36 hours this is a big deal for a
lot of people and i think it's important
that we don't underscore that
and finally
we're talking about a bill that would
literally allow people to be
incarcerated pre-trial
for an offense where the max punishment
if convicted
carries no jail time i mean that to me
is just something that should be deeply
concerning to everyone on this committee
so i appreciate the opportunity to
discuss these items with you all today
um i know a lot's been already discussed
i will you know hope you all will read
my testimony
um i think actually one one final point
we've talked a lot about solutions and
so we do know that there are solutions
to a lot of the problems playing in
society i think there was a question
about mental health earlier you know we
decarcerated the uh the uh
institutionalized mental health facility
60 70 years ago and didn't provide any
wrap around supports that is the problem
that is the thing that we need to
address we know from social science data
that if we want to reduce crime and make
our community safer access to housing
access to living wage those are things
that actually make our community safer
and actually address crime policing is
inherently reactive it doesn't reduce
crime again social studies social
science studies have shown that time and
again
so when we're talking about depriving
potentially thousands of people there
liberty i think it's important and again
you know we've tried this with zero
tolerance policies in schools we've
tried this with mandatory minimum
policies in the adult context again they
don't work individualized is the proper
way to go and so i urge the committee
to oppose this bill and to engage in
some robust data collection because
that's what we need to be doing so thank
you
representative pantalagis
so i
and i guess you can look at the
pre-pandemic here so from 2018 to 2019
overall crime went from 40 uh 8404 per
100 000 to 78.56 so in a reduction we
saw a steady reduction over all those
years and so if you're just looking at
the pre-covered years you also see a
steady reduction in crime
and that follows the general trend that
was even before bail reform even 2017 it
was higher than 2018.
representative schultz
mr chair are you discouraging questions
is it okay
i don't know if we're trying to keep
time are you asking
making a parliamentary inquiry
yes sir thank you for you're recognize
for parliamentary inquiry
um
are we in need of uh
less questions
i've not stated that there's any
restriction on the amount of questions
any member can ask when we run behind
schedule the practice in this committee
has been i would normally
limit members to two questions per
witness okay nothing's in place right
now
i do have a question so you know you
wish to be recognized for a question of
the witness
yes please you're recognized it'll be
quick it'll be quicker than i wanted it
to be
um
i really appreciate the point that you
made about what i would call the social
safety net that could fix this
in a less expensive way i'm curious to
know
because i've heard that from concord's
police chief and i represent
a lower income part of concord
um
do you have data
that could be helpful to that continuing
debate that this bill and others
fit within because i think that
financial
and practical discussion that would be
very helpful data for all of us to have
i'm not on this committee i'm a sub but
i would love to give you my email
address
and
probably would benefit everybody yeah no
i'd be had there is substantial data and
i'd be happy to circulate that and in
addition there's also lots of new
emerging data around violence reduction
and solution effective solutions to
violent reduction and part of that
includes not policing low-level offenses
and so like manchester again 84 of the
arrests in manchester in 2018 were
low-level non-violent that means only 16
percent of the arrests they made in that
entire year were for serious matters and
so again the research shows that that is
ineffective police work
if the chair could inquire with a
question and uh thank you in advance for
taking my question
at least the original draft of this has
to do with someone who's arrested while
already out on bail
so my question is
what it what what if this policy i think
you don't support
what policy would you would you support
where you actually can hold people
accountable for violating the conditions
of the pre-trial release
um
we think the existing statute has
mechanisms in place to ensure that
people who violate their conditions are
held responsible um and that there's an
individualized assessment in those cases
and if they pose a danger they should be
handled but again we're housing using
our jails as a solution to people
experiencing mental health crises
substance use etc is ineffective it's
cost prohibitive if we actually maximize
that
and so we you know we would urge
investments and actual you know reducing
investments in life-affirming services
that are actually going to address the
underlying causes that are creating
um
discord in communities
thank you representative pratt
hello
sorry sorry about that i know the aclu
looks out for the rights of people
uh we have heard today of rape attacks
with pipes injuries by people out on
bail what is your position on the rights
of the victims
from people that are repeat offenders
and people are out on bail yeah no i
appreciate that question and i think the
existing law has mechanism in place to
ensure that those people can and can be
held
it's it's incumbent upon law enforcement
to make the case to the bail
commissioner that the person should be
held but the existing law clearly states
that someone can be held if they pose a
danger to the community and so again
that's the individualized way that we
think is most appropriate to maximize
the reduce the likelihood that we are
holding people who don't need to be held
but again have a mechanism in place to
hold people who do pose a danger to
their community
so at that point they have an assessment
they don't really have an assessment of
a person
to be able to do that they were charged
with a crime and bail it out
well if they were arrested they would
have the facts surrounding that arrest
and to then bring to the bail
commissioner to make the case
and i think you know one of the things
that i think it's also important to
remember in this context is that we
heard you know a number of the
proponents continually talk to about
these people as offenders and again
these are people in our criminal justice
system which i think is most appropriate
who have not been convicted of any crime
who are then alleged to have been
done something else they have not been
convicted in any context they are not
offenders in any context they are merely
people who have are out on bail who are
alleged to have done something and so we
have a mechanism in place to ensure that
if they if they do pose a danger the the
law enforcement can make the case and
the bell commissioner can hold them
doesn't this bill make that easy to do
this bill would mandate that they're
held
and so i think that is um um uh
i'm not sure how to put this this is um
it's a blanket approach to something
that will catch in it you know
thousands potentially thousands of
people who pose no danger to their
communities and who have families that
rely upon them who have jobs that will
be destroyed that will be taken away
with houses and income that will be lost
if we do this
okay
thank you
representative pandolakis
thank you thank you for taking my
question you just said that
these people would be losing their jobs
and their homes and everything
uh if they've committed a crime
why does that matter
well they haven't committed they've
alleged to have committed a crime but
then our you know as you know in our
legal system you're innocent until
proven guilty um and we think you know
particularly for people who do not pose
a danger to their society we should not
we know that jail is an ineffective
solution to making our communities safer
and so you know we also know from social
science research that people having
employment that people have steady
housing is more effective at reducing
you know the likelihood of people
committing crimes for people who do have
criminal records the likelihood that
they will recidivate
and so we think it's you know most
important to actually follow the social
science data and the the data in terms
of what's more effective in terms of
making our community safer and in that
case it would be trying to ensure that
folks have housing
have you know you know and if they have
kids that their kids are you know not
put out on the street
thank you
and thank you for testimony the chair
has a question and thank you again in
advance for taking my question
there was a
bill
it was uh sb 92
passed in this committee as amended it
was ultimately tabled
uh
comparing that to this and i'm not
asking the line for lines for each one
but from a policy perspective on really
addressing
uh
filing conditions of release and whether
or not to bring someone in front of a
judge as opposed to a bail commissioner
is there any
i guess can you compare the two and any
thoughts on which policy may have been
more tailored towards a specific issue
yeah no i appreciate the question i
think you know in sb 92 i think one of
our main concerns was it had the 13
offenses that mandated
detention again not individualized
assessment but just because a you know
you are alleged to have done something
and i think we all know
in new hampshire that charges are
brought and then once the prosecutor
gets the case file they may rethink what
those charges are and whether they were
appropriate and they could be reduced
and so again you're going to be you know
incarcerating people pre-trial
for something that the prosecutor could
then reduce before they even get to
trial
and it's it's not it's inconsistent with
i think the best practices of a judicial
system should be i think you know from
our perspective the existing law works
the data shows that it's working we've
had substantial reductions in crime and
in arrests in new hampshire since bail
reform went to effect
you know we would of course be willing
to be a part of any collaborative
project to discuss more effective
solutions and ways that we can make our
system stronger and i think as police
commissioner shir noted
i think that discussion should include
stakeholders broad spectrum stakeholders
social service providers mental health
practitioners
substance use experts
folks who work in in low income housing
and people experiencing lack of housing
i think we need to have a cumulative
wraparound response to how we can make
our community safer
and and thank you thank you for taking
my question and one last follow-up
it
i understand that there's no objection
to holding a person or detaining a
person to they appear in front of a bail
commissioner
why is there an objection to holding
that person do they appear in front of a
judge
i think our concern is the the timeline
and so if if the judge would get them
right away that's so but we need to
ensure that there's a mechanism in place
that we are not holding people
unnecessarily and so the mechanism we
have in place now is the bill
commissioners that they're they they can
see
pretty much right away and that's an
effective way it's the data shows that
it's working um and that the bail
commissioners have the authority to hold
people if they are a danger
thank you for taking my question
see new hands raise the witnesses
excused thank you for your testimony
thank you all
right the committee now calls rusean
chester
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members i am um
a
citizen of new hampshire
specifically specifically the town of
bedford new hampshire so i am very near
to manchester i was born in concord new
hampshire and have lived my entire life
in new hampshire
i've listened to everybody's come
forward and i've heard about the
antidotes
just give you a little bit of experience
a little bit about me i was a community
outreach worker
prior to covid for a number of years i
also worked for the state of new
hampshire for over 15 years what i will
tell you and my
my background is psychology and social
services
when
bail reform first came up
i thought it was a good idea
however
i have learned
that
people
who are committing crimes repeatedly
have learned how to circumvent the
system
so
what happens to someone who is homeless
and it's cold they commit a cri before
bail reform they committed a crime on
friday night so they would be warm till
sunday or monday before they could get
in front of a judge
what they're doing now
is
they are trying to
so what's happening and i know this
because i volunteer in manchester i
volunteer without homeless i volunteer
with our mental health folks and i
volunteer with our substance abuse folks
and i'm telling you that this bill is
very much needed um and the reason for
that is
these folks are being brought toward the
bail commissioner oftentimes the bail
commissioner only knows that instance
they don't know that they have sometimes
they don't know that they have multiple
um
things
in their background that they have not
been held accountable and responsible
for we teach our children
actions have consequences
by having these putting these bail
commissioners in a position where they
don't they may not have all the
information even the officers don't
always have the information it's not
always the same bail conditioner
the bottom line is is that we need to
start holding that percentage of the
population accountable for their
behavior and it's it's not a i looked up
what is a victimless
what is the legal
um definition of a victim victimless
crime it's a
it's no apparent victim or no apparent
pain or injury
any crime has pain or injury to some
extent
even if it's even if it's violating your
first amendment rights
so you have someone that's tagging the
the side of the highways with gang
um messages
that's that's a victim that that that
crime has a victim not just the fence
not just the public property
the victim is the
the perpetrator is sending a message
every crime has a victim shoplifting you
know who the victims of shoplifting are
us
the taxpayers and people who are
spending more now because
they're not prosecuting shoplifting
anymore because it's just too difficult
i heard about the
crime has gone down well
okay crime's gone down absolutely
i would argue that's because people are
not being arrested
people are not being held accountable
and responsible and they can say well
i'm homeless or i have mental illness
it's not a catch-all people should be
held accountable and responsible
um
i believe this bill
also provides some kind of protection
for
all of us as citizens but also it
provides protection for our law
enforcement officers because
you look at you look at
the number of studies that have been
done
when a person breaks the law
and doesn't have a consequence for it
they're going to continue to break the
law
and they're going to increase
the um the
the potential to have a victim so if
they're first victims are just tagging
the sides of the road with um gang stuff
what's their next crime if they weren't
held responsible for that one
um
i heard about
unintended consequences
to be honest with you
a bill like this
would provide transparency it would
develop a level of trust that has been
lost
and a level and it would bring the
community more together because there is
a huge divide right now there are a lot
of people um
in even bedford new hampshire that are
fearful of the homeless are fearful of
the mentally ill why because that small
fraction that have
that they've heard about is scary
that's not okay
i heard about the statistics
thousand we're gonna violate thousands
of people's rights
so i took that
and i because
one of the first things i learned in
psychology is how to lie with statistics
statistical psychology
so based on the figures that the last
presenter gave me
we would be by holding someone in jail
until they could get in front of a judge
we would be affecting less than
one-fourth of the percent one-fourth of
a percent
of the total population of new hampshire
and
he said thousands
but i also heard someone else say
of those thousands there's only about
two percent that are repeat offenders
so it would only be affecting it would
be affecting a lot lower sub group
that would mean
that we would be
we could potentially be infringing the
rights of
if they really truly were innocent of
all
everything they did so the first crime
and the second crime um we would be
impacting less than
.03 percent
of the population in new hampshire
what's more important that .03 percent
or all the citizens the children the
business owners
that we pay
for our government to protect us
now coming from a social worker
standpoint you would suspect me to say
oh but they have mental illness and they
have substance abuse unfortunately i
have seen it
i have seen it's a
joke criminals
that are going to commit crimes and
going to keep upping the ante no
it's more important to commit a crime on
friday night when i know this bail
commission is on because he lets
everyone off
would you believe that
because that's what's happening
so
something has to be done
is it providing more education and
providing bail commissioners with more
with more consequences if they continue
to do this
maybe
but this is a nice easy clear-cut thing
we get them in front of the judges
and we allow them
it would it would help in my opinion it
would help deter the weekend crimes
because that's also one of the things
that happens is everyone says don't ever
don't ever do this on a on a on a long
holiday weekend because you're not going
to get a bail commissioner do you know
sometimes it takes up more than three
days to get a bail commissioner to sign
your pr bail
it's happened
so the fact that i've sat here and heard
we're worried about the we're worried
about the thousands of people with
mental illness and substance abuse and
homelessness i care about them too
but i care more about the people that
are complying with our laws the people
who are not violating our
the the the rights
that our constitution and our first our
um declaration of independence provided
for us
so that's all i have to say and i'm more
than open to any questions
representative newman
thank you and thank you for taking this
question could you go back
could you go back to your st your
numbers and your statistics again
there's about 1.4 million people in new
hampshire
i think you uh can you just go over your
numbers again so
1.4 million i put by the last cent by
the census of 2020
i had only 518 000. so um if i do 1.4
million that quarter percent
is
is significantly reduced so i only so i
was doing it back there while i was
okay listening so it would be a lot less
than it would be
it would probably be it would be like 1
10 of the population or
0.0
0.001
if we were to take the only two percent
so instead of 0.03 it would be 0.001
follow-up
yes i'd i'd like to work with real
numbers here
so
if i i just looked on
21 census showed 1.38 million so we
talked in like 300 1.38
yeah
1400 is
would be the number that would be
affected by this
okay and 1400 is your one percent
0.001
okay
correct
thank you i think let me see i can do it
actually it would be .007
007 reflects
1400 people
out of the out of the figures you gave
me yes out of the population thank you
there'll be no further questions thank
you for your testimony you're welcome
there's anyone else in the audience
wishing to testify who has not testified
they mean none i will now close the
public hearing
when's the next
coming your standard recess for 10
minutes
you
you think
at this time we will now open the public
hearing on hb 1335 relative to the
parole board and the procedure for
medical parole of prisoners
and the committee calls representative
murphy
ready
good afternoon um
thank you mr chairman and honorable
members of the criminal justice and
public safety committee for allowing me
the opportunity to present
house bill 1335 relative to the parole
board in the procedures for medical
parole of prisoners
a special thanks to the chairman for
postponing this hearing from last friday
as i suspect the weather may have
prevented me from this opportunity
childcare
for the record my name is jim murphy
i represent grafton 12 which is lyme in
hanover
where i have lived for over 40 years i
am a first year representative having
previously practiced orthopedic surgery
in the granite state for nearly 40 years
at both
dartmouth hitchcock and new london
hospital
house bill 1335 is a bipartisan bill
that revises portions of section 651-a
colon 10-a
of title 62 criminal justice code
chapter 651-a
dealing with the parole of prisoners
this bill came about in response to a
review and audit of the medical parole
process
in the performance audit of 29 2019
of the adult the new hampshire adult
parole board
these revisions promulgate rules for
medical parole encodes that medical
parolees have equivalent levels of
scrutiny for parole
track and review medical parolees and
establishes medical parole conditions
there are basically three changes to the
current medical parole statute first it
revises the membership of the adult
parole board and makes terms gender
neutral
second it revises criteria necessary
for determining if an inmate qualifies
for medical parole
third and lastly it renames the position
of executive assistant to the parole
board
to adult parole board director of
operations
section three of this bill was created
to clearly and unambiguously
determine eligibility and process
criteria for medical parole
if one were to look at the original bill
and specifically i will point out
section three roman numeral one on page
two
the language as written is very broad
without essential details and is
extremely brief
it states as criteria quote terminal
debilitating and incurable medical
conditioner syndrome end of quote
the proposed revision is significantly
more detailed clearly stated
inconsistent with current medical
practice and issues and is clear about
process
house bill 1335 now specifies three
categories
for medical parole within which
all the criteria for medical parole must
be met in order to qualify for parole
within each of these three separate
categories
this bill outlines
specific criteria for each category and
as such is more consistent in align with
the vast universe of potential
qualifying categories which may exist it
is no longer one size fits all
from a physician's perspective clear
rules criteria are critical
and welcomed in the care of patients
these specific qualifying categories
recognize that medicine and complex care
of patients change over time
and has evolved regardless of one's
status either as an inmate or not
for example the treatment of many
complex medical conditions cannot be
managed in a correctional facility
beyond simply consideration of cost
we no longer institutionalize certain
patients as a means to isolate them from
society
and who may not be appropriate for
housing in a correctional facility
hospice and palliative care are now
recognized specialties with many
up-to-date treatment options available
for the terminally ill
and for whom specialized settings for
their care are needed
the scope of medicine has expanded and
times have changed and these statute
changes are better aligned with these
changes
mr chairman and committee members we
believe that house bill 1335
clearly updates and specifies the
processes of medical parole with more
specific criteria for consideration of
medical parole it clarifies rules of
medical parole it tracks and reviews
medical parole's parolees
it establishes up-to-date parole
conditions
consistent with and recognizing changes
in medical practices
and it makes clear
parole board responsibilities for
medical parolees risk assessment and
monitoring while on parole
we therefore encourage you to vote in
support of these important revisions to
medical parole
we also have here members of the new
hampshire adult board to present their
own detailed testimonies regarding
parole criterion processes
board membership and
renaming the executive assistant
position
i'm happy to take any questions now if
the committee wishes thank you
thank you for your testimony
your witness is excused thank you
the committee now calls horus enriquez
do i just begin
thank you good afternoon mr chairman and
members of the criminal justice and
public safety committee thank you for
hearing and considering my testimony as
to the medical parole portion of
house bill 13335
specifically the medical parole
proportion portion
for the record my name is horace
enriquez i'm a member of the new
hampshire parole board starting my third
year of service
i'm a retired transplant and trauma
surgeon having practiced in new
hampshire at dartmouth for the last 25
years or 30 years now
as dr murphy mentioned this legislative
effort is in response to the performance
audit of 2019 of the new hampshire
parole board ordered by your committee
the overarching criticism of the parole
board or its lack of definitions and
inconsistent applications
to rules
the concept of cost as applied to the
parole board was unfavorably
viewed
what you have before you is our response
to the audit's 16 specific points of
concern
as a starting point i would like to
emphasize that the new hampshire adult
parole board is an independent and
separate entity from the department of
corrections
we are continuing from the courts
through the doc to to transition inmates
into society
but we are still functionally and
administratively
separate from the department of
corrections
as another perspective we currently have
about two to four cases we hear
a year and only currently have one act
of medical parole parolee
but we do have an aging
prison population and with increasing
medical concerns
in the past two years as i mentioned
we've heard four cases
and they have been they would be slotted
into uh each of the three buckets which
i'll explain in a moment of a hospice
type care
a permanently incapacitated type care
and what i call the serious and
complicated medical condition which is
what we wrote in our thing
i think the serious and complicated
medical conditions highlights the real
difference between what is medical
parole and parole
in that
while on medical parole the poli was on
house arrest
which would not allow him to go to the
grocery shopping or into the community
to attend church as these activities
would not have allowed to be allowed in
the prison
it is uh we consider this
a prison sentence
gaining medical
care that is needed
i do realize the doc has raised concerns
about the proposed legislation
however what is not challenged is the
proposed concept of our definitions of
the three buckets if you will
for a medical parole to be considered
i would also really emphasize and i'll
emphasize again
that um
the concept or the application of
medical parole is through the division
of medical and forensic services it is
not initiated by
an inmate
it is uh reserved for those who have not
yet met their minimum sentence so that
we can't even consider parole
and again i think this is an important
concept and i think this is a concept
that the department of corrections would
agree with
as to uh
the term of the ill
this would be the concept here would be
someone who is a cancer patient in
hospice care
the concept of terminal and hospice care
is easily definable through medicare and
medicaid rules
the permanently incapacitated
the situation here is the person who's
had a debilitating stroke
who's a paraplegic of some sort cannot
care for themselves needs care for their
routine hygiene
bathing
toiletry eating feeding
it is just beyond the capacity it may be
it may not be beyond the capacity but it
is a bucket in which the department of
corrections has a choice
and the last one is the serious and
medical uh
complex medical care
and the best example we have which is
our most recent one within the system
was a paraplegic who had bed sores
required uh sense of
plastic surgery special beds
rehab issues re-operations
and required a
litany of steps in their care
this was also a inmate who came back to
us to be considered for parole when that
was available to them
the specific revisions within our system
uh which dr murphy has alluded to
is that these would enact uh have
equivalent levels of screening in other
words if they are a serious threat to
society
would they get paroled no
i think two of these categories are
quite easily defensible because the
inmate is
so incapacitated as to
hardly be a threat
any concerns by the doc to the medical
proposal
have been
or will be addressing and i have a
meeting with the department of forensic
services tomorrow to to work on the
these issues
i believe our differences are minor
essentially perceptions of vocabulary
definitions and because we are separate
entities we have different sort of
concepts of definitions i guess this way
i would say it
i think added to the turmoil of covet
and the quarantine rules we have been
distanced a little bit further
and i think we can solve this problem
quite quickly
but there are nuanced and important
practical differences between the
prison medical systems and the
university medical systems which i was
raised in
i'm just learning about these nuances
but tomorrow i have every belief this
terminology issues will be resolved
i believe our face-to-face discussions
the next few days will be comfortable uh
we'll and we will comfortably resolve
separate uh entities under so that
separate entities understand each other
administrative rules and practice
documents mr chairman and committee
members we believe that hb
1335 clearly updates and specifies the
present processes of medical parole
with more specific criteria for
consideration of medical parole
it clarifies rules of medical parole it
tracks and reviews medical parolees
it establishes up to date parole
conditions consistent with and recognize
changes as medical practices and is
based on best practice models
and it makes clear parole board
responsibilities for medical parolees
risk assessment and monitoring while on
parole
it also maintains
the
origin of the medical parole request
with the division of uh corrections
department of corrections within the
division of medical and forensic
services
and again only applies to those parolees
who have not mentioned
sentences a representative of the new
hampshire adult parole board i ask your
forbearance we would like to have some
time to collaborate with the doc and
return to you with an amendment
i'll be meeting with the deputy director
forensics medical services this week and
hope to have an agreement ready for the
committee's consideration following that
for the amendment i would encourage you
to vote ought to pass
in its reconciled and mutually supported
version i am happy to take any further
questions
representative true you're recognized
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
you had made reference to uh
if a
medical parole was granted it would be a
house arrest
yes sir
bear with me
um so i mean house whether it's
in a hospice care building or a hospital
or your physical house is all
that's all considered house arrest yes
sir thank you
senior hands raise the witnesses excuse
thank you thank you for your testimony
thank you very much
the committee now calls the honorable
donna scitec
we now call jennifer sargent
thank you good afternoon mr chairman and
honorable committee members
i'm here as the chairman of the new
hampshire adult parole board to ask you
not only to
vote in favor of the medical parole
statute once
dr henriquez has had the opportunity to
go back and
work the
vocabulary issues the the meaning issues
of certain terms and certain principles
through with the department of
corrections but also to understand the
non-medical parole features of this
bill
the first part
that is
in the bill is
the amendment of
the word executive assistance and to
director of operations it neither
changes the salary
grade
nor the definition of the job
the
term executive assistant
is
inappropriate in its colloquial sense
and also i believe in its professional
sense
regarding the job that the person in
this role actually does and i do have um
of course a list of a variety of the
tasks that the person engages in in our
office
if you would like me to read those to
you
on the back page the last page of the
bill
it just follows that the name would be
amended to the director of operations
again
without cost or task change
we have a ceo coo type of model
uh in the parole office with me as the
chairman in the ceo ish role and the coo
role going to the director hopefully the
director of operations but now what is
named the executive assistant
that person really does direct all of
the internal operations how things are
going to precede how information comes
in all of the operations i do not direct
the operations i am the
policy and hearings procedure person but
in terms of all of the things that
happen in the parole office and there
are so many
that person our current executive
assistant jay mackey
does all of that so it is the most
appropriate name for the person title
for the person in this position to be
director of operations
and in that regard it is a
definitional technical change
additionally we have in the center of um
the bill
in terms of under paragraph
one and two
the two paragraph simply cleans up
the membership and is more concise
two attorneys who are a member of the
new hampshire bar in good standing and
who are in in an active status
we have to maintain two attorneys on the
board because we have to always have an
attorney at our parole revocation
hearings
so since we have to have two in case
to switch off and in case one is not
available to have the other there it
just makes sense to add two attorneys
and then say there are three additional
members
and take out
one at-large member
this change shortens things up and just
cleans
things up
and chairperson obviously the
gender-neutral
statement of
the chairman
because a chairperson is
obviously
can be male female
non-binary
individual
and so we think that it makes the most
sense to just have it explained in a
gender-neutral way
that's all i have to offer on the
non-medical parts of the bill and i'm
happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony seeing no
hands raised the witness is excused
thank you
the committee now calls jeff stresslove
did i
mispronounce that
hi good afternoon my name is jeff
strozen i'm an associate attorney
general at the new hampshire attorney
general's office
we agree with the comments that you're
going to hear from the department of
corrections regarding this bill we think
it makes sense to consider the language
of the bill further and to study it
further before it's passed these are
very significant changes that are being
made to this bill
it's important to note that the bill
applies to any inmate regardless of the
number of victims that they've hurt or
killed the number of crimes they've
committed or how little of their
sentence they've actually served
the way medical parole works if you have
somebody who happens to be sick and they
commit serious crimes or older when they
commit serious crimes they could
conceivably serve very little of their
sentence and turn around and walk out
the door because they have medical
issues these are very difficult concepts
for victims to understand and it's very
hard on victims to find out that that
kind of consideration is being given to
people who victimized their family
members so we would just ask that you
consider the department of corrections
proposals and study this bill further
given that it has very far-reaching
consequences in cases
that's all i have and i'd be happy to
take any questions any of you have
representative true you're recognized
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
and
i don't know if you're the right person
to ask but
the bill as proposed
versus the
criteria they use to grant medical
exceptions paroles now what's the
difference
so this in our view is more expansive
and we think
if we're going to consider revamping
this bill we should consider other
aspects of it including the fact that
again
it's without limitation so
in most instances when an inmate tries
to leave prison for instance if someone
wants to suspend their sentence they
have to serve two-thirds of that
sentence this bill has no such
requirements or limitations
and you know not every
offender is of perfect health
or necessarily young we have offenders
of different age groups different
different health conditions
just because an offender is older or has
certain health conditions shouldn't mean
that they would escape the consequences
of their actions and there's no doubt
that giving someone medical parole is
not the same as having that person be in
prison and i can tell you what
family members have said to me is you
know my loved one didn't get to die
surrounded by friends or family
why does the person who killed my loved
one get to do that and obviously there
are other concepts here at work but that
is something that resonates with family
members and so we think it just makes
sense to consider the whole package
including that piece of it maybe it
would be that people would have to serve
a certain portion of their sentence
before they'd be eligible for medical
parole
because that's certainly how it is in
any other instance where an inmate would
get to leave prison early so we just
think this is an opportunity to consider
all that together
thank you thank you for your question
representative lynn
yes uh mr shelton i i think your your
points are very well taken on this uh
but let me add as as i read the language
of the bill as
currently proposed
a person would be eligible under this
language to be released on medical
parole
even if
the condition the medical or
psychological condition that they suffer
from was one
that they had at the time of sentencing
and was known to the judge that was
pre-existing it was pre-existing
condition so they could
and and then the the other question may
i ask a follow-up
um
the um the language of the current law
as as i understand it
just talks about has a terminal
debilitating incapacity or incurable
medical condition or syndrome
and i note that in the permanently
incapacitated section
of the new proposed language it talks
about not just a medical condition but a
mental condition and i'm wondering if
has the
current law been interpreted to allow
someone to be released because of a
mental
condition
i don't know the answer to that i think
the department of corrections could
possibly have that answer i can tell you
that the most recent case i had
concerning something like this had
nothing to do with a mental condition it
was purely a physical condition only so
i had
to my knowledge in our office we haven't
run into a request for medical parole
involving a mental condition
i mean it would strike me that that
would be a
that would be a much more dif much more
difficult issue
in terms of proof and things like that
it would and again you know not none of
us are perfect not every offender who
commits a crime is perfect
this this is a significant avenue for
someone who may have committed some of
the most serious crimes that we have to
leave prison relatively early into their
sentence so again we just think this is
an opportunity to consider all those
factors if we're going to significantly
revamp this bill
representative pratt
some of the conditions that are
explained here could they be handled in
the affirmary or the jail
i have spoken with uh people department
of corrections on on a case i had
recently and they did describe to me
their capabilities and again my guess is
that commissioner hanks could probably
answer those questions far better than i
can there's certainly some
that can be
again i'm not fully aware of their
complete capabilities though i apologize
thank you you're welcome
see no hands raised the witness is
excused thank you for your testimony
thank you very much for letting me speak
i appreciate it
the committee now calls commissioner
helen hanks
good afternoon honorable chair members
of the
committee helen hanks commissioner of
the department of corrections for the
record i thank you for the opportunity
to speak on the proposal before you
today and to triage some pre-existing
questions and any follow-up questions
understandably our director of medical
and forensic services paul mattis did
send her testimony in advance and i am
assured i know you will read and review
that
the concerns we had under the current
proposal
were the areas around a mental condition
and some other specificities that
ironically caused some vagaries and for
that matter with our experiencing
corrections we have individuals whom
have clear diagnosed medical conditions
that they're in the current formulation
of the law are high costs to the state
of new hampshire that are
high um
high utilization of our nursing
resources and become a challenge in the
environment and traditionally have been
terminal or debilitating in a way that
mitigates any risk to the community if
we find an appropriate health care
setting that would take them and that
appropriate health care setting
historically has been hospice care
sometimes nursing home setting and in
rare instances a home setting wrapping
hospice around that person because they
are eventually going to be terminal and
the age ranges have been from a young
person with terminal cancer to elderly
individuals with other comorbidities
associated with their care
so we do appreciate the adult parole
board and we certainly were part of that
audit as referenced in 2019 and look
forward to moving
and resolving some of those things in an
iteration of new reform of law under
your guidance obviously but we want to
we want to make sure we don't open the
door to
individuals who will actually intend to
abuse this law in an attempt to go home
be non-compliant with their mental
health care and i know this committee
knows the actual numbers of prevalence
of mental health and substance use
disorders and those incarcerated and i
know you wouldn't be surprised that some
people would be non-compliant with their
treatment when in an attempt to
achieve medical parole and i as much as
i appreciate
having those requests come to my office
i want our time to be meaningful
together
so i certainly support working with any
members both of the adult parole board
this committee and the attorney
general's office on some mediated
language that reduces potential abuses
but recognizes other
medical diagnoses such as dementia and
alzheimer's that could be
deferred to a community based setting
safely as long as the person's conduct
and course of behavior is not such that
it would be adverse to the other
patients in those settings so we
appreciate the progress that is
attempted in the iteration before you
but would ask
the committee to create a subcommittee
so we could work on an amendment
together that would be more
measured
balancing the concerns expressed in the
testimony sent prior to today i'm sure
there were other key areas but again i
don't want to dwell into the testimony
too deeply i know you've read
it and again is it compassionate release
is it cost related release what what is
the state's intent in this update
because cost is completely excluded in
the proposal before you
and i'll tell you the average cost of
incarceration is forty five thousand
dollars right now um we generally and
historically have only put cases forward
that are significantly higher in cost
so with that i certainly am open to any
questions that the committee may have of
the agency
representative roy
thank you mr chairman
um thank you for taking my question
my question is um regarding you know
there's a whole
a whole list of possible ailments and
conditions
how does the um the department deal with
chronic pain patients currently um that
require uh opioids or things of this
nature in the facility
representative roy thank you for that
question with regard to chronic care
associated with chronic pain
the treatment plan for those individuals
are going to be truly individualized
and balancing people's risk for opioid
addiction we will look for non-opioid
interventions to help that person plus
wrapping around mental health groups
managing your pain before it manages you
is a common group methodology we have a
multi-disciplinary team that actually
vets and evaluates people with chronic
pain
it's an interesting question because the
way the language is written that's a
debilitating condition that's not
reversible in many cases
but if that came to my desk i wouldn't
be recommending them for medical parole
but i would have hundreds of individuals
who may attempt to seek medical parole
just under that one condition
representative muse
yes thank you for taking my question um
i'm curious about
how the department of corrections
handles inmates who need palliative care
or hospice care my guess is not all of
them are applying for for medical parole
representatives that's an excellent
question we actually created a hospice
program using residents who are trained
in um
call benign activities not health care
related activities and we actually
conduct hospice in our infirmary
settings for individuals who have not
risen to the current statutory provision
for medical parole sometimes hospice is
rather sudden and sometimes we know in
advance and i do balance the voice of
victims involved in many of these cases
if i have an individual who's
incarcerated with and i have seen this
upwards of 10 counts of aggravated
felony sexual assault and we have a
terminal condition and that person needs
hospice i'm not likely to ask for
medical parole because the costs can be
actually contained within the current
budget of the agency under the current
algorithm and statute
thank you you're welcome
representative bert
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
i did some work for a lady that
it was a scarsdale diet murder
back in the late 80s or 90s
and she was the person that killed the
guy
but she got out on a medical
exemption like what we're talking here
today
what would this bill do
with somebody like her
that got better
because she's out living in monroe new
hampshire and now she's uh i think she
has past sense but uh but
you know there was many years she got
better so what would this bill do if you
get better would they bring you back
representative bert that was an
excellent question it's almost like you
read the 2019 audit because there was no
um there is a provision in the current
statute that says that the person is
better
the adult parole board the first excuse
me field services our probation approval
staff should tell the adult parole board
the person's better they don't meet the
criteria the statute and the adult
parole board would then have a hearing
and then revoke the privilege of parole
and in that case scenario we have had
individuals whom did well under that
type of medical parole supervision and
the timing of their sentence actually
afforded the agency to put them out on
administrative home confinement
that's that was a specific
unique outlier associated with someone's
sentencing and serving that sentence
thank you you're welcome
representative newman
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um on on page three of the bill it it
shows the the current language that's
lined out
and it says all these conditions apply
and then starting on line 17 or 18 it
says it says the inmate falls into one
or more of the following categories and
then lists the filing categories that
have been testified to so far
could you just kind of give
your impression of
how the lined out version compares to
the lined inversion and what kind of
problems it might caught for you or and
what's maybe left in or not left in or
needs to be left in i know you're going
to have other discussions in some detail
but just kind of a 30 000 foot uh
explanation
thank you representative newman
under the existing uh provisions cost is
a factor so again and i trust
wholeheartedly the adult parole board's
research that many states have balanced
cost as a driver to medical parole with
compassionate release and and things of
that nature and i would defer those
decisions to the legislature and then i
would act on them so that is one obvious
um clear distinction in what's being
proposed today
the parts and the new proposals it's
really a new proposal that creates a
differentiation because it's clear right
now for the department that it's a
terminal debilitating
medical condition
that
that causes a reduction of risk so much
so that the person's not going to be a
threat in the community and that's in
cost
and then looking at the proposed
language using terms such as you see
before you mental condition mental
ability
things of that nature that creates a lot
of broadness for us with a large
prevalence of individuals with mental
illness and we just want to work on
refining those areas of the bill so that
we really are looking at individuals
whom and i will use dementia as an
example have dementia have needs that at
this point could be served better in a
health care setting outside of a
correctional environment rather than a
person who has and as written
it would be challenged by people
incarcerated that they have a major
depressive disorder and they're not
compliant with their medications and
it's not reversible and
i think we can do this in a mitigated
way to be successful in the intent thank
you you're welcome
seeing no hands raised the witness is
excused thank you for your testimony
committee now calls donna scitec
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
i can do zero to 60 eventually
i um
want to uh respond to some of the uh
issues that have been raised attorney
stellson talked about
gee what if some really dangerous
criminal
ask for medical parole
i would remind you that under current
law there is no limit on who is eligible
the current law
is on page two you can see that it's
crossed out starting on line 10 the
criteria
are on
lines 10 through 15.
so
even if you don't pass this that that
doesn't change that there is the
possibility that somebody who committed
a violent crime
who otherwise met the criteria
might be eligible for parole if they met
all the other criteria
right now
as a former 10-year member of the parole
board i can tell you that medical
paroles are very few and far between
this bill doesn't try to open the doors
it just tries to
specify
uh
with some detail
what the criteria are right now the
general terms terminal debilitating
incapacitating are incurable
condition
what is that
the other thing is that it's determined
that the cost of their care is
determined to be excessive
now for years the board has been trying
to get a definition
of what's excessive cost
we would ask and they'd say well we know
that their drugs cost this much is that
excessive there was no definition
and the
audit asked us
they dinged us on that
they said that you don't have any
definition of what what's excessive cost
and for years we have been trying to
work with the department to develop
a definition of cost
the reason that's in there
is that
a person who is behind the walls and
needs medical care the state has to pay
for it if they're on medical parole
they go out on medicare medicaid
private insurance
so there's an incentive to get them out
the door because it's costing the state
too much
the way that that issue is addressed in
the bill is on page three line line
three
it says that
their care
requires resources that exceed the
department's medical capability
so and that's what's really driving this
if you can't provide it behind the walls
because it's too expensive
if you have somebody who's on dialysis
for example
is the cost of the dialysis is the cost
of a corrections officer who has to
accompany them two or three times a week
we were never able to get numbers on
that so we we wanted to
address that issue in a general way by
saying that
that they require uh
treatment that
and resources that exceed the
department's medical capability
uh the commissioner uh and in the letter
from
paula mattis talked about the concern
about including mental conditions
the board is very agreeable
to taking out any reference to the
mental conditions
that it was not our intent to expand
eligibility the intent of this bill is
to clearly define it and to set up a
process for tracking
them once they've been released
the audit
noted that we
uh
required some to report
back to us there that there any changes
in the medical edition every three
months somewhere every six months
we don't know whether the reports came
back it wasn't clear who had to file
them this bill clarifies all of that
so
that's another reason that this bill is
better than the current law
uh and i remind you that any of these
medical paroles are initiated
from the commissioner's office
so if somebody is too
high profile too dangerous to
whatever
we never even the parole board would
never even get to see it
um
there was a question about
somebody
who
is released on medical parole and gets
the care they need and recovers
well the bill requires periodic reports
and if they no longer meet the criteria
for medical parole they come right back
to the prison
and as dr henrico said we recently had a
case like that
where somebody was released to the
community was treated in the community
he got better
he came back to the prison
to complete
up to his minimum
and then he has a chance for a hearing
on a regular
parole
so i hope that uh
i uh would allow the stakeholders to sit
around the table and come up with an
agreeable amendment
that satisfies
the the
the specifics that the audit required
from the parole board and
makes it very clear about eligibility
and the process for tracking people
who are released on medical parole
so i would thank you for your attention
and take any questions you may have
representative roy
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i'm curious
because you just mentioned that there
was a case
does the time while the person is out on
medical parole toll
against their
no
the clock keeps running
and when they reach what would be their
minimum had they not been released on
medical parole
they are scheduled for a hearing for
regular parole
so somebody who was on medical parole
who's still sick
and didn't come back
meets the the date for his regular
parole he gets a hearing and we decide
whether he can continue where he is but
without those restrictions of medical
parole perhaps
representative newman
could you just elaborate a little bit
about um
a person who is released on medical
parole to an outside entity as opposed
to being cared for medically within the
institute the prison
who pays for that or how it's paid for
or who is required to pay for it
on the walls when they're behind the
walls the state is on the hook for the
complete cost of their care
if we release somebody
on medical parole who meets all the
other criteria
and there are on medicare medicare we
pay
many of our
inmates
are eligible for medicaid
and we have released people who had
private insurance
dr newman recognized for a follow-up
thank you mr chair
and
what would be the condition of what
would happen for somebody that just does
not have access to medical
care onto any of the things that you
mentioned
well before they're released they have
to demonstrate that they have a place
that they can go to that will provide
the care
and if they don't have any funds and
there's no way to pay for it they're
going to have trouble finding a place
but if they if they
they can find a facility that will take
them
thank you
representative lynn
yes thank you and thank you for taking
my question uh i'm just curious if um
do you have a view on whether there
should be some language in this that
would
require that the condition that provides
the basis for the potential parole
be one that that arose after the
sentencing because i guess my my concern
would be
if you didn't have that then you could
have a situation where for example a
judge
knowing all about the condition
nonetheless decided let's say that
someone should should receive a 10-year
sentence
and then
you know almost immediately the the
person could apply for medical parole
and the parole board
could essentially
sort of
you know undo what the judge did by
saying no we think the person should be
should be paroled
well the parole but only considers it if
the commissioner of corrections
recommends it
and there there is no limit on
how long they've been in they i mean
attorney strauss and talked about other
areas where sentences are modified after
they serve two-thirds for example
we never considered that
i can tell you
it is so rare
i've been on the board i've just
completed 10 years on the board and
there was never a situation like that i
think in the 10 years maybe i've seen
15 or 20 medical girls
so it's very rare and those kind of
scenarios are nothing i've ever seen
okay thank you
representative pratt
hello
earlier we've talked about mental health
and that's going to get worked on but is
it possible a serious mental health
person could end up in a nursing home
for medical medicaid medicare to take
care of them
and they would be in a nursing home with
regulations about mental health is that
the department has the capacity to deal
with mental health that we have a secure
psychiatric unit
so
i would
i would say that the board is very
receptive to the idea of eliminating any
of the concerns
about
broadening the application of this by
applying it to mental health conditions
that was not our intent good thank you
nice seeing no hands raised
speaker thank you for your testimony and
you're excused
are there any members of the public
president who wish to testify that have
not testified already
seeing no hands we now close the public
hearing
on house bill
and
i'm going to
assign 1335 to a subcommittee
representative welch
i'm going to appoint you the chair of
the subcommittee
representative byrd
no
we'll put representative testament
representative boardney
and represent a muse
yes
all right this time i'll close the
hearing on
hp 1335.
is
at this time we're going to go ahead and
open the public hearing on hp 1105
relative to earn time credit
and the chair recognizes
chairman amnesty introduces bill
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee
i i'm representative daryl abbas i
represent rockingham county district 8
which covers salem
and
this just to be clear just to be
clarified with members of the committee
last year i know we've we've heard a lot
about the earn time credit program
and i've received a lot of comments
already and a lot of communications both
in support and uh in opposition to
uh hb 1105.
now if you look at rsa 651 a
22-a
there are various programs that someone
an inmate can complete in order to
reduce time off their sentence
we've over the years have expanded that
list it includes getting a high school
diploma you can get a bachelor's degree
even a master's degree
there's vocational programs there's
participation in family connection
programs
and a lot there's also on-the-job
training that they can receive and
mental health treatment
in any any inmate is eligible to receive
up to 21 months off their sentence
what
hb 1105 focuses on is
simply subsection f which does exclude
sections a through e
that which i just discussed
and what that section would apply to it
really allows it's kind of a catch-all
section where really any program that's
approved by the commissioner could be
an inmate to be eligible for up 60 days
off their sentence
it can be used an unlimited amount of
times up until the point at least they
reach the 21 months
and although i don't have an any issue
with the underlying policy
under subsection f itself
there was no limitation or otherwise
criteria for what any program would be
and how that would actually
uh how that can be used and applied
i've been there before it happens
that's that's why i'm not upset
but
i what i looked at is and please don't
mistake my testimony or the intent my
intentions i'm not in any way implying
that the current policy under subsection
f is being misused or misapplied
my concern is simply that it is
something that without any criteria what
would really qualify
in you know in terms of the curriculum
how many hours that the program would be
it seemed to me that it there could be
situations where
people would raise questions about
whether that program was sufficient
so i thought it was worth
at least the time being to put a
limitation on the catch-all provision by
limited limiting it to a single
uh eligibility for a single time use
similar how you if you got a your high
school diploma you couldn't get more
than one
and under subsection a so therefore you
are limited to one time use
and i'll answer any questions
there being none
oh well there's one there you go all
right represent true
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
look looking at section
f which is what your bill
deals with
for that program that section f is
talking about
you could only get a
one no matter how many you completed you
could only get one 60 day off
program
thank you for your question as written
in the current law
a person can complete the program
by my math it was ten and a half times
each time they they complete it
they would get be eligible for six they
would get 60 days off their sentence
so what i'm trying what i'm explaining
is that
there is no criteria
of how that program makes you eligible
other than it's approved by the
commissioner
so
there's no
guidance beyond that point but you can
keep repeating that program up until you
reach the 21 months
and what the bill would do would mean
you only could complete the catch-all
provision one time and receive just a
single 60 days off your sentence you can
keep
re-entering a different taking a
different program one after another and
continuing reducing your sentence
thank you
representative muse
thank you for taking my question um you
had said the
your reason for submitting the bill was
because of the lack of qualifying
criteria in the current statute
but what your bill appears to do is to
just limit the amount of credits as
opposed to actually changing the
criteria would changing the criteria be
another way to address this
thank you for your question
without without having a spec a clear
criteria of what would qualify under the
catch-all provision
uh to me limiting the the amount of
times it's applied was i thought the
best course to go because
what i believe is an appropriate
criteria
i can imagine and i love working with
everyone on this committee but i know we
may have all different opinions on that
but if you if the criteria was really
specific i don't think there would be as
much of a motivation to
reduce at least to one time i mean maybe
it would be two or three times that they
can be eligible which might be a
reasonable but having a criteria for i
think would benefit
would benefit the the concern that i
have
and
one of the other things that i'm i'm
curious about too are the the types of
programming uh that are currently
offered as part of this this catch-all
so
i'm
i'm wondering uh you know what's offered
what the advantages of of taking it are
and if there are advantages
to completing multiple programs instead
of just one
uh from the perspective i guess of both
the doc and the uh
and the resident
thank you for your question in in some
circumstances and assuming that the
programs that we're i'm speaking of
don't fall under subsections a through e
which
cut does cover a lot of ground
and and this is part of the problem with
creating a criteria without knowing
because it's kind of a catch-all without
knowing what the program is it's really
hard to articulate what the criteria
would be so think of like if you're
getting your real estate license there's
a certain amount of hours in the course
you have to take in order to complete
the program i'm just saying without as
written now
it's not really clear i just don't know
without knowing what the program is it's
hard to actually put that all together
so that's some of the concerns i have as
well
thank you
representative boardney
thank you sheriff thank you for taking
my question
so
i'll go back and and read because i love
the read
oh good um
but
it says here in an f
that uh
a prisoner who
meaningfully participates in any program
that is authorized and approved by the
department that the commissioner
deems to be valuable so someone is
making an evaluation that
hopefully we can trust and that is the
commissioner corrections and i'm sure
that the commissioner of corrections is
not going to approve
a program
repeatedly for the same person unless
they're getting something from it
so
is your bill really necessary
thank you for your question uh and first
of all i wouldn't file a bill unless i
thought it was necessary
but with that being said there is a the
criteria for what the commissioner would
evaluate is that they believe it will
meaningfully assist the person the
inmate in rehabilitation
what i'm saying is that there's no
there's nothing actually articulating
though what
the in-depth of that program is
whether it's course hours
and for them for a person to be able to
get 21 months off their sentence i mean
in theory they could take a attend a
lecture on a iphone or
an electronic device that's 20 minutes
long and that could satisfy now i'm not
i'm not saying that that's happening
frequently but it certainly is a concern
that could happen in the future and
again i'm not suggesting that it's
currently being taken advantage of but
it seems to me like something worth
worthy of clarifying
follow-up
so what right now we are
relying on the judgment of the
commissioner of corrections to evaluate
whether it is a valuable for the real
reputation of prisoners just like we uh
value the
judgment of judges on assigning
sentences
is there a question yes shouldn't we be
relying on the judgment of the
commissioner of corrections
well i
thank you for the question i certainly
don't think you should take all the
discretion away from the commissioner
especially
i i don't i don't see any
any reason why the commission wouldn't
be involved in this process throughout
the you know whether it's a through f
altogether i think the commissioner's
obviously going to play an active role
in that but like judges we create
sentences
there's sentencing criteria but we when
we pass legislation and create a penalty
there are sometimes limitations on what
that that sentence can be whether it's
shortening a term or making it a life
sentence or even
beyond that when it comes to fines it's
the same
issue the judge sometimes has the
discretion to waive a fine reduce the
fine it could be a fine up to a certain
amount so there is a lot of discretion
that can be taken into place
but in with in this scenario i'm just
explaining that there really is
no set criteria to for someone who's
been convicted of a crime to be able to
reduce their sentence by 21 months
i would just think that there would be
some structure to especially with the
catch-all provision because that seems
to be more
um
it's less directed at a specific topic
like some of the what you see in
subjection a through e thank you
thank you for your testimony
thank you
we now call pamela kylie
good afternoon mr chair and members of
the committee my name is pamela keilig
and i am the public policy specialist at
the new hampshire coalition against
domestic and sexual violence the
coalition is the umbrella organization
for our 12 community-based crisis
centers
who provide free and confidential
services to nearly 15 000 victims of
domestic and sexual violence each year
i'm here in support of hb 1105 which
would provide
guidance on the number of applications
submitted for earn time credits in new
hampshire correctional facilities as it
pertains to the other programs category
thank you so much for the opportunity to
speak today
and i apologize for being nervous
this bill makes a simple yet important
amendment to the number of applications
that an inmate can submit to receive
earn time credit within the other
programs category
as an organization that advocates on
behalf of victims of crime in this state
we see this change as necessary to
ensuring that the balance is maintained
in the criminal justice system that
meaningful rehabilitation and community
justice can take place
the change will not restrict the
opportunities for incarcerated
individuals to participate in
rehabilitative programming
but instead we'll insert an important
guardrail to limit any insincere use of
this well-intentioned program
just to give you some background of what
we've seen over the last couple of years
the pandemic opened up online
programming making programs more readily
available and being completed at a much
more rapid rate while this was a
necessary change given the circumstances
it has also had unintended consequences
including a flood of applications under
this other program's category that we
are addressing today as the earn time
credit program is implemented now these
applications are being submitted at a
frequency that has had negative impacts
on victims and their families
especially around their mental health
and their safety
and i think it's just really important
that we all whenever we're making these
decisions that we're considering victim
input
victims and survivors in new hampshire
have experienced some of the most
unthinkable and traumatizing events
the nature of domestic and sexual
violence is deeply personal where the
offender intentionally uses forms of
abuse to maintain power and control over
another individual
unfortunately this abuse continues
throughout a victim's engagement with
the criminal justice system
and i want to just note that we are
incredibly grateful for the work of the
department of justice's victim witness
assistance unit and victim services at
the department of corrections who
provide critical support to crime
victims and their families
these services help ensure that criminal
justice system minimizes further harm
through these supportive services
this is important because i think it's
we really need to remember that behind
every
person going through these
rehabilitative programs is a victim or a
family of victims that are trying to
heal
and to kind of further illustrate this
according to the department of
corrections website victim services
staff documented over 9 000 contacts
with more than 3800 victim survivors and
their families in 2017
that's the most recent data i could find
and there were also 351 new requests for
victim notification during that fiscal
year
so victims can remain heavily involved
in the criminal justice process long
after the trial occurs
we hear from countless victims victims
families and
service victim service providers about
the ongoing trauma that victims
experience even after a person who has
harmed them has been incarcerated and
this can take on many forms one of that
is being notified that their abuser has
received earned time credit which
lessens their sentence and often makes
them eligible for parole long before
someone even anticipated that happening
when a victim chooses to engage in the
criminal justice system as a way to hold
their abuser accountable they are
seeking safety security and a sense of
closure this is immediately disrupted
when a victim or their family learns
that the abuser has had a reduction to
their sentence
which can be extremely painful
stress-inducing and re-traumatizing
i say this all just with
in context of this bill
that an inmate's rehabilitation cannot
occur in isolation it should be in
response to and acknowledging the
particular harm that was created through
an effort to learn from and move beyond
that incident but it requires mutual
understanding as well as recognition
that harm was committed in the first
place
this bill really helps maintain that by
establishing guidelines that balance the
opportunities for inmates to apply for
in time while also ensuring that victims
are granted the space to heal and have
their safe and not have their safety
jeopardized
so i just closed by saying i hope you
consider
having this conversation around this
bill
and i really urge the committee to
consider passing this legislation thank
you so much
thank you for testimony
the committee now calls in a call can
put
now it's on okay thank you
all right good afternoon mr chair and
members of the committee my name is
nicole kippet i am the administrator of
the victim services unit at the new
hampshire department of corrections and
i am here today in support of this house
bill
i want to just thank you ahead of time
for hearing my testimony my goal here
today is for you to hear
the victim side and to see this bill
from that lens
so at the victim services unit we do
strive to empower victims support them
and provide them with information
pertaining to their case
as they interface the criminal justice
system
so every year we are providing thousands
of notifications to victims of crime on
case status
whether that be about a transfer to
another facility or as a resident
transfers out of the prison system a lot
of our notifications do revolve around
earn time credit because it is impacting
the resident sentence
earned time credit is one of those
types of notifications that we provide
multiple on a weekly level
and i want to share how that has
impacted victims today so just to give
you a background or just to give you a
little bit of context with how those
notifications go out so when a resident
applies for earn time credit within the
new hampshire department of corrections
and that is approved by the commissioner
of corrections or denied by the
commissioner my office receives that
notification and then we provide that
notification to the victim who is signed
up to receive notification from my
office so a notice will go out at that
time so we will be informing a victim
that
a the
application was approved and this is the
sentence reduction
or it's denied or it's approved and now
the offender now has to submit a motion
to the court
receiving those notifications or
multiple notifications on earntime
credit as you can imagine can be
disheartening
and re-traumatizing for victims and
that's what i really want to hone in on
today is that re-traumatization that
this can cause
and today you'll hear firsthand and
hopefully you all receive some testimony
from victims as well who will
articulate very well how earn time
credit has impacted them and how it has
been has been re-traumatizing
um and one thing to note is how it can
certainly have an impact on
their healing process so whether that
halts their healing process or
makes them take step back in their
healing process
so i just want to make a few points
like pamela already said it's really
important to acknowledge that
the victims have already been through a
very traumatizing experience just having
been
a victim of crime having to go through
the rigorous criminal conviction process
and then start to understand
post-conviction and then to be faced
with the realities of earn time credit
and sentences being reduced up to 21
months for an offender's
rehabilitative efforts to get time off
and
hopefully correct some of their behavior
a lot of times when an offender is
sentenced that gives
the victim time to heal in time to
allow themselves space to feel safe and
to work towards full healing
so when earned time credit is granted
that can often compromise that
healing process
additionally with earned time credits um
this can result in a victim not just
being informed about the process but
having to talk to multiple advocates at
my office at prosecution the prosecutor
and oftentimes having to go back and
relive their trauma in a court room
so some other victim related concerns
that i want to point out quickly
so a lot of times earn time credit was
not part of the underlying sentencing or
plea agreement if the resident was
sentenced prior to september 2014 that
would not have been part of the
sentencing so a victim would not
necessarily have agreed to those terms
you'll hear from the victim today who
that was the case
that was not an agreed term
so then an offender can do the treatment
get the earn time credit and then they
have to motion the court to then go
before a judge to have it either granted
or denied
so the victim who never agreed to it now
has to go back to court to either give
input or talk to prosecution about what
their options are in giving input and
possibly living with the reality of earn
time credit being granted regardless of
and then earn time credit can be
added in addition to
already time suspended for
other programs completed so
if a sex offender for instance was
granted two and a half years off of
their term for sex offender treatment
they can still apply for earn time
credit for behavioral health services as
well
there is also the other program's
expansion from legislation in 2020
this definitely
created an influx in the other category
other programs category where multiple
residents were applying i think pamela
alluded to that as well and then the
other part i really want to hone in on
is
the level of safety and i've touched
based on this a couple times but just to
go a little bit deeper
so when earn time credit is granted say
it is granted to the full 21 months off
of a minimum and maximum oftentimes as
part of sentencing whereas part of
parole conditions a victim can request
time
can request for no contact orders or
travel conditions so when earned time
credit is granted and those sentences
are reduced we're actually reducing
certain levels of safety with no contact
orders or travel conditions that could
be in place for longer but are actually
reduced because of earned time credit
so i i think that's where i will
move on from and kind of come to a
conclusion at this point i don't want to
take too much of your time um but in
conclusion i don't think that victims
are necessarily against the
rehabilitative intent of earnt time
credit
in fact i have worked with plenty of
victims who have been in support of
earned time credit and their offender
getting the rehabilitative services that
really are necessary for them to be
productive members of society
i think what it comes down to is
weighing and balancing the victims level
of safety and their input with the
rehabilitation of the resident who is
incarcerated and that's really what i
wanted to present to you all today
and if you have any other questions or
questions for me i'm happy to answer and
again i appreciate the time that you've
given me to um speak and hear from the
victim services lens of things regarding
this bill
representative bourdain
secretary thank you for taking my
question
um
it seems to me that notifications from
to the victims
from
the prison concerning uh things that
have changed in
the uh inmate
uh seemed to
traumatize the victim again and it i'm
wondering if
these notifications of which i've just
heard
people have signed up for
is really
such a great idea
i appreciate your question
it is their right to have notification
and to be kept aware of the resident's
status so it is it is part of their
healing process oftentimes to be
informed and involved and to have input
in that process
thank you
there is another program
uh called
earn time off for good conduct do
victims get
notification of those credits as well
all right thank you for your question
again are you referencing the 150 days
that they receive
as part of their sentencing structure
i'm referencing credits for good conduct
uh in
51 8 22
uh two and a half days a month for good
contact conduct
good conduct a month we do not provide
notification on that no all right thank
you very much
representative conley
thank you and thanks for taking the
question
forgive me if this was
clear to others in your testimony but is
your concern
the amount of total time that could be
earned or is it the fact that anyone
could earn any time credit at all
thank you for your question
um it's not
that it's not opposed to the amount of
earned time credit that can be given the
21 months
i think it goes back to the amount that
is being applied for under the other
category
thanks for that question and just to
show the impact that it has on victims
in general thank you
there be no oh there's one more
representative
um
one thing i
i'm i'm kind of a little curious about
is how the notification comes to victims
so
um
i was a victim in a credit card case and
i get notifications from the department
of justice and there
about the status of the trials of the
people of whether or not they were
imprisoned when they'll be getting out
they're very short they're very clinical
they're a little scary
and
i'm just wondering is
is the problem the earned income credits
or is it the way that these
notifications happen is there
is there a better way of setting
expectations maybe with victims that
this is part of the process and this is
something
maybe they should
expect
as opposed to
be alarmed about
thank you for your question um
i think that
i guess to answer a couple of your
questions that i don't think there's any
perfect system for notifying a victim of
any change of status i do think that our
letters are very
as best as we can victim responsive and
sensitive
we try to provide them as much
information and education as possible
and we have tried to do a lot of
education to prosecution
around earn time credit just so that
they are aware how many sentences are
being impacted so that victims can be
properly educated on earn time credit
and again we are doing education as best
as we can we've created
a sheet that we hand out to victims as
soon as we get an earn time credit
application so that they can be aware
and see firsthand what a resident can
get earn time credit for and how it
works
but i do appreciate your feedback on
that
if i could ask a question um just so the
rest of the committee has kind of an
idea
your office doesn't
doesn't handle um
credit card fraud for for lack of a
better term could you give us an example
of some of the crimes that the victims
are suffering from sure um thank you for
the question we provide notification and
services to any felony level survivor of
crime so whether that's identity theft
burglaries robberies homicides
death resulting from drug overdose
sexual assault and domestic violence any
felony level crime where someone is
incarcerated the victim of that crime
can sign up for our services
so
under identity theft that could actually
involve credit card correct if that
included uh
a prison sentence yes that is the case
very good thank you very much you're
welcome uh representative
thank you mr chair question of the chair
do we have anyone else coming from
department of corrections to testify
yes we do thank you
there being no further questions we
appreciate your testimony thank you
and i do have copies so i'll hand those
out
we now call aaron brown
and you have written testimony
and maybe you could shorten it up from
15 minutes
thank
you for 15 minutes
good afternoon mr chairman uh honorable
members of the board my name is aaron
brown um retired manchester police
detective i come here uh before you
today as a victim of attempted murder um
in the written testimony you'll get
delaney is pretty much what happened
i'll sum it up real quick essentially um
back in april of 20 2013
all on patrol and encounter with an
individual during a car stop
um it's an individual provide fake
identity ultimately fled on foot
from the stop while chasing this person
as i closed in to grab him and take him
into custody he turned on me and fired
at me with a handgun
um
you know the encounter being so close
that my uniform was burned from the
gunpowder discharge
you could feel the heat on my face
i lost my hearing i had eyesight
problems
and so on
after exchange of gunfire the foot chase
continued i eventually caught up to this
person arrested him
it was only afterwards that we found out
the scope of the criminality this
individual had been involved in
that particular day he was in possession
of not one but three fully loaded
semiotic handguns that he was using to
you know insulate and protect his uh
criminality
he was in possession of hundreds of
oxycodone tablets which
eventually transformed into what we're
seeing now with the heron and the
fentanyl epidemic
he was uh already inserted into the
department of corrections i was on
probation however he was listed as a
fugitive uh because he just decided that
he was going to obey the terms of his
probation
and they kind of lost track of him
you know due to his efforts to be
not seen or heard from um at any rate
you know he faced
you know several felony charges that day
obviously the most serious being
attempted murder of a police officer
this person would go to court and
ultimately plead guilty to all those
charges
it was sentenced to 20 to 80 years at
the new hampshire state prison
as a victim of the crime i was in
agreement with his plan sensing
on the condition that he
waved
any ability to reduce his sentence so
in the simplest terms there was nothing
that he could do
the day of his plan sensing
that he could do once in prison to
reduce spending every day of the 20
years incarcerated nor could he do
anything to reduce the remainder
of the 80 years once out on parole so he
was to do all that time within the
correctional system
fast forward um to 2014 you had the
passage of irsa 651a22a
and essentially it threw this young man
a lifeline in terms of a sentence
reduction so all he had to do basically
for the rsa as you know is get
permission from
the commissioner of corrections and then
perform the courses and then once
completed he would have to petition the
court um to have that applied to a
sentence so currently uh this individual
from every right has accrued 180 days
worth of earned time credits under that
statute he's petitioned the court of
course i objected and now where um that
matters before the court hasn't been
decided yet so i anticipate there'll be
hearings
and so on and so forth with respect to
that
as it relates to the um house bill 1105
we're here for today
i'm obviously in support of the changes
that would make uh regarding the um
you know the special courses or the the
other courses in terms of the unlimited
amount of time currently that inmates
can get um i see no reason why they
should be afforded the opportunity to
get unlimited credit for
um you know right now unspecified
courses um as someone mentioned they
could essentially accrue the 21 months
maximum time under that uh portion of
the law
um
you know whereas obviously the bill
today would limit that to 60 days
which you know i think is appropriate
um
i understand you know the passage of
that law a lot of times there's a lot of
nuance in other things
regarding sentences and someone spoke to
it earlier um
you know the truth and sentencing here
in new hampshire it's just little things
like that that you know as
the victim of attempted murder if i knew
today what i then what i knew today in
terms of of this law and his ability to
reduce his time i obviously wouldn't
have agreed to the sentence that was
basically the sticking point for me
agreeing to the 20 to 80. and so um
you know i can attest when i get the
letters from the victim's office in the
mail my first reaction is now what and
then to open that letter and read that
you know this person
is not only eligible but now has
completed courses and is slated to get
you know at this point 180 days worth of
credit
um i guess you can imagine how upsetting
or troubling that would be to someone in
my position
um
so i think
i think i can leave it there uh i thank
you for for allowing me to speak i can
answer any questions if there are any
there being none thank you for your
testimony
thank you
the committee now calls
thomas adams
ccjr
good afternoon members of the committee
i'm tom adams a concord resident
and executive board member of the
citizens for criminal justice reform a
membership organization
registered as a new hampshire
corporation
non-profit
our members are seeking a system of
justice that protect protects our
communities
while promoting the rehabilitation of
offenders
it also prepares an inmate for re-entry
into civil society
a reunification with their families
communities and possessing the knowledge
and skills
for obtaining and maintaining
gainful employment
since our formation ccjr has advocated
for programs which rehabilitate inmates
and prepare them for successful re-entry
into society
we have in the past collaborated with
legislators the department of
corrections to institutionalize
vocational training programs such as
high school diplomas
college degrees mental health courses
and on-the-job training
we do support specialized programs
and this is the instant case we're
dealing with in this amendment proposed
amendment we do support specialized
programs tailored to individual needs of
inmates
we oppose the enactment of this
amendment
because it will eliminate individualized
programs that the commissioner
quote
deems valuable to a
prisoner's rehabilitation
end of quote
hp
1105 proposes to delete
section 822 af
and limit those specialized programs to
a one-time reduction of 60 days
our current
helen hanks
the commissioner
is a prudent
thoughtful and focused administrator
trust me you know that by experience i
know that by experience
she is guided by the doc's
mission
and core values
along with her staff she is committed to
reduce recidivation providing safe
secure
humane supervision
and
clearly
evidence-based
rehabilitation
to enhance what the public safety in new
hampshire
it is evidence
based
individualized programming
that's key
that's in the mission
of the department and its core value
section uh
651 a 2 2 a f of the current law allows
the commissioner to create individual
plans that address an inmate's specific
needs
in this sense
these experiences are akin to
individualized education plans which are
used in new hampshire public schools
these are plans focused on the
individual based upon their needs
determined by assessments
this section helps accomplish a
doc core mission
namely to provide evidence-based
rehabilitation to enhance public safety
to enhance public safety
and reduce recidivation
and engage in
progressive rehabilitation i've noted
the mission and core values as an
appendix to this document i think it's
extremely important that this committee
who knows all about that probably should
re-read it again when you take a look at
this proposed amendment
research has documented that a key to
reducing
reincarnations is improving the physical
and mental health of inmates providing
educational and vocational programs that
will prepare them for a congenial life
in the family gainful employment and
participation as informed citizens in
civil society that's what we need
these evidence-based programs do not
coddle inmates
they are not like a free lunch
they are not a form of recreation
they require work in the classroom
and they require homework
completed in an inmate's cell
this is not being soft on crime or
punishment
they demand
the department demands tenacity for
learning while inculcating
a love of lifelong learning because if
if this doesn't stimulate
growth in the future for these inmates
who are released
then they may return
so they
the department's well aware of that
that's why it's evidence-based these
programs are focused on recovery and
rehabilitation
the doc staff is creating programs and
experiences to stem recidivation
and future victimization
when an inmate re-enters society
they often do not possess work skills
knowledge and mental health stability
which limits their employability to
menial
low-paying jobs
many become homeless and live on the
fringes of society where their need to
survive lures them into committing
crimes again
national research has shown that former
inmates who complete some high school
subjects have a recidivation rate of 55
percent
and vocational training cuts recidivate
recidivation or reentry back to prison
if i get the word right
to about 30 percent
possession of an associate's degree
reduces the chances of reoffending
to
13.7 percent
earning a bachelor's degree the rate
drops to 5.6
it's amazing
and i would ask you to take a look at
the link that i provided to gives the
research behind those statements now
those are national statements take a
look at what's happening and i'm sure
that
helen hanks will provide you with this
information see what happens to the
reentry rate
in new hampshire over the past
few years
it's declined
declined but you'll see that
now i also want to point out to you the
bad college prison initiative
and the support program
for after release from prison is
extremely successful
the rate of return is less than five
percent it's below the national average
bard has partnered with many colleges
and universities including the
university of vermont
and yale
as well as many many other universities
and colleges throughout the
country
i've also provided you a link with the
bad college prison initiatives annual
report this is very important because
it's just chock full of information that
this committee needs to use
and it's simple it's down-to-earth
straightforward
you need to use in terms of
understanding
some of the
importance or the importance of
ensuring less crime after
being discharged from prison
this earned time opportunity is based on
incentives
research has shown that behavioral
modification does facilitate change in
behavior
these incentives are used to encourage
inmates to improve their lot
many of them have a fatalistic view of
life
they lack a positive outlook about
themselves
many have a defeatist attitude they've
hit the gutter and can't climb out
i'm not sympathetic to criminals i'm
hard on punishment
but i'm hard on rehabilitation
i think it's important
in order to preserve society
the obstacles to them seem too high i've
got fallen so low why try
i'm going to end up in the same gutter
all over again
they're discouraged by peer pressure in
in the prison by other prisoners it's
difficult to take that home
homework into your cell and work
because some prisoners
don't like it
and that can be tough on those who want
to change
earned time credit is an inducement for
them to learn it is a form of behavioral
uh modification
reduce reducing recidivism
prevents more crime and accompanying
costs of reincarnation
reincarnation
reincarnate reincarnate
return to prison
i
you know i used to teach
i'm amazed at myself i've deteriorated
in my old 80 years it is a self-interest
of our state to reduce the numbers of
re-offenders thus reducing prison costs
it will provide
safer communities and that's what
miss hanks is going to be talking about
i'm pretty sure
that is why the mission of the doc
resonates with our membership
our membership urges this committee to
determine that this amendment is
inexpedient to legislate
and as i said before
you'll find the department mission and
goals at the bottom of this
because it's important that we focus on
what its intents are
thank you
representative bourdain
thank you chair
thank you for taking my question
uh according to uh
our laws
the
uh time
earned time off is limited to 300 days
which
do prisoner inmates ever take more than
enough courses to make uh
over 300 days off
i don't know that fact you could ask
helen about the statistics i don't want
to put words in their mouth okay thank
you
representative penalakis
thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question could you tell me who
pays for the courses that these people
take
in college
you'd have to ask helen that i don't
know what the current status is we've
debated that question over and over
again
uh it and may i assure you that before
covert
the department doc
had started a working with some area
colleges which our organization wants to
participate in and we're very
encouraging by the baad program
and so the costs were discussed but i
don't know the current situation thank
you
i'm going to recognize myself for a
question um
we we've talked about
the rehabilitation and the necessity to
rehabilitate and and i agree with all
those things but we also heard from
victims and there's a there's definitely
a balancing act
that the legislature has to look at
and
so we heard from a police officer who
was basically shot in the face and he's
got ptsd for the rest of his life i'm
quite sure and someone who was sentenced
to 20 to 80 years in prison
do you not see anywhere in there where
there are certain levels or certain
crimes so heinous that the there should
be a limitation on what they can whittle
away at the time they have to serve
is there no punitive aspect at all in
your mind for for incarceration yes i
just i think i said that i'm hard on
crime
i am hard on crime
absolutely i'm not a about crime
trust me trust the students i taught
we will pardon you
i'm sorry i didn't hear you maybe i
shouldn't have
uh
crime and punishment is a balancing act
the the mission of the department is to
punish
the state wants to prevent future crimes
and the
the judicial system is the one that
makes the decision of how long
and they can put conditions
on that sentence
okay
i also believe that it's in the
no matter what the highness crime may be
that person
might
change
and that's the goal
if the person is not changing
trust me the penal system will keep them
in place
and the parole
board will
this is based on evidence-based
information and research this is tough
and i agree with you i would say to the
victim
victims groups
we all should be advocating for
education of those who are victimized
because there's a concurrent need
for the people who have been
a victim
to be helped
we can't
their sentence with this memory
is devastating i don't care if it's
someone taking money on the bank as they
did with me from russia
or it's a person of a sexual assault you
still
have grief
and and uh and that has to be dealt with
i think the state has a responsibility
to do that
and i certainly would consider uh
legislation that deals with that
thank you for your testimony
thank you
we now call joseph laskas aclu nh
okay that brings us to helen hanks
um that's a tough act to follow but
well i won't
never mind
helen hanks commissioner of the
department of corrections for the record
and
not intended to confuse the committee
you did hear from our administrative
victim services because the mission of
corrections includes supporting victims
rights as well
but on behalf of the agency we are not
in favor of the amendment in hb
1105 and i've given you a twofold an
opportunity to provide you a
comprehensive packet of information
both to demonstrate the effects of
earntime credit since its inception and
obviously moving forward
i'll start off by just clarifying some
what i call misinformation not
misintended but misinformation no one is
awarded earn time credit for completing
the same program over and over and over
again it is a one-time consideration for
the completion of that one program
that's deemed eligible and we have an
internal policy that i also attached uh
to the testimony that is specific to
what's allowable
uh so i wanted to be clear there
and to represent pandalaka's question on
pays for courses
as we went through the budget process i
appreciate the legislature for restoring
most of our educational funding but i
was also provided a mission and a charge
which is to find a tele path to
education as well and we've continued to
do that so in many instances as we even
testified in 2014
individuals who are working to attain an
associate's degree or higher are paying
for that out of their own pocket
the department provides opportunity for
a high school diploma and individuals
who are working toward their high school
equivalency certificate have to pay 60
dollars for that certificate program
i've taken that charge from the budget
process seriously and we're moving
forward with some partners in the pell
grant area now that the federal
government's provided that opportunity
as well as a recent approval of arp
dollars to create the i.t infrastructure
for would make those things possible
to the numbers of people uh to represent
a boarding's question that have hit 21
months you can only hit 21 months you
may not achieve more than that that's a
rare instance
since our time credits inception and one
thing people haven't talked about is i
actually deny
people earn time credit
as the commissioner because their time
credit they're applying for is not
indicative of their prisoners
rehabilitation and i think one mindful
very mindful
element of the statute is it's not
prisoners it's it's individualized there
is an apostrophe s rehabilitation i have
individuals whose primary need is sexual
offender treatment who have remitted
applications for other earn time credit
and i have declined them because they
are not willing to engage in sexual
offender treatment and their primary
criminogenic behavior was sexually
deviant behavior
i wanted to make those points readily
clear
i want to talk about what has happened
since earntime credit and some of the
things as this agency has done as many
of you have done is surmounted a
pandemic in a corrections environment in
a way that if you had asked me in 2017
to become the commissioner and become
the commissioner of corrections through
a pandemic i would have politely
declined
but with that said balancing
coveted quarantine medical isolation
having our 1900 plus individuals who are
incarcerated today have to be
quarantined in some cases up to 28 days
we did leverage our tablet technology
and through that tablet technology is a
learning management system so we both
facilitated coursework through our
granite state high school as well as
one
two two programs under other a
combination what's called the peace
education program and 10 correctional
rehabilitation institute programs
as well as a breaking free from
substance use disorder i've included
all of that information in this packet
and the origin of the foundation for
those decisions
one nuance that has only come to my
attention since uh donna scitec brought
it to my attention so i appreciate it
for that is there's a report that comes
out from those other programs that has a
time to completion
and it was articulating that in some
instances they were completing things in
eight minutes well that seems not
equitable nor accurate so i'm working
with the vendor
to say is that numeric correct and they
said actually it's not it's not counting
everything that they're doing so i just
want to share that as a piece of
information
so if i go backward the department of
corrections and quite frankly the state
of new hampshire should be quite proud
for the last several years u.s news has
has
seen us in a positive light twofold for
a reduction in crime in our state and
for the positive way in which we manage
corrections and that's the balance
between
the penalty associated with the criminal
act and the rehabilitation and
sentencing efforts we've moved forward
on
we should be honored and proud of that
because that is the mission that my
national corrections commissioner
partners engage in every day and so
taking the person who's incarcerated
because most of them are returning to a
community near us and finding a
rehabilitative path is our mission our
primary mission each and every day and
earn time credit has created an
opportunity
for people to be incentivized to engage
but it also has created several layers
of opportunity for that earned time
credit to be forfeited so i also forfeit
earn time credit post award if they
engage in a major a disciplinary action
during incarceration or if they join a
security threat group i forfeit their
earn time credit because it is a
privilege on top of an incentive
those instances do happen
when i during the height of the pandemic
needed to create appropriate
rehabilitative opportunities we measured
deploying and using that tablet learning
management system and did a study 20
excuse me 12 months prior to that
implementation and looked at our major a
offenses and then looked at them after
12 months and there was approximately a
21 decline in adverse a offense behavior
and balanced with we still had the same
number of quarantine and medical
isolations because one would say they
weren't going anywhere what could they
do well
that was all balanced so that did make a
difference as far as change in
institutional conduct and rehabilitative
value the other part in my testimony and
i apologize for the size even i'm
struggling to read it
is what is happening in our department
of corrections is because of these
development of other programs is things
that don't fit into the other sections
of the statute so we've deployed those
rehabilitative programs and the re
recidivism rate one year post release is
going down it's going down significantly
each year that's a great sign and then
the following year so starting in 2018
2019 and 2020 people are not in new
hampshire returning to incarceration and
we continue to measure that that's
rehabilitation
i want to drill in other programs as
deemed by the commissioner yes by deemed
by the commissioner but vetted by
national science if you will moral
recognition therapy is a copy written
program we deploy that you can earn
earned credit for that
with breaking free from substance use
was actually designed in the uk
specifically to work in corrections
environments we deploy that i actually
sometimes deny people sometimes approve
it it depends on if
they're actually meeting the level of
participation associated with their
latex assessment
thinking for a change i think this
committee has heard of that program it
is a nationally recognized uh
intervention for rehabilitation to
change your criminogenic thinking
the other part on earned time credit is
the actual and i provided you a copy of
the state sentencing document and i 100
empathize with individuals who went
through the justice system before the
deployment of this law
because it i do struggle when i have
those applications and it's not on their
sentencing minimus how that affects
the history of of the decisions made at
sentencing but i also trust the
judiciary process and that vetting
process and that happens in other
instances of state statutes such as
someone seeking a two-thirds reduction
and other elements of state law that
allow someone to even their own
independent motion to suspend portions
of their sentences all trigger those
communication events and touches with
the judiciary system
but i've highlighted that in the
testimony that on the minimus the
education at sentencing if that box is
checked should be to the people who are
participating that you can you can
experience up to
21 months of earn time credit
notification that those might happen if
that box is checked and what would
happen if that box is not checked that
they would then try to solicit that
through the judiciary process post
incarceration
so i included a copy of that
the other thing i put in here is there
are three basic principles associated
with determining if a program has
rehabilitated value in a corrections
environment and that the treatment is
provided to people who assess for the
risk for it so you need you need it to
change we assess that in our
organization both through our risk
assessments with our case managers our
clinicians and so on and so forth
through the incarcerated process
and that the treatment program actually
targets those criminogenic behaviors
that have resulted in the
incarceration so it's anti-social
attitude substance use disorder
you know
anxiety self-esteem or feel goods but
it's a combination of all of those
things and finally that it's delivered
in a responsive way to the person's
style of learning
using cognitive behavioral approaches
and changing attitudes and ultimately
teaching concrete skills that that
change how they respond in the future
i bring that up and i'm headed to a
close to let you ask me questions
because i think one thing we've not
talked about is the average grade level
of a person who's incarcerated is fifth
grade so if we wrote all of our programs
at a associate's bachelor's degree level
we would not be rehabilitating people so
some of the things you see in here seem
maybe middle schoolish it should because
they have to translate to the audience
participating in them and i include
those statistics for you
so as we charge for to improve the
literacy of those incarcerated in new
hampshire we also have to provide a
balance of how we deploy information so
it's actually absorbed understood
processed and adapted
i assure you and i appreciate the
comments made about the prudency in
which i
move forward on this and i do
that we look at rehabilitative programs
we do take feedback we obviously make
adjustments i've also included our
application
it's a it's just the cover sheet that
does never never arrives to my office
alone it comes with numerous documents
attached
and with that i'd be happy to answer any
questions of the committee
representative true
thank you mr chair and thank you
commissioner for taking my question
um
as i keep warning people i was i was
pre-med not pre-law
looking at other programs i don't know
if you're familiar with the rsa i'm sure
you are yes i am okay looking at other
programs
i don't know how many there are i'm
going to say there are 10 10 other
programs that you have come up with
the way the amen the way the bill reads
do you read that that
even though there are 10 programs
four might be appropriate
for me
but only one of them is going to get me
60 days that's how i interpret the
proposal thank you you're welcome
representative um bordenay
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
how much time do you spend a week
evaluating uh
earned time off
representative boarding a i i spend a
surprisingly a lot of time a week
i in fact have i think 20 applications
on my desk for this week
so
over fifty percent i will spend at least
one days worth of yeah well i really i
don't really work eight hours you get a
lot of good time out of me so let's just
say roughly eight hours at a minimum of
reviewing those applications
thank you you're welcome
representative martin
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i'm assuming you're
in favor of us passing this bill i would
recommend you itl this bill and leave
the law as currently stated
thank you for that clarification you're
very welcome
representative newman
thank you chair and thank you for taking
my question i'm over here
um
we have testimony
that listed a whole bunch of programs
that look like they were all started on
the same day and ended up maybe
three days later and
i just don't is there anything like that
in the uh or if there is is there
anything like that if there is how does
it does it affect you do you know
anything about that it looks like maybe
they're online programs or something
like that i've not seen that i can only
assume that has to do with what we
deployed in december of 2020
obviously mid pandemic trying to
continue to deploy rehabilitated
programs we used our tablet learning
management system
and again donna brought something to my
attention
i don't know in the summer of
2021 that caused me to look more deeply
at those programs
thank you but i've not been provided
that thank you
representative newman the better part
yes
thank you
you have you have a big job
um i was
in tr
i was fascinated in listening intently
to your testimony and also the previous
testimony
by mr adams
um
i'm just going to begin my question with
a
comment that i heard years ago from some
of my elementary school teacher friends
that if you want to know
who's going to wind up in prison ask an
elementary teacher and you'll get an
idea of what's coming
in all of the programs that you have
i've heard you say that you can
determine a level of participation
i i want to i don't want to assume
anything but i'd like to ask is a
is a level of attitude adjustment
on an incarcerated person's
and is that evaluated by you also
so representative newman that's an
interesting question to try to ascertain
a level of attitude adjustment what i
will tell you is we absolutely look at
their conduct and you have to look at
the conduct
at least six months prior to their
submission of runtime credit and if
their conduct is not
exemplary
then i don't even consider the
application it doesn't even make it to
my desk
thank you you're welcome
representative
thank you for taking my question
um
one of the things that we've heard about
is the the problem
for some folks may be less with the
courses themselves
and more with the amount of
notifications and how that process takes
place
so
is there something
that could be done to to change that
process so for example i noticed that
you have
in the list of courses
there are some that have individual
names but there are others that appear
to be
more of a curriculum
where you have to actually complete
multiple courses to get a credit
um is there a way to structure things so
that it's
less of an individualized course that
can be completed
you know maybe in a few hours and more
more of a structured curriculum so
basically you're getting maybe more bang
for the buck and there are fewer
notifications to victims
representative muse i think that's an
interesting question and it balanced
with
if we're
i don't know that there's always a
one-size-fits-all approach to each
person
i do think that we could try to be more
mindful about
the process in which the application is
processed so instead of it being here's
one here's one here's one
maybe they only remit one application
for multiple things
every quarter or every six months or
something to that effect
but we could actually
likely change that in policy and not in
statute
thank you
okay that's gonna all right
representative jasmine
with the coursework you have
obviously it has to be completed
you know
by the prisoners
i have said heard it said that
you can tell how many prisoners you're
going to have by how many people can
read by the fourth grade
do you come
do a lot of your prisoners come to you
unable to read at a
at the level they can complete these
courses or are we making do we making
some
adjustments for them
representative testament that's a
mindful question people are coming in
with a very low literacy level and we
have to tailor our curriculum if it's
not already tailored to a fifth grade
lead reading level and we actually have
a grant um that we've recently deployed
that's working to do that through a
universal
learning design theory
so it's it's something we have to be
mindful of with everything that we do
representative boardney
thank you chair thank you uh
commissioner
um
i'll keep hearing stories about
how traumatized victims are
by notifications from the prison
uh
petitions to have be paroled for inmates
to be paroled
and i'm wondering what kind of pr i
heard nicole
but
can we do anything better to prepare our
help victims uh get over their trauma
representative ordinate i wouldn't
and i wouldn't attempt to try to answer
that question on the fly here but i'll
certainly work with our victim services
administrator to see what we can do to
improve or help
to represent muse's comment the process
um
i think it's the
it's the number of times and
and i think every person affected by a
criminal act really has their own path
forward for themselves
thank you very much you're welcome
representative pratt
that's a quick one
just a little one um
so you notify them every time that
they've earned time and they may reduce
their sentence to let people know
they're going to be getting out early
you let them know when they've been
penalized and it's gone the other
direction
i've i've started to include our victim
services department on all those
notifications okay yeah absolutely okay
that's the last question i'm gonna allow
for this witness
um but keep in mind members of the
committee that uh commissioner hanks is
very responsive to emails and if you
have any further questions she will get
right back to you
thank you for your testimony bill
whatever you need thank you
the committee now calls joseph laskas
thank you mr vice chair members of this
committee
my name is joseph lascaux i will be
representing the aclu of new hampshire
in opposition to this bill
and i am asking that this committee will
itl this immediately and i will answer
any questions that you may have based on
my testimony at the end
the first thing that i just wanted to go
into about this bill of why i'm opposing
this is it's based on a personal concern
over whether or not there is a full
understanding of the earned time credit
system and how it works
also coupled with the fact that this is
a department of corrections it's not a
department of punishment which means
that the goal the number one objective
of the department of correction is to
rehabilitate the people who go through
those doors
because we
as we know we're in we live in a state
where
over 90 percent of the people
incarcerated are going to be returning
back to the community at some point in
time so the goal should be to make sure
that they are rehabilitated that you
know
they do have an attitude adjustment as
it was stated and that they're ready to
come back to the community
what i wanted to point out was on line
uh starting on line three um
lines three and four it says the value
of the value to the prisoners
rehabilitation which are not covered
under
paragraph a through and the reason i'm
sorry line three starting with the um
that the commissioner deems to be
valuable to the prisoners rehabilitation
which are not covered
um the reason why that's there is
this is a person's personal journey as
someone who's been sentenced to the
department of corrections and i went
through that whole process and came back
to the community rehabilitated i can i
can assure you that a person's journey
to rehabilitation is unique it's
personal and sometimes people achieve
that milestone of being rehabilitated
through non-traditional means
and this this this goes to
representative boarding's question
earlier about the discretion of the
commissioner um leaving that to the
commissioner for um
to determine these programs and it is
actually necessary because um there is
not just one
um cookie cutter
mold for every individual who goes
through the department of corrections to
to achieve their rehabilitation and the
individuals who know the best of whether
or not someone is rehabilitated is going
to be those that work in the department
of corrections who are around
the residents 24 7. so i i think that
further restricting and limiting um the
incentives for people to take control of
their life and engage in programs or
activities that are going to actually
change them i think presents a a
dangerous
concern that i think that we need to
take a look at
one of the things i do want to
acknowledge
is the fact that yes the
the victims advocate groups are correct
about the re-traumatization that can
happen through notices i i do want to um
to to give them that uh that credence it
is
something that i recognize and i respect
one of the things that i wanted to to
talk about on that vein is the fact that
when an individual is rehabilitated they
are no longer the individual who created
or did the offense physically they may
be but mentally they are not the same
person and that is the shift that we're
looking for we're looking for a mental
shift because that is what determines
whether or not a person is going to be
rehabilitated we heard that crime has
been decreasing in the state and crime
decreasing in the state means that
people who are going back to the
community
are not re-victimizing people that you
know earlier today we heard about
re-victimization in the problem that
that that
presents to the state and so when we're
hearing that there are people that are
leaving the department of corrections
who are who are not re-victimizing
people we need to embrace that approach
and see what are they doing that we can
continue and replicate that process so
that you know we keep those numbers
going up
uh
the other issue that i think of why uh
this bill is is dangerous to limit the
um the earned time credit opportunities
is the prison itself is actually limited
to the environment that that it's that
it's at to to offer earn time credit um
uh opportunities so uh the prison
currently doesn't have wi-fi in the
prison right so if you if you had if
there was a program you know every
member of this committee could come up
with a program that everyone agreed with
let's just say all 24 members you know
agreed on a program if that program can
only be delivered on wi-fi and it's the
most rehabilitative program it it's not
currently going to be able to be
rolled out in the prison they don't have
that ability so they are limited to the
individuals that volunteer for the
programs that are hired to do the
programs um in what technological
advances or you know
capacities they have in order to roll
out programs so the tablet system was
was a step in that direction because
every resident who is incarcerated has
access to a tablet system and so what
that means is that every resident does
have the ability to meaningfully engage
in the programs that are offered on the
tablet system
and i do agree that you know what
whether if this is about having a
structure in place for the programs that
are that are there as opposed to
limiting the time i think that then that
should be explored but to actually just
limit the time across the board that is
very harmful and
and i use myself as an example of this
language specifically when it talks
about limiting a through e
um
i myself you know when i was sentenced
to the department of corrections i
didn't i didn't have kids so i was not
able to do the family connection program
i didn't have any mental health issues i
was not allowed to do any of the mental
health programs for earn time credit i
already had my high school diploma when
i was sentenced to prison which means
that i wasn't able to engage in the ged
or high set i had to buy my own time
credit through
through the college program and not
every residence has those economic means
where they're able to purchase um the
the college programs and they're you
know for someone that's incarcerated
that's that can be expensive so i i
think that
so but this bill right here would have
specifically applied to me where i
wouldn't i would have been just barred
across the board from the earned time
that the prison um offered and i think
that that uh that that is that's an
issue
one of the other things too is that at
the time of sentencing a judge
and a county prosecutor are aware of the
earned time credit provisions in this in
uh offered at the doc
that is a determination that they make
at the time of sentencing they the
county attorney will usually meet with
the the defense lawyer and the judge and
they will say well this individual
should be eligible for earn time credit
or no this individual shouldn't and
that right then and there is if they're
eligible for earned time credit at the
time of sentencing it would be safe to
assume hypothetically then that that
individual would be able to earn up to
21 months off of their off of their time
and and it's going to be through repeat
or repeated process there is not one
avenue in the prison to earn 21 months
of earned time credit you have to do
multiple things
and i think that when we take a look at
society as a whole we do see many
systems where this where you do have
a reward system that's in conjunction
with achievements where a person can
keep doing achievements and continue to
be rewarded for that i think that
saying that an individual doing a
program 10 times if they're doing 10
separate programs you don't know what
impact that will have on that individual
it may be a program that shifts that
person's thinking that stops them from
thinking about things in a criminal
manner and so i think that we should
they should have that ability and that
should be rewarded when they are taking
that conscious step to change their
actions and change their life and again
that is a determination
after the courts and the county attorney
has agreed to that that's a
determination that the department of
corrections looks at and i know that
they deny people because i'm the one
that gets the calls is like hey can you
sue the the doc they won't give me my
own time credit well why what happened
oh i got a ticket well well i i can't do
anything about that if you got a ticket
and so it does happen it's not just this
free
free reign for people um getting earned
time credit there are people that get
that that do get it um
um
denied
and um one of the last things that i i
wanted to um
to uh to to talk on was about the hours
in the curriculum
it depends on what the specific program
is there is an accounting program that
has multiple things underneath it um
that you know i think that
representative news has talked about
that you'll see those and you'll see
multiple things and that's why you get
one certification but there are some
other programs that are very specific
they are they are geared towards one
aspect and that is why they're only
under one one thing um
so that is uh that you know that's what
i would have to say on that
um
another thing that you know this is not
related to uh it is related to the
testimony that we heard today and as
someone who was referred to by by the
statements that were made i do feel that
i have a duty to to say this because it
was done in a public manner but we have
heard testimony today um concerning uh
concerning this bill that i that i
believe uh we need to we need to be
cautionary about considering where where
it came from and given that the fact
that there was a a public history of of
bias and racism towards the individuals
that would be affected by this
and with that i will
end my testimony and i'm happy to answer
any questions that the committee may
have
represented newman
for these earn time uh credit programs
can people take like two of them at the
same time can it be taken
in that manner or did they do them one
and then another one
sequentially so that's a that's a great
question you can take uh programs as
long as you are accepted into the
program so if
you know if you take the thinking for a
change program for example if this
program you know this program offers
earn time credit if you're in thinking
for a change while also currently
enrolled in a mental health program it
is possible yes that you could get earn
time credit for um you would get earn
time credit for both them and you could
be enrolled in both of them at the same
time
you could be enrolled in educational
classes while also enrolled in a mental
health class too and be able to
have earn time credit for both of them
but one thing that individuals
do and it's something that um you know i
i uh advise people when they when they
call and they ask um
you know is is that usually individuals
will wait
to till they have amassed all of the
earned time credit that they're either
gonna go for or that they can get and
then they put in for it at one time and
the reason why is because the wording of
it is that it has to occur on the
sentence that they are doing so there is
some some people don't un think that
well if i have a consecutive sentence if
i parole the second sentence i'm not
eligible to earn from my earn time so
they just want to do it on one time and
and that may not be the case um
statutorily but that is a philosophy
that people have so
usually people will wait till they have
gotten all their earned time and then
they'll put in for all at once which
will which will you know then go to the
commissioner if um they have the box
checked off on their minimus that allows
for the doc to award them good time and
earn time and if they don't then they
they will petition the courts
quick question sure did they have the
tablet program while you were
yes
and there being no wi-fi how does it
work did they upload the programs before
they issued the tablets how does that
work so it's an intranet system that um
that they came and installed the the
company came in they installed um
routers directly onto the housing units
itself and then these routers um they go
to a uh they they go out to um
the servers
the servers are hard lined to the
internet and that is you know that's
secure that's kept securely and so the
tablets while the tablets themselves
use a wi-fi system it's actually on the
internet it's internet so anything
that's on there's only you have access
to
thank you very much
thank you for your testimony
the committee now calls donna scitec
hello
um
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee i'm donna scitec i'm from
salem and i just finished 10 years on
the parole board
um
i asked
our representative abbas
to introduce a bill to call attention
to some concerns
that i had about the earned time credit
program
the legislature has approved the
awarding of time for
earned time for against their minimum
and maximum
for certain programs and i've given you
a copy of the statute and you can see
the types of programs and how many days
are uh
that they'd be eligible for if they
completed them and i would remind you
that this is
the earned time credit is applied not
only to their minimum but also to their
maximum
so the sentence is getting smaller from
both ends
and you heard the victim advocate talk
about
travel restrictions that would when we
parole somebody sometimes will say you
can't go to nashua because the victim
lives there that only works during the
period of their parole
and if their parole is shortened
through the application of runtime
credits the victim is less protected but
last year when i was still on the board
i noticed that uh inmates that we
typically would see two months before
their minimum
were coming to a parole hearing with
only weeks left to their minimum
and this was because they've been
awarded earn time credit under the new
provision
that was uh
offered in paragraph f of the current
law and i've highlighted that
this paragraph up the other programs
was new
now
i'm not a stranger to the legislature
uh
i follow the legislation i said where
did this come from
and looking at my experience on the
parole board you know suddenly there's
all this earned time credit indeed the
number of inmates are receiving earn
time credit in all of 2020 was 274.
so 274 people got earned time credit in
all 19 of
2020. but in the first first nine months
of 2021
it was 1266.
a 460
increase
so what the heck is going on
because this was during the pandemic and
a lot of the traditional programs had
been shut down so why where was all the
certain time credit uh coming from
so i looked at it and it was being
awarded for these other programs under
paragraph f
i said well where did that come from
so i did a little digging
and i found out that was added as an
amendment to an omnibus senate edna bill
that had 23 sections
this committee never saw this provision
it was thrown in and nobody paid
attention to it
so
before this
before this other program's provision
was added the legislature went through
and evaluated each of the programs that
would be eligible for on-time credit and
over the years the list has grown
and as has been said in the sentencing
document the judge specifies whether
they'd be eligible for end time credit
so
this uh the the new provision he gave
the commission of the authority to add
programs that she deems valuable to an
inmate's rehabilitation without coming
back to you i mean that that's a
inefficient way to do it
but that's the reason i'm here for you
today i'm worried about one particular
subset of the other programs
i'm worried about the programs that are
completed on the tablet
and an inmate
all the inmates have uh access to a
tablet and they can
watch a video uh selected from a list of
available programs and then they answer
questions that are multiple choice true
or false
the prisoners have told us they can
complete three or four programs in a
day's time
and all of this is done independently
nobody's watching them we don't know
whether they're cheating
there's no monitoring there's no
in-person group discussion like they
would be for a mental health program
or an educational program or a sex
offender program where you have to go
and actually do something other than
work on your tablet so i was concerned
about that
and so this i've on the back of this
sheet uh is a transcript of somebody who
completed some programs
and you can see from the dates
that he would start it
on you know march 11th and finish it on
march 11th and get 100
you go through all the programs that he
did he can do it really quickly
so i would question the value of
programs that can be
awarded earn time credit without any
anything other than watching a video and
answering true or false
i know that
i do a bible reading every day and
i probably forgot what i read yesterday
you know
so
something that you just read and don't
have any conversation any
any tests other than a multiple choice i
i just wonder
so
so all of this is to set up a policy
question for you the policy makers do
you think it's appropriate to award the
same 60-day sentence reduction for
spending a day or two watching videos
the same amount as for like a six-month
mental health program
our nine-month drug treatment program
our sex offender program
are a hands-on apprenticeship program
the
programs on the tablet are eligible for
60 days
is that
equivalent to these in-person programs
that require your participation and
engagement
so that's the policy question for you
personally i don't think they ought to
get 60 days for the tablet programs
the rest of the programs under other
are very valuable one of them is moral
recognition
not recognition moral recognation
therapy
and that is a series of uh in-person
programs and the inmates rave about it
how it has really changed them
maybe the legislature wants to specify
which of these other programs should be
eligible for 60 days
uh maybe you want to look at the tablet
programs and say maybe they're not maybe
they're worth something
that is 60 days maybe they're worth 30
days maybe they're worth something other
than that
um i'm aware that the uh department of
corrections is tightening up their
process for documenting all the programs
that are eligible for on-time credit and
that's a good thing uh but i question
the question for you is whether an
afternoon of watching videos should
merit the same 60-day sentence reduction
as a months-long in-person counseling or
educational or vocational program
i don't think so
uh
from my experience uh the most i've ever
seen an inmate awarded earn time credit
we had
a woman who was in who took advantage of
everything she got 620 days
that's the most i've seen for any inmate
now that's unusual
we also have
the current members of the board told me
about a
recent
parole hearing
where the inmate had been
he was going on social security
disability so they asked what's your
disability well i have a learning
disability
um
yet he was awarded earned time credit
for multiple
tablet programs
so
if you've got a learning disability how
are you going to complete a program that
you've got to watch a video and read the
test so we wonder about that
so i think this is something that is
ripe for legislative review
maybe you don't want to pass the bill as
introduced but i i would hope that you
would consider
um maybe listing the specific programs
that you think are eligible for 30 days
and decide whether you want to
give the same amount for tablet programs
if you think that everything's fine
don't pass the bill but if you think it
requires some attention
i would encourage you to
work with the department and figure out
what should be eligible for
what amount over in time credit
so i'll take any questions
representative newman
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i i owe an apology
because
this paper had been on my desk and i
didn't i i thought you had already
testified and i asked the question i was
referring to this paper
when i talked to commissioner hanks and
asked about this particular question
so i'll ask you
i'm confused as to whether you're in
favor of or against this bill and
because on the one hand you said you
think that the paragraph is helpful
and on the other hand you said that this
needs legislative review because this
this may not be appropriate to be
counted as one of the things that's
right i think
my preference would be to amend the bill
to say to add the the programs that are
currently offered under other and
specify them
moral recognition therapy choose love
thinking for a change
and say they'd be eligible for six
months
and decide whether you want to include
the programs that are on the tablet
through the cri was the corrections
research institute i think it was
rehabilitation
yeah
so i mean i mean that's one way you
could approach
follow-up
so i just want to make sure i understand
your answer that
if we
fix these tablet programs and evaluate
them correctly and if they have merit
that they should fall in with other
programs but you would be opposed to the
bill as currently written where it only
says there is a one-time use and i think
that means all of the programs so far
there are a lot of programs that are
currently offered under other that are
worth it i think if they take moral
recognition therapy and they do thinking
for a change or choose love they ought
to be eligible for the
60 days for each of those programs it's
only the tablet programs that i'm
concerned about
thank you
representative muse
thank you for taking my question um
my question i'm a little
i'm a little confused in some ways
because uh
tablets and online learning have become
extremely common
outside of prison settings
so virtually every college i know of
offers online colleges now
online courses
some colleges only offer uh online
courses is your
issue
with the fact that these courses are are
on a tablet and they're not in an actual
classroom
or is it more with the content
my
concern is that there isn't any
interaction with an instructor
a lot of these are for
some of them are for mental health i
mean where it would be good to have a
group discussion
uh it's not like learning accounting and
i believe that the online courses you
can talk to the instructor you might
have to
type in your question but there's
interaction between the instructor and
the the student
on the these uh
tablet programs that there isn't that
interaction
so if you have a question
you ask the guy in the next cell
follow-up follow-up
um
do you think that there is a um
a trade-off
uh you know for example you're the
department of corrections and you have a
couple of thousand prisoners
that you're
basically trying to rehabilitate but you
only have so many teachers you only have
so many people who can lead these
sessions
so
my guess is is that
the tablet programs came about as a way
to multiply
um
just
to make more course material available
to more people
without the need to hire more
instructors and and teachers so
do you have a problem with doing that in
general no i don't have a problem with
that at all so i'm still i'm still not
understanding
your objection to the program content
itself
not the content it's the interaction
between the instructor
and the student
okay because i i question the value of
just reading something and doing a
multiple choice test
i don't
it's not the way i learn
thank you representative schultz
thank you mr chair it's great to see you
here
um i'm a sub from concord representative
schultz so apologize i'm not usually on
the committee but
um two quick things one i've never come
out about this as a legislator or in
public in general but i have a learning
disability
um
and it is amazing what the technology
provides if you have a learning
disability all these advances with
online classes have been amazing
and i think i must also be slightly
dyslexic because you can now choose a
font specification
did you know that these
advancements existed because it's did
you had you heard that and then a quick
follow-up
i know that there's a lot that's
available online and that are tailored
to people's style of learning i don't
know whether these programs
sure
follow are so tailored yeah they're
great on the kindle for whatever it's
worth um and also uh
i had tried a class on edx
ed i think hyphen the letter x
where a number of these courses are
online have you looked at any of the
course materials or any of the course
content on your own
because i was shocked at how cool
it was we asked for access to some of
these programs and and it was not
available to us that's true i looked
online to one of the original programs
at the peace education program and i
looked online for that
and
it's you know been used all over the
world this is a wonderful thing and the
examples they give online about this
program are for in-person
delivery of the program
interesting
representative
thank you
would you thank you for taking this
question for the
history three
looks like economics and financial
literacy
do you have um
what grade level
do you think they would be i don't know
i i believe that most of the programs
are done at like this that was it fifth
or sixth grade level
um
thank you and and quick follow-up
are these all if people are using
tablets
are they do they have an option to use a
language other than english
i don't know
thank you
see no further questions thank you for
your testimony
is there anyone in the audience wishing
to testify who has not signed up to
testify in this bill they're saying no
not hereby close the public hearing
and i am now opening the public hearing
on hb1512
[Music]
yeah if you could was anyone else doing
is
oh
yes
the committee now recognizes
representative robert the burge
you know thank you committee members um
uh i'd like to introduce um house bill
1512-fn
a bill relative to uh to the parole of
certain prisoners
that being said may i
acting german interpreter roy may i
address the committee regarding my
comments on this bill that i'm in favor
of the floor is yours okay thank you
very very much for the record uh my name
is uh robert thibault representative
from colas district 3 the city of berlin
as you well are aware
the northern new hampshire correctional
facility is located in berlin
when it first opened up i was the mayor
of the city
and was served on the first public
advisory committee ever since then i've
been working with our veterans and the
reason i'm here today
is to address
the bill
in
in advocating for our veterans
those of you
who have served are very familiar with
post-traumatic
stress disorder i for one am very
familiar with it and the reason i bring
that up is that
i have had friends as a vietnam war vet
have returned to the states
have committed suicide
have caused problems with their family
members i've had children have asked
what's wrong with my father i've had
wives ask i can't recognize my husband
anymore
and there are situations where something
triggers
a returning veteran with ps pstd
that causes you know a criminal offense
that being said i'm advocating for the
veterans because
this bill i think if looking at what the
variable should be
i think ptsd should weigh very very
heavily
followed by if they're a model model
inmate
as well as letters of support from the
correctional officers and the warden of
the prison
it's
i think it's
and that's why i'm it you know i'm
support of the bill it's really
advocating for the veterans but for all
people the situation back then 25 30 40
years ago very little was known about
post-traumatic stress disorder i am not
faulting the courts at all given what
they had before them i think they did
things correctly
what has come to light is what has
followed up in the information we know
about ptsd
so this bill will look at an inmate's
request for reevaluation of his parole
and given those variables
weighted correctly and particularly with
ptsd
may come out with a different outcome
now there is a cost associated with this
but then i asked the committee
you know how do you weigh this i mean is
it something that you know
you know for somebody to be released
into freedom do we need way our
compassion
i'm not saying that it's injustice but i
think the committee should realize that
there are certain things given the
amount of time that has elapsed
we can we can look at uh the situation
very objectively we have all been uh
subjected to over the years
those of us with white hair
uh that um
you may have been in favor of something
20 30 years ago but when new information
comes to light
your opinion has changed so that's what
i'm advocating for regarding this bill
different facts and opinions may come to
light
in the in to benefit the intimate the
inmate who is asking for parole
thank you
i will intimidate any questions but my
responses will be only in french saying
that i'm from a french city
i have a question
representative testerman all foreign
two questions uh number one
are we we're talking about 1512 which is
uh just
is looking for an earlier another parole
uh look at it is that correct yes that
is correct okay i was trying to get ptsd
in this well no i'm i'm asking that when
we're looking at this that
the parole you know uh
i guess committee or people
take that into consideration as a
very
important factor in looking at whether
or not the inmate should be paroled or
not
okay
one last question there's one
where did you come from
okay
uh
the uh
it says says in here
that
it'd be good to have
a pro a parole hearing on anybody who
has over 25 years is that just sort of a
blanket we're going to review everybody
that has 25 years of
incarceration well
that's why i mentioned that there has to
be certain factors or criteria that the
inmate has to be
a modeled inmate
that they have letters of support by
correctional officers as well as from
the warden so not all inmates who have
been there for 25 30 years or more would
qualify under those variables
thank you
representative lynn
just just a question but am i innocent
the i mean i understand that might be
your intent but the bill as it's drafted
doesn't say that it just says anybody
that has 25 years no no i i realize that
and you know i
i believe that
a committee amendment may be in order if
the committee chooses to do so
thank you
just a point of order the representative
is introducing the bill he's not a prime
or a co-sponsor so be gentle with him
please
it's all right i've been here 22 years i
can take it trust me
that i can dish it back too
thank you
representative connolly you had a
question
it was more a question of the chair
um thank you you're recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
chairman
could we get a very basic two-sentence
explanation of what this bill would do
because my read on this
of what this bill would do has not yet
been
discussed by anyone
well first of all that's not a
parliamentary inquiry
but at the sa
i guess you're asking me to explain the
bill what i would want to do is let the
members of the public
speak and
the bill's been introduced the prime
sponsors not here representatives
obviously filing on
introduced on his behalf i would just
let the testimony uh come out and then
i'll offer an explanation after or
during the executive session
may i ask a follow-up
of your parliamentary inquiry of the
chair
yes
my understanding of this bill is it
would do away with the sentence of life
without parole is that not correct
that's my understanding in a short cliff
notes version of it
thank you it's just good for everyone to
to know what we're talking about before
we ask questions and so on so i thank
you for the intelligence
okay
recognize for a question of the witness
okay here's a dumb question maybe this
is for help hi
um
it reminds me of what i hear of and am i
right in this if this bill reminds me of
what i hear in other countries that
sometimes a famous prisoner will be
released
because they're really old or
sick i remember that especially of the
lockerbie bombing
the gentleman who was convicted of
the bombing
uh was released
because he had a serious cancer or
something like that i mean is that
really does that seem to be the intent
of this is
sort of compassionate
release
you know thank you i'm sorry thank you
for the question no i don't believe that
this bill addresses that issue
if there's a medical condition that's
very severe and it can correct me if i'm
wrong commissioner
they are
there is a procedure for for allowing
them to be released is there not
this happens when it gets late in the
day
when the witness is done with his
testimony answering questions if
a question is asked and it's no
no no it doesn't mean the person doesn't
they don't get the answer they don't
need it
and and
that member of the public is signing to
speak so
i'm sorry representative do you have a
follow-up or
that was what you said was helpful okay
i think you had an irrelevant tangent
sorry okay
you know well uh
for a segway with that i mean i i work
17 years in africa and i'm very familiar
with prisons overseas believe me the way
we treat our inmates here
is unbelievably well they're well fed
taken care of and whatnot i had friends
that i had to go take out of kitty kitty
prison in lagos and that was not a nice
scene if you're in prison there
you're dependent on your
someone to bring you food clothing
shelter everything because they do not
take care of you so i really admire our
prison system here in the way that we
treat our inmates
saying new hands raised i want to thank
you for your testimony the witness is
excused
the committee calls jeff stresslin
attorney general's office
it
it just before the
witness begins for members of the public
testifying we're going to limit
testimony to three minutes per witness
thank you good afternoon again my name
is jeff strozen i'm attorney general's
office
our office opposes this bill for several
reasons and i'll explain why
first the beginning of the bill contains
several claims that are offered to
justify the passage of the bill
i didn't look in detail at every single
one of these but i did look at one to
see how applicable it is to new
hampshire because when you look at the
preamble to the bill it looks like most
of these claims are really not
applicable to new hampshire
one of the claims was that we have that
many inmates are serving extended prison
sentences due to mass incarceration
i checked and confirmed that new
hampshire's prison population has
actually dropped each year since 2017.
in addition i found a news article from
that cited inmate statistics that showed
that new hampshire had one of the lowest
incarceration rates in the country and
it was actually going lower at that time
and i confirmed the department of
corrections has actually dropped every
year since then
the article also revealed that new
hampshire's incarceration rate was half
the national average
so based on the actual inmate numbers
from new hampshire we do not have a
problem with mass incarceration which
would justify what this bill proposes
which is releasing
violent offenders from prison early
the second issue with the bill is that
it cannot achieve its stated purpose
which is having the parole board review
the validity of convictions and
sentences
and that's because the you'll hear from
other witnesses but the parole board
does not have the authority or
capability to investigate those types of
claims it's not within their purview
instead inmates already have a variety
of avenues to contest their claims to
contest their innocence to contest their
sentences and that ranges from having
appointed counsel the ability to file
motions to dismiss motions for new trial
the appeals process sentence review and
state and federal habeas corpus
petitions so there exists a system
outside of the department of corrections
to address the issues that are raised in
this bill
another issue that the bill doesn't
account for is the fact that the
majority of defendants plead guilty to
their crimes and agree to incarceration
so this bill would undo all that for
violent offenders including murderers
and people who committed sexual assaults
even though they pled guilty
admitted their crimes and agreed to be
incarcerated the state prison
this bill would undo that and allow them
to essentially leave prison early so
again these are not people for whom
innocence or their sentences were an
issue they agreed to those
and again that would be obviously unfair
to those victims family members
the victims themselves and the
communities involved
the reality is that this bill targets a
certain class of inmates and those are
inmates serving senses of at least 25
years or more
those make up some of the worst of the
worst in this state as far as offenders
they include criminals who've murdered
and raped their victims including
children
some of those people who are serving
those sentences have killed multiple
people raped multiple people and are
serving consecutive sentences for each
victim so we have double and triple
murderers in this state double and
triple
rapists in this state they get a
sentence for each victim so they may
have three consecutive 25-year sentences
this bill would undo that and say after
they've only served one of those
sentences for 25 years they'll be
eligible for parole and could walk out
of prison
that's obviously not fair to any of
those victims involved each victim
counts
this bill would also allow
criminals who are serving sentences to
get out early no matter how many victims
they've victimized and no matter how
many crimes they've committed again we
have some people in prison who've
committed multiple serious offenses and
received multiple consecutive sentences
this bill would undo that and let them
simply walk out the door early again not
fair to those victims or their families
and finally as i think
was noted earlier by another
representative this bill would be in
conflict with existing sentencing laws
regarding murderers and people who
commit multiple sexual assaults for
example
this bill would undo the sentences for
all first-degree murderers so
instead people who've committed murders
during a sexual assault who committed
home invasions and committed murders
and people who committed multiple sexual
assaults
those people normally be subject to
life's life without parole sentences
this bill would undo that and instead to
be able to leave prison early
we also have a law in new hampshire that
says that people who murder children
children of the age of 13 have to serve
a mandatory minimum of 35 years in
prison before they're eligible for
parole this bill would undo that as well
and finally this bill would be in
conflict with existing law that requires
offenders who've committed multiple
aggravated felonious sexual assaults
against children
those offenders are required to serve
life prison sentences this bill would
undo that and let them leave prison
early at 25 years
so those are all the reasons that we
oppose this bill i'd just like to
comment on one thing regarding ptsd ptsd
is a potential defense that a defendant
could raise if they're charged with a
crime that is best dealt with at the
time they're charged with a crime in
court that's not something that the
parole board has the ability to explore
or investigate the time of parole that
is something that a defendant
could and would potentially raise at the
time of their trial and they have lots
of avenues to do that at the time of
their trial if they choose to do so
that's everything i have to say i'd be
happy to answer any questions that there
are though
representative true
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
you said something about
the bill as written
gives the parole board some authority
that they don't have to to look at a
guilty sentence that's correct
but where do you see that
from line 27
where do you see that that
the bill was instructing them to do that
i'm reading it it just says shall grant
a parole
hearing
the bill
the bill is intended to address people
who've been over charged overcharged
wrongly convicted
or over sentenced that's paragraph 10 of
the preamble
and so that what that says is that
that's what the parole hearing is going
to be about to correct that and the
parole board has no ability or authority
to address those types of claims
so those claims are all addressed prior
prior to an individual being convicted
so
that's paragraph 10 in the preamble
thank you you're welcome
representative you have a follow-up
question
um
question of the chair
you have a parliamentary inquiry yes
am i correct in assuming mr chair that
lines 27 through 30 or whatever it is
that's the bill
and the findings
have nothing to do
with what we vote on
it's kind of a parliamentary inquiry
it's
i i think i'm just gonna underst that's
a question we can discuss during the
executive session uh members of the
testimony
members of the public can testify
and speak freely and we're not really
going to debate what we debate them we
agree with their interpretation or not
we encourage everyone to testify and
we'll leave it at that
i would say that as i read the bill
those findings in the beginning are
essentially the the reasons why the bill
should pass that one through ten and so
that's why i made the comment i did
representative roy thank you um
there are avenues available through the
courts to address
wrongs such as excessive sentencing
and things of the nature that are
brought up
um
is that not true that people could
petition for for a rehearing on that
there are lots of different avenues i
mean originally a defendant would have a
sentencing hearing where they would be
represented by council and have the
ability just to contest the sentence up
front they can file motions for
reconsideration
and for superior court or felony
sentences a defendant has the right to
go to what's called the sentence review
board which is a three-judge panel and
essentially have a re-review of their
sentence as well
they have other ways to contest it along
along the road including habeas
petitions in the state and federal court
so there are lots of other avenues to
contest that
um my follow-up question is is kind of a
tied to representative trues in in your
luck way a few seconds ago
does the court look at the preamble
because does the court not try to find
out legislative intent when they
interpret a bill
courts will typically look at
legislative intent if there's an
ambiguity
and certainly if the parties disagree
about the meaning of a statute it's not
uncommon for the parties to cite
legislative history
especially because this the preamble
here
says that the general court finds and
then lists those paragraphs after so
those would be important considerations
if there was a dispute about what the
terms of that statute meant but
in fairness the statute is pretty clear
which says that no matter what somebody
does not no matter what crimes they
commit no matter how many victims
they're eligible to walk out the door at
25 years thank you
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for his testimony and
witnesses excuse me thank you for
listening i appreciate it
the committee now calls jennifer sargent
new hampshire adult parole board
good afternoon mr chairman honorable
members of the committee
i'm jennifer sargent i am the chairman
of the new hampshire adult parole board
i speak in opposition to this bill
on behalf of the new hampshire adult
parole board
um
what i believe this bill is doing what
the board believes this bill is doing is
violating the separation of powers and
also uh serving as an end run around
sentencing reform and that is because
what this bill asks the parole
board to do
is to move
the minimum mandatory parole date
which is established
by a court
it is the
authority of the court to determine in
an indeterminate sentencing state such
as new hampshire the minimum to be
served and the maximum to be served the
minimum to be served is the minimum
parole date
the judge
imposes that date
so that the parole board if asked to
hear somebody at 25 years
when their minimum parole date was
either non-existent in the cases of life
pro
life without parole or
was farther out than 25 years would
actually be altering a judge's sentence
that
is a matter for sentence reform
that is a matter for sentencing laws to
be redrawn
for penalties for particular offenses
this the new hampshire
adult parole board
does not have as an executive branch
as part of the executive branch
the power
to move
a minimum mandatory parole date
that is done
by not only a judge's date but then
something like burn time credit
where some
trigger
some award some
substantial
participation in that program allows
them to work off
portions of their sentence to change
their minimum mandatory date
this would also require
practically
as attorney general sterling
argued
pearl hearings
for extremely institutionalized
individuals
who will not have the opportunity to
engage in much programming
before
getting out because a lot of the
programming
is
geared towards somebody who is going to
parole very soon because you want the
programs to be finished
in a
timely manner so that they can continue
with that on the street
someone who's engaging in programming
a year or two or three or seven and a
half years in is in a very different
position than someone who has already
served 25 years who is then engaging in
programming
the amount of material that the parole
board would also have to pull together
read and review
would be
extensive it would be years
uh it would be all of the information
that went into
the case itself there would be many
victims who would
present themselves however we would not
as a board
have all of the input from the members
who engaged in the prosecution
like a judge
would do at a sentencing hearing i am
also a former district court judge now
the circuit court but at the time i
served as a district court judge it was
the district court i was in lancaster
littleton in haverhill those were my
courts and i circuited around the state
of new hampshire and i can tell you what
goes into a sentence be it a house of
correction sentence or
a felony sentence to prison
i can tell you that the work that a
judge must do to figure out
all of the factors
cr
general deterrence specific deterrence
victim
implications
how likely the person is
to
rehabilitate all of the things that a
judge considers the parole board would
not have it have in front of it
it would have to be
a significant retrial
basically
to determine whether or not the person
should get out at 25 years
and most of the applications under the
current criteria for parole which are in
the par administrative rules
would not be met
i would ask that the committee
find this bill inexpedient to legislate
and i will receive any questions that
you would
want to ask me
see no hands raised i want to thank the
witness for our testimony thank you is
this excused
we now call helen hanks
sorry
i was thinking the same same thing
good afternoon uh for the record helen
hanks commissioner of the department of
corrections um
just an affirmation yes the prison
population actually has been on a
decline since 2011. i'll send that to
the committee it's i think a very good
statistic for the state of new hampshire
we're 38
down on our population rate that's good
for corrections because our staffing
hasn't gone up yet and we're almost to
the actually design capacity from circa
1980 whatever for the men's prison
sorry so with that said lines 27 and so
on where it references the commissioner
she'll grant a parole hearing and the
commissioner shall schedule a hearing
the commissioner correction has no
authority over the adult parole board
it's fundamentally flawed so you could
compel me to compel them to have a
hearing but they could just simply tell
me no
so for those purposes i think it's not
well articulated bill at this point
because it confuses and creates
authority where authority doesn't exist
for the position of commissioner
and just a point of clarification people
who are incarcerated with these lengths
of sentences do have steady access to
treatment interventions education and
programming they don't have to wait for
those i just want to make sure the
committee knows that
i do appreciate the information shared
by the chair of the adult parole board
with that i'm going to keep this
testimony short and answer any questions
you may have for me
representative board name
pikachu thank you for taking my question
um
actually i have two but we'll see
where the first one goes
um
do you ever
see
uh
people that have sentenced to long
prison terms
uh make uh drastic changes in their
behavior so that they might be
when they come in a murderer and
a dastardly murderer that
by the time 25 years has passed
they've become
quite different and maybe even
reformed
uh commissioner bourdain i would say
that the answer to the question is we
see people who come in with sentences of
multiple links who make rehabilitation
and reform um and we see people who do
not so i see it in many other cases
recognize for a follow-up
thank you
um uh clearly uh you've shown us that
the uh the bill is poorly uh worded
uh
is it possible we could make it
more acceptable and
possible to implement
representative bordenay i would leave
that to the fine deter determination of
this committee again as the commissioner
corrections i will leave sentencing and
everything pre-incarceration to the
legislature and the judiciary
thank you you're welcome
so you know hands raised i want to thank
the witness for our testimony thank you
everyone
the committee now calls gene phi
thank you for allowing me to testify as
i am now a massachusetts resident
instead of new hampshire
and i would like to make a request if i
could could you please tell your
secretary that
to tell me i only have one minute to
speak is a little
ineffective
my name is testimony is limited to three
minutes i'm sorry your testimony is
limited to three minutes
not not one minute
but but we'll we'll let you know when
it's been the time
okay
um i'm a retired federal ptsd therapist
from the veterans administration
i have worked with combat veterans for
over 40 years from all american wars
since world war ii
i have known one particular one gary
place who is currently
an inmate at the berlin correctional
facility since 1984.
he is doing time for first degree life
without parole
gary is a marine veteran who served in
vietnam and was stationed in caisson
during the four-month siege of one of
the longest and most violent battles of
the entire war
and was given numerous awards
and an honorable discharge
and one of the things i always used to
say to my clients is just because you're
a veteran doesn't mean that your
experience is the same as someone else's
with gary's experience i compare it to a
cousin of mine
who was actually an attorney
at the embassy in saigon
who never saw any combat so he came home
without ptsd
that's not the case for gary
when his trial was covered by the media
back in 1983
ptsd was a contributing issue but most
people didn't know very much about ptsd
things have changed considerably since
that time
ptsd now is known to be linked to
numerous causes
not just combat
and it is much better understood
you asked a question earlier about
had she ever had any experience with
people
i had two
veterans down in massachusetts who were
world war ii veterans
who had the very same experience
and they were let out at the age of 70
because they both had serious health
issues
and until the time that they died they
were exemplary citizens
um
gary immediately which doesn't happen
very often
took responsibility for his actions and
turned himself into the police even
before it was realized that a crime had
been committed
since 1983 he has worked on his issues
relentlessly
and when the bill was
up for passing a year ago he was highly
recommended for conditional pardon
even by his former prosecuting attorney
he has incredible support from his
family members
friends
former employers
the victim's family
he has completed any and all available
treatment programs within the prison
as well as some of those that he could
do via mail
he is currently an inspiration in
particular
to other incarcerated veterans and there
are more than you realize
and he works now as the facilitator for
various therapy groups
in the prison
i know i understand this bill was meant
for any and all individuals who have
served at least 25 years with a few
exceptions and i think that was the last
sentence in the bill
it is important however
that each inmate seeking a conditional
pardon
be independently scrutinized
and judge based on their own individual
accomplishments and behavior
that's my one minute
representative boyd are you recognized
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question can you repeat your name oh my
name is joan phi fye
thank you
that's it representative newman
representative sue newman
yes
thank you
there was an executive council hearing
that mr place had
uh yes there was um no i don't think it
actually went to hearing i think it was
a proposal and it got turned down
will there be another opportunity for
the executive council to that i don't
know i'm sorry i'm not a lawyer i don't
know thank you
see no hands raised i want to thank the
witness for a testimony the witness is
excused
the committee calls russell roy
thank you mr
excuse me thank you mr chairman
committee members i'm a little hoarse
here
my name is russell roy i i live in
manchester
and uh i'm here representing myself i'm
not a member of any group or
organization
one thing that i learned sitting back
here for the past few hours is that
you folks really earn your hundred
dollars i'll tell you
uh so thank you for your service i
appreciate the all the work that you do
i'm here today to register my support
for house bill 1512.
um and i say that uh notwithstanding um
the points raised earlier about the the
problems uh with it with the the wording
in this bill
i i have to say uh with all due respect
to the authors of the bill
that i winced a little bit when i saw
the references to people who have been
falsely accused
of crimes
and and
are serving sentences
this bill uh even though that was used
to bolster the arguments for for support
of this bill by the authors
um it's misplaced and uh so i agree with
with uh with the previous folks that
that that spoke against that
but i i don't think that that um
uh washes away the the the uh the the
forget the argument that that particular
argument it doesn't wash away the the
the intent of this bill which is to
offer some redress to folks who have uh
served uh are serving extreme sentences
one thing which is clear to me
is that length lengthy sentencing that
we've engaged in since the 70s
has not made us safer if that were true
the us today would be the safest society
we incarcerate more people in this
country
since any time in recorded history
but yet there is still
we still face violence in our society
more than 3 000 young people are
murdered by their 25th birthday
50 7 000 children survive
sexual violence half a million women are
victims this there's plenty of violence
in our society but long sentences are
not making us safer
i'm here today as you sit in
consideration this bill to ask your
indulgence
in
taking a more nuanced approach
than we have previously brought to bear
this bill seeks to provide some means of
redress to those serving stream
sentences
yes people who have committed the most
serious sorts of violence those serving
life without parole
this bill is about how we talk about
and how we treat people
who cause great harm
and begin to unwind
an unsustainable and unwise policy of
extreme sentencing
we heard today uh before some of the
previous testimony talked about the fact
that that commissioner hanks is doing an
excellent job that we've been cited the
state of new hampshire has been cited by
u.s news and world report as as a one of
the
preeminent uh corrections uh
uh facilities or uh systems in the
country and that is all to be applauded
um and it's and it's good to know know
that our our incarceration uh rates are
are going down
um but that's not reason enough i think
to abandon uh this bill or the or the
people that that it would seek to serve
i i'll provide you with some copies of
testimony but i want to bring your
attention to uh an open letter that from
uh dated april of 2021
and signed by 64
attorney generals from across the
country this is not just people from
new york and massachusetts but states
like texas and florida and everywhere in
between
and in this in this open letter they
took they addressed the the uh
the notion of of past
past extreme sentencing so so uh
uh miss sergeant alluded to the the
notion about about well what uh what can
we do to correct uh you know the the law
we can't we can't rewrite the the uh the
sentencing here uh this is this is not
uh about sentencing reform this is
asking for redress for people who are
already sentenced
uh to to the uh to uh life without
parole
just to quote briefly from from this
open letter which i'll provide you a
copy with so you can see it in context
but they say although the role of
incarceration is primarily to protect
public safety our criminal justice
system has few mechanisms to sure to
ensure that only those who still pose a
serious safety risk remain behind bars
and it goes on
you know
uh the tough on crime appellation
is not is the sole propriety of no one
all of us
with leanings on both sides of the
reform issue
need to feel safe in our homes
and our neighborhoods
no one wants to feel threatened
but
i i know of no one that that says that
that we shouldn't be prosecuting uh
these
people
when they when
crimes particularly violent crimes are
are
are committed
we all need to feel safe and and that
prosecution has to happen
my intent is not to engage in excuse
making on behalf of the incarcerated
ultimately each of us is responsible for
our own actions regardless of the
circumstances it is however important to
recognize that violence occurs within a
context and that understanding that
context is a piece of the puzzle and
ending it
some people
i do have to limit tests i did limit
testimony in three minutes i i want to
say that you're close to doubling that
time
i'm sorry i need to ask you to wrap up
the testimony
okay um
well
it's tough here okay
well uh you know let me just just
conclude by saying you know
a lot of uh times when the legislations
of this sort come up uh our thoughts go
to the victims
and uh and i want to speak in support of
victims as well
um the truth is that that most survivors
uh don't
don't live in the space between totally
angry and totally forgiving they live
someplace in the middle
and that that allows for people
that that are being that could be
offered this opportunity for parole not
to have mercy but to be accountable
um to be accountable to the the uh
in in in accepting responsibility for
the the harm they've caused
and acknowledging that to the victims
engaging in actions to correct that and
making personal transformation to to
demonstrate their commitment to that
thank you for your testimony i do have
to ask you to conclude i appreciate that
i'm sorry
i'll take any questions you might have
seen
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the member for his testimony
the witness is excused
any members of the public who wish to
testify
they have not testified already
seeing no one this time will now close
the public hearing on house bill 1512.
this the members of the committee we we
will be executing some bills uh hb 1540
will be the first one up it is an early
deadline bill that early deadline is
tomorrow so and we have nothing
scheduled
between now and tomorrow
just a hand there will be more more than
that one
always
is
thank you
this
this time we're now going to open the
executive session on house bill 1540.
so
all right with the when the executive
session is now open representative welch
i was just grave
gracefully handed in amendment it's
2022-0616h
i'm not recognizing anyone to make a
motion so please don't yell
yell anything i'm just asking is this
amendment
is this does this rewrite the whole bill
is it inserted into
the original bill
no this is uh
in a sense it does rewrite it
but
initially the reason this amendment was
drafted today
was to satisfy a com a conversation
between representative lynn and barcher
and
the agreeable
and it was to uh
it's on line three
custodial interrogation means express
questioning is
associated with a formal arrest
or restraint on freedom that is the
functional equivalent of an arrest
or other actions or words by a law
enforcement officer
which are reasonably likely to elicit an
incriminating response from an
individual
and occurs when reasonable individuals
in the same circumstances
would consider themselves in custody
my understanding was that after um
the discussion between representative
lynn
and bob's share that there was they were
agreeable that that satisfied
that makes that makes two of us
mr chairman
representative antologues is this not
already being done in our police
stations within the state
well i don't want to speak for every
single police station but my
understanding that the overwhelming
majority of police officers
they will at least audio record an
interview if not actually record it with
it through a video
it's being done what this would do is
basically set up
you'll make it a mandate
an unfunded mandate for what it may look
like but a mandate no less
at the very least would downshift the
cost to the counties and
towns but any event
it if it's not followed if for some
reason whatever they didn't follow
didn't record it any it wouldn't be
admissible and neither would any of the
fruits of the poisonous tree
so that's what this would do
some states have to take a different
approach some states have
they when they give the jury instruction
they would just simply point out the
jury by the way
when this in this in confession was made
this interrogation was done it was not
recorded when it's the policy of the
police department is to record it
my question is what is going to be done
if the departments do not do this
my understanding is that if they don't
follow the
procedure correctly as it relates to in
custodial interrogations that
any information evidence confession that
was
gained through that
custodial interrogation would not be
admissible
thank you
representative sue newman yes
just
this is your discussion time correct on
this one um yes
there's no there's no motion
there's no motion recognized i just we
just handed an amendment but we have to
accept this bill today
and
i was i was pretty taken with the
testimony of cynthia
muso
new hampshire innocence project
and her comment that
a third of confessions are have been
determined to be false confessions i
said to her during the uh the break
between the the next uh the next hearing
that there was just something this past
week on
public radio that i heard and it was a
young person i don't remember if it was
a young man or a woman but they were i
don't know 17 years old
and after hours of
interrogation they had an audio of it
they finally got him to say he killed
somebody when he actually didn't any and
the person spent
years deca
over 10 years in prison um
so
i was i thought that was
just interesting with the whole thing
that if it's recorded you've got
something
so i and i appreciate the listen if
you're a police officer it makes your
job a lot easier to record these entire
interrogations because then it's all
documented
false confession aside whether it is or
not
this is a policy whether they should be
recorded or not making that mandatory
i think whether they record not you
still can have the issues of false
confessions
so
this is my my opinion
does anyone else wish to offer any
comment
representative true
yes thank you mr chair
i am still looking at
a 28a issue
which is not
a small issue
in my book
it is a constitutional
issue that we cannot
downshift
i've heard
explanations on why downshifting really
isn't downshifting
i've never understood those
but i see this as a 28a
um i
i don't see how
i can vote for
something that is a 28 a issue thank you
representative roy
thank you um
i would tend to agree with my colleague
if if it specified the manner or
machinery or storage
that had to be used
um
as has been pointed out
every police department in the state has
got some type of recording device from a
phone to a pocket recorder
they're used in wiring
they're commonly used in police work
it's not something that they would not
have access to or would not be able to
obtain very very reasonably
um storage is a thumb drive
um
if we could make it better so that there
would be a statewide database where they
could share with the state police i
think that would be great but that's not
before us
but um i i just think
it keeps everybody honest i like the
bill it makes
it makes the police do better police
work it protects the individual um and
it's good for the system
so
as i said since i don't see a
a mandate with regard to what type of
equipment or how expensive they have to
invest
theoretically they could
spend 20 on one tape recorder and
and whatever it costs for the tapes and
it's so minimal as to
not
be impactful
representative do you wish to be
recognized to make a motion
on the underlying bill
and stop calling me mike
um
i i move uh house bill 1540 uh
as itl
is there a second mr chairman i second
it's been second by representative
marston
representative lynch i i i
tend to
agree with my colleague that i think
this is i think this basically is a good
bill i don't really see the
the uh
the 28a issue uh
i mean i think it's it's de minimis
because i suspect that ever as you say
every every police department has some
kind of
ability to make a recording the only uh
and i do as i said before i think the
custodial interrogation thing that that
the change
would satisf in the amendment would
satisfy me i i and i don't you know hope
hopefully
all of you but would
satisfy me the only other point that i
would make is
there the section of the bill that
talked about
it could be um
you you know the the the person being
the person who's being interrogated
could waive the requirement
of uh recording but that waiver either
either had to be
in writing or on the recording itself
i i do think that's a problem because i
think there are some
i i've seen actually some circumstances
and i think i think it's not uncommon
for somebody who doesn't want
uh their recording to be doesn't want
their interrogation to be recorded
to say i'm not signing anything and i
don't want you even to record that i've
said i don't want it to be recorded they
just don't want to record it so i wonder
if we could
just end the sentence in which that
appears in the bill
to just you know
stop it stop put a period before you get
to provide it
that would be my suggestion other than
that i i think i think it's a good bill
good luck getting an amendment to the
bill this
that's the that's the problem we have up
against the deadline but
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and
to
representative
lynn
what i would argue with
is i
i think everybody should just shut their
mouth when they get arrested but they
don't
so with that said if they're stroking
about not wanting to be recorded
hopefully they have the mindset to say
you know what i think i want my lawyer
and i'm not going to speak so i think
that issue if we leave it in there is
going to be taken care of by the people
that will use that exercise you know the
constitutional
rights that they have to stay silent
which they should um i'm looking at the
28a issue and and
representative roy you know almost said
everything i was going to say so i won't
repeat it so he is 100
accurate
every police station has something to
record
absolutely they do
so there is not a 28a issues that's why
i put my name on this um that's why i
support the bill so i am the third vote
here and i'm going to be saying no
to the itl
thank you mr chairman
representative wallace
thank you mr chairman uh i concur
this is a
although i understand your position
representative uh true
but
i don't know about sandown's police
station but i know in our little town of
danville our holding cell has got audio
and video recording equipment as does
every pc manufacturer that's in our
office we can record with that
the rockingham county jail the holding
cells have video and audio recording
already in place and that stuff is
monitored by the guards it would just be
a matter of sending that information to
a file someplace in an already existing
uh infrastructure and file storage
system so i don't see the downshifting
of the costs and i'm very conscientious
of that having trimmed 10 percent a year
every year i've been
the chairman of the rockingham county
jail out of the budget which i'll do
again
friday
so that's my two cents worth
what one issue that comes up with this
once it's recorded you the police
officer
i'm not saying they can't they should
not be just leaving it on their cell
phone for their own cloud service
that it needs to go on to a some type of
protected database somewhere
similar how you know with the body image
cameras so i agree the fact that every
police officer presumably has a
smartphone
we shouldn't rely on that officer to
store on their personal cloud
i'm just saying that it needs to be
uniform what i would say nor would that
be appropriate
no it would not have statutes that
prohibit the distribution of a
post-arrest photo
do we not know that
there would be a chain of custody issues
supposedly they if a police officer
recording their phone and whoever
handled their phone
perceivably has now handled the video i
mean my son picks up my phone i have to
add his name to the list
i'm just saying these are these are
problems with that it should be stored
on a device and i guess that my thought
with the unfunded mandate is the storage
device is the
issue not necessarily the recording
device the recording device is a minimal
expense
represent
representative pantologist
the more i read this bill and the more i
think about it
i'm beginning to believe it's a good
protection for the police
and the towns and cities
so i couldn't really
say that it was a 28 age issue because
if my department doesn't have
things to record and we're in big
trouble
so
representative ordnae
thank you mr chair
i'm going to oppose the itu motion
i think that
the
person under consideration for arrest
is already being recorded when they ask
not to be recorded so that will be part
of
taking care of
i don't want to be recorded
so
i would suggest that we
defeat the itl motion and
pass this bill
with the amendment from
roy
professor
who wrote to the amendment
well
if if we get to that point i'll let you
do the honors of second in it
representative marson
thank you mr chairman i'd like to make a
note that the reason i seconded the
motion to itl is that now we can have
this discussion that we've been doing if
there's no second it dies
with that being said in my part of this
discussion i have a big feeling that i
believe
representative true is a hundred percent
correct we are trying to pass laws and
we ain't funding it and that's an
unfunded mende mandate and that's going
to cause a problem down the road that's
going to flare up i believe that
sincerely i may not be here when that
happens but if you pass this that's
what's going to happen unless you fund
the towns the ability to record don't
leave it up to them to maybe do it
and maybe they store it and maybe they
don't and so on and so forth and with
all of what i'm saying
and i'm not a lawyer
man is a good lawyer going to take this
apart and rip it up like nobody's
business and so with that being said i
will still itl i will vote to itl thank
you mr chairman
representative pratt
i would have not thought that this was a
uh
unfunded mandate but uh in reviewing
this letter from the new hampshire
county attorneys there's 10 accounting
attorneys on here that are not in favor
of this
so i'm going to lean that way i guess
sorry
representative schultz
thank you
um i'm curious to know what the blue
sheet reflects in terms of support and
opposition and i texted to mr vice chair
the online numbers it was two four and
two against but it also lists their
names
i'm just curious to know if you have the
if you have the blue sheet
and could tell us the tally
representative wallace you happen to
have the blue sheet
this was the second day we had a hearing
so the
maybe two blue sheets
there no blue sheet to reference
okay
do any members wish to speak they
haven't smoked already
i i'm just gonna point out we had a
bill involving body cameras and the
consensus was that was an unfunded
mandate so
so i guess how is this not
is it because it's a minimal cost
less expensive
how how is there no cost because my
concern is the unfunded mandate but
apparently
i'm in a small group here so talk me out
of it
i got fingerprinted at the goffstown
police not by criminal you know criminal
criminal act representative
representative you are live streaming
yes
no no i wanted a
concealed carry license out of florida
so that's why they fingerprinted me
because i had to do it uh but you know
they told me when i walked into the
fingerprint room
uh you're being audio in video and i
wasn't even being charged for anything
and it the tapes are rolling
yes
and uh so you know if
you know goffstown's not small but you
know i know where which is small there's
so many other small police departments
they all record because they the biggest
thing they want
is they want to protect themselves
and they want to make sure that whatever
the person that shouldn't be talking
talks they want to make sure they get
him exact because what he's going to do
is he's going to tell his lawyer once he
gets one go i didn't say that and then
it's his word against their word well if
it's a recording they can't do that and
and i know every police station in the
state has one
so
we have the blue sheet
it's rather interesting two in support
four against
would you please add who was for and who
was against please
it is public record no secrets here
that needs a job for the clerk
so buzzshare supports the bill
okay representative john t mcdonald
carol district six opposes
uh
joseph ebert new hampshire state police
as against it
elizabeth sergeant new hampshire
association of chiefs of police is
against it
laurie roberts new hampshire innocence
the innocence project supports it
and uh joseph hoboke hollis pd
is opposed
and mr chair the text i sent to the vice
chair also has the names of those four
individuals
well with that being said i think we'll
represent them true
thank you mr
chair i do understand people are saying
don't worry about the 28a issue because
everyone already has all this stuff in
their police stations
letter from the new hampshire
county attorneys
says they are opposed and why are they
opposed because many of our law
enforcement departments do not have the
equipment which is necessary to record
store and transmit interrogations as
mandated
our officers do not have the electronic
storage capacity or the personnel to
receive redact if necessary under the
law and transmit
so there's a difference of opinion
a whole bunch of county attorneys say
all our departments don't have the
facilities or the equipment to do this
and there are people in this room saying
yes they do
for this bill
for this itl
i'm going to go with what
the county attorneys of new hampshire
say
that
there's already constitutional mandates
in place
which address the underlying bill
but their main point being
no
many
law enforcement departments do not have
the equipment or the capacity to store
thank you
at this time the matter will now be put
to question if you're in support of the
motion of nxp and to legislate please
say yay if you're opposed
please nay clerk and i'll call the roll
vice chairman roy no
representative welch
no
representative burt
representative lynn
representative greene
clerk votes no
representative testament
yes
representative true
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative schultz
that was too quick on itl no
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay
no
representative muse
representative ray newman
no
representative bolden
representative conley no
representative bradley
no
representative sue newman
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
with a vote of 16 nays
six yays
itl fails
representative welch would be recognized
to make a motion
representative borden you wish to second
that the motion has been
and two not voting did i say twelve
so that motion has been seconded by
representative bourdain
rips you wish to
wish to speak to the motion
i think we've discussed it pretty well
the
amendment
was
i think fairly clear
the only thing that really changed was
the definition of law enforcement
officer
and
what what an arrest is
our custodial interrogation
i think that's sufficient
and i think
representative marston you recognize for
parliamentary inquiry
oh sorry
so representative welch the question was
of whether which amendment we are
dealing with my understanding is you're
offering
amendment 2022-0616h
correct
all right so this time the
matter will now be put to question
the question is whether to adopt the
amendment
if you're in support of adopting
2022-06168 please say if you're opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes
representative burt yes representative
lynn yes
representative greene
yes
clerk votes yes representative testament
representative true
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
no
representative schultz
yes
representative panolakis
representative o'hearn representative
bordenay
yes
representative muse
yes representative ray newman
yes
representative bolden
representative conley yes
representative bradley yes
representative sue newman yes
chairman abbas chair votes yes
16 3.
the amendment is adopted amendment
2022-06168
has been adopted representative welch we
used to make a motion about the passes
amended
i make that motion and the
representative board now you wish to
second that
anyone wish to speak to the
question
oh wait can i
i still think that issue about what uh
you know the when when when somebody
doesn't want to uh agree i still think
that needs to be changed but but that's
not a reason not to i intend to vote yes
that can be either changed by a floor
amendment or changed in the senate
i don't think it it's a reason not to
proceed so i intend to vote yes
if anyone wishes to me
although i don't mean to rush this the
fact of the matter is we
we're not here tomorrow to execute so we
it's today or never so a four amendment
to address that representative and i
would have no
problem putting the best whatever we
send to the other side assuming it
passes the house we should send them the
best
if it's possible maybe representative
welch and
representative you guys can continue
that healthy conversation if i could
just for a second
um you don't feel that the fact that
this would mandate recording of an
interrogation so that would recording
would be press start hello my name is
officer so-and-so
we're here today to interview you you're
being already recorded i don't want to
be recorded who stops he's captured
would that
you know i think i mean i i think often
it would happen that way but i could see
sometimes where the police officer might
say to the purge you know to the person
as they are sort of taking him into the
interrogation room listen we're going to
have to you know we're going to we're
going to have a conversation we're going
to have to record this and he says no
you know before they even get in there
so that's the kind of situation where i
think it could come up but you know as i
say it's not
it's it's not a big deal i don't think
we can i think it could be worked around
representative marston
i just even have a problem with this in
the sense that
if
and i can give a couple of exa at least
one example but my problem is if
somebody was trying to arrest me or
gonna take me to this police station the
the only words out of my mouth would be
i want my lawyer
and then i would stop talking
period and i can give you an example of
how i feel and yet i think the police do
an exact job i wouldn't want their job i
commend them
but i had police come to my door and i
live in an apartment complex buzzed them
up they got to my door they said can we
come in
do you know what my first words to them
were
no you may not
and then we talked a little bit and then
they did come in based on what they said
to me but i at that point still knew
that if they saw something and i don't
have anything i don't do marijuana i
don't have wheat i don't have any
but that when you allow the police into
your house
and they see something that they know is
not kosher
bam you are in trouble it's in the
evidence it's you're out in the open
they're not searching your drawers
they're just and that's why i say
you got to use your head when it comes
to the police
i want my lawyer
so again i can't abide by this i i know
where you're trying to go i love david
welsh representative welch and not in
that
off color way but i respect him i
respect what he's trying to do and yet i
also respect representative true and i
think this is an unfunded mandate that's
going to come back and bite you in the
butt
thank you i appreciate the time mr
chairman
thank you
mr chairman if i just really quick i
just want to make sure that we we all as
a committee um understand and appreciate
the fact that law enforcement does what
we pay them with our tax dollars to do
and that is to catch criminals and
you know sometimes um it doesn't work
out right but
um besmirching all the law enforcement
is you know we've got to watch out there
out to get us is also not the way to go
um they're doing what we pay them to do
and at that great personal risk to
themselves oftentimes so
you're missing one point
we make the laws that they have to
enforce that's correct in this
legislature
what what well said representative
pandalagas well said representative roy
this time the matter will now be put the
question if you're in support of the
motion of ought to pass as amended
please say yes if you're opposed please
say nate the clerk will now call the
roll vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes representative burt yes
representative lin yes representative
green
nay clerk votes yes
representative testament
representative true
representative pratt no
representative marston
no
representative schultz
yes
representative panalakis
representative o'hearn representative
bordenay yes
representative muse yes
representative ray newman
yes
representative bolden
representative conley yes
representative bradley yes
representative sue newman yes
chairman abbas
chair votes no
with a vote of 13 to five and two not
voting
it passes
13 years
six days the emotion of ought to pass
as amended passes
representative wells will you prepare
the majority report
and just a reminder that report needs to
be done
asap tonight because it's the deadlines
tomorrow
will it be a minority report
yes
same instructions
if it's not in by noontime tomorrow it
won't be accepted
so
it's tomorrow's the deadline to get it
out move it out
i know i know the deadline i know the
deadline
all right and this time we'll now close
the executive session
on house bill 1540.
mr chair i just wanted to thank you and
the committee you've hosted me again as
a substitute
we're not done we get some more and
thank you for you're regretting that
for once and i'm glad you're thankful
because you got one more to go
at this at this time thank you for
welcoming me to the next bill
at this time he'll now open the
executive session on house bill 1178
representative burt
you wish to be recognized to make a
motion
yes i would like to make a motion of
ought to pass
as amended
with amendment
2022-0479
h which is very well written
is that has been
second and that has been seconded by
representative wallace
representative do you wish to speak to
you your your motion
yes uh this amendment that came forward
is
is well written
it goes right to the point
um
you know i believe even the ag is uh in
support of it
or they're not going to oppose it
because i don't think they support much
they want to stay as much as neutral as
they can i guess
it's just it's just a good amendment
and so the overall bill with the
amendment will be a perfect bill to send
to the other body which they should be
happy with
and thank you
representative lin yeah i just want to
second what uh representative uh burt
said this um this really was a a
a collaborative effort of i think a
number of interest uh groups
um and as representative burt said the
the uh we did run this by attorney
general formella he indicated he had no
problem with it i think you're probably
right that he may not come over and say
you know he affirmatively supports it
but that that's just because they don't
generally want to take a position on
policy things that they think for the
legislature but um
it's a very i think it's a good proposal
i note that um
uh
one of the person one people i suspect
that the that this committee has heard
from previously was
alan rice from the gun owners of america
he made this suggest the last section
the last proviso in section two of the
bill
which and i'm just quoting here it says
provided that the provisions of this
chapter shall not provide for the
distribution of information required to
be destroyed pursuant to 18 usc
section 922
t2c
um he that was at his suggestion from
the uh their
that organization's council and frankly
that was something that none of us had
thought about and it was it's a very
good point
uh because there is there is this uh
federal statute you know when you have
the instant the uh instant background
checks
that there's a provision in the federal
statute that says the records of that
have to be destroyed except for that
by the federal government they have to
be destroyed except for that
uh unique number and so this would
prevent
any any distribution of that kind of
information so i i think it i agree with
representative burt i think it's a i
think it's a very good proposal
representative true
thank you mr chair and i'm going to
speak slowly because if we're here after
5 30 the chair buys everyone dinner
is somebody going to
i hear that the amendment is a very good
amendment
is somebody
more familiar with the amendment
amendment than i am
going to explain the changes
the amendment makes to the original bill
representative true so
in the original bill
i'm just i'm looking at the amendment if
you look at lines 9
to 18. that is in the original bill that
is unchanged
and then if you look at
page two
lines four to seven
that's the severability clause that is
also in the original bill my
understanding those provisions word for
word have not changed
and last year
we the house
had a similar bill
and we passed an amendment in this
committee that was identical to
the severability section and
the first section which starts on line
nine that's
what is being added in the amendment is
lines
to 29 on page one
and then on page two lines one
through three
so that's what the changes and my
understanding of it's a clarification
that this is
simply a policy issue relating to the
regulation enforcement of
uh firearms uh if someone is involved in
trafficking
narcotics
at
the
state or county or municipal
police office could assist
in enforcing the federal drug laws if
they so choose so
but
not strictly just to enforce firearms
that's that what this would do there
have to be something in addition to that
but you cannot use it as a shield per se
from
this is this is the exact language we
passed
last
last year um
that's what that's what that second
paragraph does
it's really just re emphasizing that
representative pratt
is there anywhere in here that is a
penalty
for non-compliance
there is no express penalty however the
um there was a bill we recently passed
this committee now we haven't passed in
the house yet but it did pass on consent
it had to do with the
account police accountability and police
standards where we expanded the members
of
the of the committee on that
in that bill there is a provision that
basically if a law enforcement officer
willfully disregards their duty
this is this is basically restricting
what police officers can do okay
if they would they would be subject to
that disciplinary board it's my
understanding but there's no
some states have passed provisioning
this they have
different types of enforcement penalties
enforced by the attorney general
this does not have that okay it looks
good thank you
representative connolly
thank you mr chairman
not entirely sure how i'm going to vote
on this right now
it's not because i've changed my mind on
firearms
but i do think one should be consistent
in one's views if i don't want the
federal government enforcing cannabis
laws in our state if i don't want the
federal government enforcing immigration
laws in our state
would i then not be consistent and
support this
i i'm wondering if somebody could
address whether or not the grants are at
risk we heard about that earlier
during testimony
but
but that's
that's just where i am at it uh with
this
i
i will say
uh hp 1598 which is the bill we passed
17 to 4 in the committee had
some language not identical but similar
where would prevent police
local law enforcement officers from
participating and enforcing
cannabis laws with the federal
government so we have passed this policy
before in other subjects
in regards to the grants i asked i asked
that question during the public hearing
if there was any
examples where they could say any state
was denied a grant or denied funding
because of this policy
and
there was no examples provided
so again a quick follow-up so i think it
was alan rice with whom i don't
generally agree on much of anything said
federal
officials enforce federal laws
state officials enforce state laws
and
it's hard to to find a flaw with that
argument although i would hope that
other members take a similarly holistic
approach when we have other bills before
this body that have a similar question
of federalism and so forth
representative pantalaquis yes can
somebody give me a reason for this bill
i mean it says a presidential executive
order has there been one put out there
there actually wasn't
never come down to new hampshire well
i can i can answer your question in
respect whether there isn't is not an
executive order those can be those can
happen at any time
and
i i would just be straight pretty
straightforward i'm pretty sure the
current president has said if
legislation isn't done that he
it would be done through executive order
that has not happened
but during the campaigning process
that was said several times over
but what about any fun any money that's
coming in
that we might
be deterred by this
i i heard that concern i asked
specifically what grants are there any
grants that they were specifically
worried about that the state of new
hampshire wouldn't get or there any
situation where other states were denied
grants or
lost funding as a result of any policy
similar to this
and not a single example could have been
provided
we're not the first state to
uh
to entertain a policy like this so
in since last year
i think two additional i think texas and
missouri also have now passed a
not the exact same bill but a similar
policy
hey thank you
representative bradley
yes i just have a question so if this so
if there's an executive order by the
president and he decided to say
you know we need background checks for
all gun sales
we here would not have to abide by that
is that correct
well
it's not that we wouldn't be abiding by
it
my understanding is the local police
officers whether state
county municipal they would not be
enforcing those laws that's a federal
order it would be for the federal
government to enforce that a firearms
dealer is licensed by the feds and
therefore if they do not follow
the executive order
i can imagine
that they would have some licensing
issues and
unlike the cannabis laws the atf tends
to actually enforce the federal law so
they would
there would be some issues there
and they are already doing that based on
a couple of eos on firearm accessories
presently
you do appreciate the answer
representative newman ray newman
yeah i just have a question i mean
right now the police local police
cooperate with federal enforcement of
firearm laws is that correct or not
are there instances of that where they
work together to enforce federal
and if this passes would they be able to
do to do that based upon this amendment
i i'm not i'm not prepared to tell you
specific examples but
if this were to become law
the police in new hampshire would not be
able to simply to help and assist
federal officers in forcing
any federal firearm regulation
if it's inconsistent with new
hampshire's law
so if our law is the same as the federal
law we could still participate there
would have to be some other criminal
offense
unrelated to the firearms in order for
the local law enforcement officers to be
assisted in that investigation
so we we have we do not have a state law
about firearms in schools is that
correct
that we have a state law that that does
that the only state state law that i'm
aware of
there is there is no specific law that
talks about members of the public there
is a law prohibiting students
in schools
so so with adults
there is no state law that prohibits
an individual from carrying a firearm
into a school
right
right that's the under the current state
law that's correct
we had and we had that we had that bill
last time we had this the bill on that
issue
so if there were a mass shooting or
something that happened in a school or
an individual need whatever
the
if this amendment passes then the then
the local officials and municipalities
would not be able to assist them is that
correct no because there's several
capital level crimes that were committed
murder shooting someone in a school for
no reason is illegal and that's that's a
felony it's felony it's a murder in the
first degree
so if that were to happen because there
is a
underlying offense that is against state
law the murder first degree murder is
illegal in new hampshire
then
if the federal government asked us to
help assist with that we would be
certainly
within our rights to do that the mere
fact that someone's using a firearm
illegally does not stop local
uh police officers from enforcing other
laws it's the mere fact of the gun
regulation itself
so for example if the federal government
made it past a law
restricting the capacity
amount of rounds that a firearm can hold
let's say they made it a 15 round max
maximum the state of new hampshire would
not assist in enforcing that
thank you
oh representative bourne
thank you chair is there a motion on the
floor
okay well is there a motion to off the
pass as amended since two it's the
motions actually to adopt the amendment
okay
i
i would say i will support the amendment
but i am going to oppose the bill
uh the amendment does improve uh the
bill and i will support that amendment
thank you
represent representative roy
i'm gonna address my comments to my
colleagues who would be inclined to um
for a gut reaction to to vote against us
and i'm not going to try to change your
mind i just want you to think about
something if we went back in mr
peabody's way back machine
a couple years ago
and there were a different executive in
the white house
and he started issuing executive orders
saying you know i prohibit this i
prohibit that
i feel like
people would think differently so
there's an important reason we have
federalism because we like to do what we
like to do locally and we don't want
someone in washington telling us what to
do and what not to do
on a federal level so i just i throw
that out as food for thought and i align
myself with representative conley's
thing you know we have to be consistent
if if we don't um want them meddling in
something then we don't want them
meddling in anything
thank you
could i reply to that i don't
i don't think the people that you
address that comment to
uh
pass laws based upon a gut feeling thank
you i didn't address it to anyone
specifically
represented pantologists yes i just feel
this amendment
is not necessary and that our
constituents out there that aren't gun
crazy okay
don't care about these things they want
us to pass things that will protect them
and take care of their
thoughts and business and this every
time we turn around and pass one of
these gun things it comes out like we're
all
in a world of our own out there
that's just the way i feel my
constituents call me and ask me if you
have anything else to do in criminal
justice besides past gun laws and i say
yeah we get a few other bills
representative muse
one concern that i have is that
new hampshire law doesn't mirror federal
law when it comes to firearms
trafficking
which is a
an increasing problem with new hampshire
providing
essentially a flow of guns into
into other states
by not even being able to cooperate with
federal investigations
one of the issues is
the issue isn't guns falling into the
hands of people
who are legally able to own guns you
know we're talking when we're talking
about trafficking
with guns falling into the hands of gang
members felons
and people who are prohibited by our own
law
from actually from actually having guns
um
i i see
um i see that uh potential uh potential
issue issue with it and um
you know i'm i i'm also uh you know
looking at the wording uh which
continues to talk about uh prohibiting
cooperation
um
it's one thing to to actually tell our
law enforcement folks you are not able
to enforce this on your own
um
it's another thing for us to say
you can't cooperate with an ongoing
federal investigation into firearms
trafficking which i think is what this
bill would actually get into
um and if i've if i'm misinterpreting
this uh set me straight but
well
why don't
just
just to clarify
if anyone
whether they're a criminal selling guns
illegally
a licensed firearm dealer or it's a
private
exchange between two people anyone who
transfers a firearm to a person that is
dis prohibited under law disqualified
into law that is a crime
in and of itself so if someone is
giving is someone in new hampshire
is transferring a firearm to someone
who's a felon
that is already against the law in new
hampshire
so this is not encouraging that activity
nor would would
would local officials be prohibited from
assisting in that investigation because
that person is committing a crime in
violation of new hampshire law
we we do spend a lot of time talking
about enforceability in in this
committee and
you know one of the things that we're
you know would be doing would be
essentially taking the teeth out of any
enforcement
mechanism
for firearms trafficking in this state
when was the last firearms trafficking
case prosecuted in the state of new
hampshire representative
you're asking me when the last fight i
do not know well you anecdotally said
that that's a problem here in new
hampshire so i'd like you to support
your allegation with facts not
supposition
and
mr chairman
your statement about
people that's not supposed to have guns
shouldn't have them they can't get them
maybe you'd like to go and tell my two
grandchildren
that that that father who was chief of
police of greenland a little town
they buried him because someone that
wasn't supposed to be have a firearm
shot him
so i mean that's
that
and and all all and i'll just clarify
the comments i'm sorry for what if what
happened with your family
and
all i'm saying is that if anyone were to
transfer a firearm to someone who's not
allowed to have one whether this bill
passes or not that's still a crime out
of new hampshire law and a crime under
federal law so that that issue raised is
not impacted by
uh the house bill 1178 or the amendment
that's already
that should remain illegal because there
is
there is
certain disqualifications in place and
that would even happen in a private
situation if i were to simply gift a
firearm to someone who i was just a
friend of mine if that person's not
allowed to possess one legally i would
be committing a crime even if i didn't
sell it so any type of traffic like that
to felons would be
already illegal and that's the point
that i was trying to make
representative can i just make a point
answer
in response to the idea that like new
hampshire because of its laxed quote
unquote gun laws you know we are our
supplier of guns to other places that's
a frequently made argument around the
country but stop but but and i submit
it's really a fallacy stop and think
about this if the theory is that new
hampshire's gun laws are so lacks
that we're causing the problem in let's
say massachusetts or new york the guns
are going down there well
logically you would think if that was
true if the guns were coming from new
hampshire
there would also be a real problem in
new hampshire it wouldn't just be in
these other states it would be there
would be big crime a big crime problem
in new hampshire or the same thing is
made the same argument is made in you
know indiana indiana supplies all the
guns for uh for chicago but you'd think
that if that were true there would be a
big because that the guns are
originating in indiana there'd be a huge
gun problem in indiana but in fact there
isn't so that's i mean it's no
disrespect to you representative do you
remember that there was six guns found
in massachusetts that were bought in
state of new hampshire
stores debt committee crimes
yes six so this is the huge problem six
it's huge to me
just there is actually
this information is actually published
by the atf
i'm well i know i only read the atf
publication it's called
time to crime and what it took into
consideration was any firearms so it
went state by state
how much time would would go by between
the time the firearm was sold to the to
the point in time where a crime was
committed with that firearm in in new
hampshire the
average time period was over eight and a
half years
between when the crime would occur with
the use of that firearm now that's the
atf public
i didn't fact check that anything beyond
reading the report and i don't have any
problems with guns i own one
but i'm just saying
that out there in the public eye
they wonder what we do besides make laws
about guns and if you don't think this
isn't going to be a newspaper issue it
is and i mean
i i don't i i'll do respect to you guys
and what you think but that's my opinion
i think that we ought to do something
else besides past these things that's
all
representative schultz
thank you sir um two things
uh first on the trafficking piece i
found an interesting quote uh from the
giffords organization which okay throw
the bias at it but uh new hampshire
penalizes any person who
in purchasing or otherwise securing
delivery of a firearm gives false
information or offers false evidence of
his or her identity
new hampshire has no other laws aimed at
firearms trafficking
and to circle back on that issue
of course
gun use is dramatically different in
gary well maybe not gary indiana let's
south bend indiana
versus chicago this could be the same
here
you know
our culture in new hampshire is
basically a neighborhood suburban and
rural
community
the way people use guns i'm from
kentucky i'm i grew up my first 26 years
of life minus college
i spent in kentucky and there
i we
lived uh on meat that my family
uh hunted as when times are tough for
sure so i'm not against guns but it is
definitely
a spurious claim i think that'd be the
right way to put it to say
how can there be trafficking of guns
from new hampshire
to massachusetts that cause any problem
because we'd have a problem here you
cannot compare urban use of guns
to
gun use in concord where i am a state
rep the culture
the
i mean do i really have to explain all
the layers of the of culture i mean
so much is different at an urban
level versus here and i've lived in
washington dc and louisville kentucky
where there is an immense
gun crimes guns are just used
differently
so selling guns here because our laws
are lacks
goes to the greater boston area because
of the way guns are used in trafficking
drugs i don't know did i really have to
spell that out i don't know but
obviously
guns will still be here they're just
used for hunting or self-protection or
sometimes
use in a violent crime for sure but um
you can't you can't dismiss it just
because it doesn't look as ugly we also
have far fewer people by by density of
area than a lot of those places there's
just so many layers of data i could
provide just this is just top of
the top of my head
it's spurious to say therefore
new hampshire doesn't have a gun problem
we would have it just like boston
i just hope that is helpful for you to
think it through
just a small point if if someone from
massachusetts came to new hampshire to
acquire a firearm
the
dealer actually has to not only does
that person have to be in compliance
with new hampshire law they have to
comply with massachusetts law so
massachusetts law let's say they had a
capacity restrict which they have some
regulations on capacity restrictions
when you if someone comes to the store
here
and they show their identification
that the dealer is not going to make the
transaction because it's not the new
hampshire law it's the other states law
there's that too but just right right
off the bat that's
saying that we're trapped we're
supplying the surrounding states yes
yeah that's not
unless that person is is the sale is
also complying with the other state's
law
the still the sale's not supposed to
happen if it does happen that's that is
an illegal sale
from my understanding
um grabs at gun shops lately they may be
massachusetts perpetrators
we know this from the law enforcement
that gather in boston every year or so
often i will admit i'm not an expert on
this or i would have boned up on on this
better but i do know this from
uh sitting at the feet of representative
catherine rogers who knows this issue
well and has attended these meetings and
she's been the only representative from
new hampshire at times and uh law
enforcement official after law
enforcement officials say the majority
of the guns used in
crimes
probably
well i can't say how they obtain them
but i can tell you the guns are coming
from new hampshire
as best they can determine at a much
higher rate than happens in their state
so
that means our gun laws are conducive to
giving guns to massachusetts but it
sounds like you guys
can make this
can you just explain what law
enforcement agency in massachusetts is
blaming new hampshire for massachusetts
uh i know that and i can look this up
but i know that there were multiple
i know the mayor of boston and the state
i believe the state police and other
agencies gathered together and invited
people from new hampshire including
representatives from the governor's
office invited other places because of
this guns and drugs we get the drugs we
give them guns it's basically the way to
water am i the only one that has heard
of this i can't be
this has probably been in testimony
does anybody want to back me up here but
it's definitely
i think let me look let me look this up
for you
come on amy representative green you're
recognized
thank you mr chair
speaking of gun trafficking one of the
largest gun trafficking that was carried
on was by the federal government and
fast and furious
where guns went to mexico and ended up
with a cartel
representative byrd you're recognized
thank you mr chairman and you know
mr chairman
you know i think we're getting way off
track
if anybody
shoots somebody
the local police is going to arrest them
this bill is not going to stop that
if they wave a gun out the window
driving down the road in a road rage the
local police state police are going to
pull that person over and they're going
to arrest them it has nothing to do with
this bill this bill only
tells the feds or the local police that
an executive order or other
federal statutes if they limit magazine
capacity
or ban a certain type of gun
it will tell them
that local police will not enforce the
federal mandate that's it
now if i commit a crime with that
i'm being arrested by the local police
you know this you know it just isn't you
know we're way off topic here
and you know so back to the bill
it's just
we're telling the local police they are
not going to enforce the federal gun
laws or or executive orders
and with that
it's the way it should be
it's the separation we did it with
marijuana
we are
you know
you know a free state here to do
marijuana to appoint
against federal wishes federal wishes
say don't do that and we're not losing
any federal money over it the feds
aren't coming in here and arresting
people over marijuana and
yeah and and i just don't see why we're
so far off topic of what this is
intended to do
thank you
at this time
i think at this time we can at least
move the question whether to adopt the
question is to whether to adopt
amendment number two zero
two two dash bert wallace zero four
seven nine h
if you were in support of adopting the
amendment
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the rule
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
yes representative burt yes
representative lynn yes
representative greene yes clerk votes
yes representative testament yes
representative true yes
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative schultz no
representative panalakas
no
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay no
oh yes sorry okay
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
no representative bolden
representative conley
representative bradley
representative sue newman
no
chairman abbas the chair votes yes
thirteen yays six nays two not voting
that's the amendment
the motion
is adopted representative burt you wish
to make a motion about to pass as
amended yes mr chairman i would like to
make a motion about to pass as amended
thank you
that is seconded by representative
wallace
any comment i mean we kind of going
covering both anyway but have any any
additional comments to be made
seeing none of the matter would now be
put to question
if you support in support of the motion
about the past is amended please say yay
if you're opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll vice chairman roy yes
representative welch yes
representative burt yes representative
lin yes
representative green yes clerk votes yes
representative testament
yes
representative true yay
representative pratt
yes representative marston
yes
no
representative panolakis no
representative o'hearn representative
bordenay
no
representative muse
representative ray newman no
representative bolden representative
conley
yes
representative bradley no
representative sue newman no
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
12 years seven days to not voting
motion about the past is amended
has passed will there be a minority
report
oh you said minority i'm sorry
representative are you preparing the
minority report no there will be a
majority report
no ma'am
representative burt
i assume you'll do the honors yes i'll
have the majority uh written tonight
representative muse
this time we will now close the
executive session
on house bill 1178
yes just next week we we have
uh we have a session on wednesday and
thursday so obviously we won't be here
wednesday morning
uh
friday unless i'm going to leave that
for a subcommittee schedule to be
scheduled that day
so there won't be any
uh public hearings
otherwise so
not to the following week so
but we do have subcommittees this friday
there are subcommittee hearings this
friday so we're and i'm going to put a
subject committee together on
uh hp 1476 and i will email that out to
the committee
representative
i was gonna say a nice things but i'm
taking them all back
representatives
i really like that i know there was that
comment representative lind you may get
a gift card to use on the way home
no it's six o'clock it'll take five
minutes now we're gonna get like a 200
more emails till next oh my god the beat
of the week
it's late though
i'll be here friday
you